PATIENT --
THIS IS --
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW FULL DAY --
WITH A LOT OF THINGS HAPPENING
WE JUST ENDED A SESSION ON THE
FLOOR HONORING WOMEN FOR THE
MONTH --
WHICH TAKES QUITE A BIT OF TIME
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT AND WAITING FOR US --
WE CAN CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER --
PLEASE CALL ROLE [inaudible]
WEBER.
HERE.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY THERE
MELENDEZ STONE.
THANK YOU THAT MEANS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE DON'T HAVE ANY ACTION
ITEMS SO IT'S REALLY ALL OF
PRESENTATION AND INFORMATION.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
ISSUES --
ONE AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO BE
HOPEFULLY AS A BRIEF AN
EXPEDITIOUS AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
THE LATENESS OF THE HOUR IT'S
ALREADY FOUR CLOCK.
AND UP YET THE INFORMATION WE
KNOW IS IMPORTANT I THINK MOST
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE READ THE VARIOUS REPORTS
RELATING TO THE ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US AND HAVE READ
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET SOME OF THAT ON
RECORD BUT ALSO IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR QUESTIONS.
AT THE END OF ALL OF THE ISSUES
OF THE FOUR ISSUES THEN WE WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS WE HOPE THOSE COMMENTS
WILL BE DIRECTED TO WHETHER NOT
ON ISSUES THAT WE MAY NOT HAVE
COVERED.
THAT YOU THINK ARE IMPORTANT IT
SHOULD BE ADDED TO THE RECORD --
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
ONE AND CDC ARE --
WITH THE PLEASE COME FORWARD --
WILL PROVIDE A POPULATION
OVERVIEW A STATUS UPDATE ON AN
OUT OF STATE CONTRACT BIDS AND
WHEN THOSE INDIVIDUAL WE
RETURNING TO CALIFORNIA AND A
PROGRESS UPDATE.
ON PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME A TIME TO BE HERE MY NAME IS.
RALPH THE IS ON THE ACT INSECT
ACTING SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
OF THE CHANGES YOU'VE SEEN AND
WITHIN MY TWENTY YEARS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS --
BUT MAINLY THE FOCUS IS GOING TO
BE ON PROP FIFTY SEVEN THE
REDUCTION OF POPULATION IN A
LITTLE BIT ON PROGRAMMING.
I DO NEED TO SAY BEGIN MY
CURRENT NINETEEN NINETY ONE AS A
YOUNG CORRECTIONAL OFFICER WHEN
THE POPULATION WAS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT SIXTEEN
YEARS LATER WHEN I WAS A
FACILITY CAPITA BALLOON TO ABOUT
A HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND SO
I'VE SEEN THE CAUSES OF
OVERCROWDING MISSING THE IMPACTS.
OF WHAT IT'S DONE IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEMS AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
DURING THAT TIME OF OVERCROWDING
AND WHAT CAN'T BE DONE.
TODAY THE POPULATION IS JUST
UNDER ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND
WE'VE.
MADE THESE THINGS POSSIBLE IN
THE CITY OF THE CALIFORNIA HAVE
VARIOUS WAYS MORE IMPORTANTLY --
BECAUSE OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH GIVE THE
SECRETARY OF CORRECTIONS THE
THIS BROKEN SITUATION PROCESSES
FOR OFFENDERS.
WHO HAVE SERVED THE FULL TERM OF
THEIR PRIMARY FENCE IT ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE SECRETARY TO
AWARD CREDITS FOR INMATES
PARTICIPATION?
AND REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
WHICH PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED
CHANGES IN LAW.
ALSO TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
NONVIOLENT DETERMINE THE
SENTENCE INMATES BECAME ELIGIBLE
FOR PAROLE SUITABILITY HEARING.
BY THE BROUGHT --
BORDER PAROLE HEARINGS ALSO.
CDC ARE SIMPLE AMENDED
REGULATIONS UNDER THE THE
DEPARTMENT WHICH HAS AWARDED
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION CREDITS
WHICH COMES OUT TO OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED NINETY SIX
PRISON YEARS OFFICE SENTENCES.
BASED ON POP AS A FIFTY SEVEN IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO GIVE
A BREAK DOWN WHAT SOME OF THOSE
ARE.
INMATES PARTICIPATED IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY EARN SCHOOL DIPLOMA COLLEGE
DEGREES AND THEY'VE EARNED --
NINE THOUSAND FORTY ONE CREDITS
AND THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY FOURTH --
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
PRISONERS OFFICE SENTENCES.
INMATES PARTICIPATED IN RIGOROUS
CURRICULUM BASED IN PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR TREATMENT
WHICH THEY EARN MILESTONES IN
THE INMATES OF EARNED --
OVER TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND YOUR CREDITS WHICH
COMES TO BUY SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE YEARS OFFICE
SENTENCES.
INMATES PARTICIPATED IN SELF
HELP PROGRAMS LIKE --
AA AND AAA --
GOING OUT TO BUY GOING IN
SHAKESPEARE ACTORS GANG THESE
INMATES UP EARNED OVER FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND NINE
CREDITS WHICH EQUALS TO ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED NINETY YEARS OFF OF
SENTENCES.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED WE ALSO
ALLOW FOR WE ALSO OFFER OVER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
PROGRAMS FOR THE CAN OR IN THESE
CREDITS.
AND THAT EQUATES TO ABOUT AB ONE
THOUSAND SLOTS FOR INMATES TO
PARTICIPATE.
OUR GOAL IS TO OFFER A TOTAL OF
OVER THREE THOUSAND OPPORTUNE
RACK CREDITS IN PROGRAMS WHICH
WILL EXPAND THE SLOTS.
ROSS LOOKING TO CREATE PROGRAMS
FOR INMATES IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
MEDICAL NEEDS TO INCENTIVIZE
PARTICIPATION IN TREATMENT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT IMPLEMENTING
NURSING AND STOP SPONSORED
PATIENT EDUCATION INMATE
ADVISORY GROUPS AT THE
CALIFORNIA SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY.
AND AT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITIES.
ALL THESE NUMBERS MAY SEEM
OPPRESSIVE THE FULL IMPACT
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN I
BELIEVE HAS NOT BEEN SEEN YET.
BECAUSE I LIKE EARLIER
PROPOSITIONS PROPOSITION THIRTY
SIX AND FORTY SEVEN WHICH
IMPACTS --
JUST A SPECIFIC GROUP OF INMATES
IN A PARTICULAR WAY PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN IMPACTS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE INMATE
POPULATION BASED ON A MULTITUDE
OF FACTORS.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT
OFFENDERS --
THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED AS
PROPOSITION TOOK AFFECT HAVE HAD
THEIR SENTENCES REDUCED BY
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
THAT'S THE AVERAGE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN GIVEN
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS THAT
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE
PARTICIPATED BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
CREDITS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
WE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
AMENDING A REGULATIONS. TO
REFINE WHAT WAS CREATED IN THE
IMMEDIATE RESULT OF PROPOSITION --
FIFTY SEVEN TO BE SPECIFIC WE
ARE AMENDING --
THE AMOUNT OF CREDITS
INDIVIDUALS CAN EARN BY
PARTICIPATING IN SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
WE'RE AMENDING IT TO ALLOW NON
VIOLENT --
THE NONVIOLENT PRO PROCESS THIRD
STRIKERS DUE TO RECENT
LITIGATION WHICH IS --
I BELIEVE --
AFTER MUCH DISCUSSION OUR GOAL
IS TO SAFELY EXPAND THESE
OPPORTUNITIES AND EXTEND THEM TO
AS MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN
BENEFIT THEM AS POSSIBLE.
I'M SURE WE ALL MAY BE ASKING AS
TO WHY ON A CONSTANT BASING HOW
DOES THIS AFFECT PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH THESE CHANGES.
RIGHT NOW I CAN SAY IT'S A
LITTLE BIT TOO EARLY BUT I CAN'T
WHAT I CAN SAY IS RECIDIVISM
RATE CONVICTION IN A THREE YEAR
FOLLOW UP PERIOD. FOR INMATES
BEING RELEASED FROM CDC DOLLARS
NOW FORTY SIX POINT 1%.
THAT'S FIVE POINT 4% LOWER THAN
IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AT
THE MAX OF OVERCROWDING.
AND AN EIGHT POINT TWO LOWER
THAN ITS PEAK IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I TAKE TO
HEART --
THAT IN THE VAST CHANGES --
THAT RESEARCH HAS STAYED STABLE.
THE PRISON POPULATION HAS LARGER
PERCENTAGES OF SERIOUS ABOUT AN
OFFENDER SENATE.
OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EARN
THEIR FREEDOM BY WEEKS MONTHS
AND EVEN YEARS THAN OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE IN THE
EARNED IT I NEED TO EMPHASIZE
THAT.
AT THE THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF
THE MOST SERIOUS OFFENDERS --
WE HAVE LIFE HAS BEEN RELEASED
HOWEVER WE ARE CONSTANTLY
WORKING TO IMPROVE THIS RATE TO
ALLOW MORE OFFENDERS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUCCESS UPON
RELEASE.
OUR OFFICE OF RESEARCH HAS
CONDUCTED ASSESSMENTS ON THE
IMPACTS OF SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AND
WE'VE DISCOVERED.
IS THAT THE RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
PAROLEES WITH THE TREATMENT NEED
WHERE RECEIVE IN PRISON
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
TREATMENT WAS THIRTY EIGHT POINT
5%. TO THE FORTY ONE POINT 4%
OFFENDERS WHO DID NOT RECEIVE IN
PRISON AFTER CARE.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THE ONE YOU'RE READ --
ONE YOUR CONVICTION RATE FOR
OFFENDERS WHO HAVE EARNED
EDUCATION MERIT CREDITS HAVE RE --
UPON RELEASE WAS 9% IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALTHOUGH
WE DON'T THAT DOESN'T APPLY AN
APPLES APPLES COMPARISON.
THIS WAS LOWER THAN THE FISCAL
YEAR FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FOR A ONE
YOUR CONVICTION RATE OF EIGHTEEN
POINT.
THREE SO WE ARE SEEING SOME
MOVEMENT IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
FURTHERMORE CITY TERRACE
POPULATION PROJECTS PROJECTIONS
IN THE ADULT INSTITUTIONS
CONTINUE TO DECREASE.
WELL THIS IS ENCOURAGING CHANGES
IN LAW SENTENCING PRACTICES IN A
NUMBEROF OTHER FACTORS CAN
RESULT IN CHANGES TO THESE
PROJECTIONS.
SO WE NEED TO REMOTE WE NEED TO
REMAIN EVER VIGILANT IN
MONITORING THESE PROJECTIONS.
BUT I'D BE REMISS ABOUT AND TAKE
A MOMENT TO REMIND THIS
COMMITTEE THAT CITY SORRY WILL
BE.
SUBJECT TO THE POPULATION CAP TO
STAB MISSION CONTINUES TO BE
SUBJECT TO THE POPULATION CAP BY
THE THREE JUDGE PANEL.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE HAD A
POPULATION UNDER HUNT ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE SERVE
THE MONITOR THE INMATE
POPULATION WE ARE THREE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVEN UNDER
THAT POPULATION CAP.
HOWEVER WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE INMATES LEFT IN ARIZONA.
AND THE GOAL IS. TO HAVE THOSE
INMATES BACK BY JUNE THIRTIETH
OF THIS YEAR.
THE PLAN IS IN THE GOAL IS TO BE
SHIPPING ONE HUNDRED INMATES
BACK TO CALIFORNIA ON A WEEKLY
BASIS WE CAN ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
AND RIGHT NOW I MONITOR THIS
NUMBER ON A DAILY BASIS AND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ON TARGET.
WELL IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT I
SHOULD NOTE THAT --
ONE ONE FAULTY ROOF OR ONE BAD
COURT RULING COULD IMPACT THAT
NUMBER WITH THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
CUSHION ONCE WAS AND IT'S COME
BACK.
AND SO WE TRY AND STAY AHEAD OF
IT OUR FALL POPULATION
PROJECTIONS A PREDICT COURT
COMMITMENTS TO STATE PRISONS
WILL INCREASE ONE POINT 8%.
EXCEPT FOR MARGINAL DECREASE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY COURT
COMMITMENTS ARE PROJECTED TO
INCREASE ZERO POINT 3% EACH YEAR.
FOR THE REMAINDER OF PROJECTION
CYCLES.
I RAISE THIS POINT AS A STEWARD
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION JUST TO
EMPHASIZE THAT --
WE ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF THE
THREE JUDGE PANEL CAP ALSO
IMPLEMENTING POLICY CHANGES AND
EXPANDING PROP FIFTY SEVEN TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
A DECADE AGO ONLY A QUARTER IN
MY POPULATION WAS HOUSE ON LEVEL
TWO FACILITIES.
NOW OVER A THIRD POPULATES ON
LEVEL TWO FACILITIES AND THAT'S
A GOOD THING BECAUSE AT THE
LOWER LEVELS WE HAVE MORE --
POPPING WE HAVE MORE PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THE NUMBER OF INMATES A LONG
TERM RESTRICTED HOUSING IN OUR
OLD SHOES AT ONE POINT WAS --
FOUR THOUSAND NOW RIGHT THE LESS
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED AS OF TODAY.
IN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION'S OUR OUR ADS SAY
EGGS WE WERE AT EIGHT THOUSAND
WE HAVE LESS THAN.
FOUR THESE ARE HIGH SECURITY
BEDS OF HIGH SECURITY STAFFING
NEEDS AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE THOSE.
THIS POINT IS EVEN THOUGH THAT
OUR POPULATIONS NOW EXCLUSIVELY
SERIOUS ABOUT AN OFFENDER'S THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROUD TO SAY THAT
WE ARE HOUSING AS MANY OFFENDERS
AS WE CAN.
IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE BAD AND
ROBUST PROGRAMMING OPPORTUNITIES
AS POSSIBLE.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT --
SOME OF THE EXCITING THINGS ARE
OUT THERE WITH RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ALMOST OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INMATES IN FACE TO FACE COLLEGES.
THEN -- IN
ALL OF OUR THIRTY TWO PRISONS.
ON A MORE BASIC LEVEL TO BE MORE
CRITICAL I MUST NOTE THAT.
47% OF THE POPULATION READ BELOW
IN NINTH GRADE LEVEL WHEN THEY
COME IN.
AND ONLY 38% OF OUR POPULATION
OF HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS OR
EQUIVALENCY THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT WE FOCUS ON LITERACY.
THAT WE FOCUS ON THIS AND THERE
IS A P. C. P. BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION TO
FUND PROGRAMS.
THAT -- IF
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED AIM TO
IMPROVE LITERACY INCLUDING
DIAGNOSTIC A REMEDIAL READING --
COMPUTER BASED LEARNING ENGLISH
THE YOUR MENTORING TRAINING
INMATES TO BE COACHES --
TO WRAP IT UP BUT I ALSO LIKE TO
SAY THAT --
NINETY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
PRESIDENTS HAVE BEEN DELEGATED
BACK TO CDC ARE --
FROM THE FEDERAL RECEIVER THAT
PUTS US AT ABOUT 50%.
I LOOK CLOSELY I WORKED CLOSELY
WITH MR KELSO AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER PROGRESS.
I'M ALSO WORKING ON A FEW ISSUES
THAT ARE NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART THE AXIS OF FAMILIES --
TO HAVE TO THEIR LOVED ONES IN
OUR STATE PRISONS.
HI VANCE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS TO CONVENE A
STATEWIDE TRAINING. TO IMPROVE
OUR VISITING PROCESSES FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND VISITORS
THAT COME IN TO OUR PRISONS.
SO WE CAN ACCOMMODATE THEM
BETTER AND WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
VISIT EXPERIENCE FOR THEM.
I'VE ALSO TEST THE DIVISION OF
ADULTS INSTITUTION IMPROVING OUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE AT THE
INSTITUTIONS.
SO FAMILY MEMBERS CAN BE CALLING
THE INSTITUTIONS AND CHECKING UP
IN RECEIVING POSITIVE AND DIRECT
INFORMATION ON THEIR LOVED ONES.
ALSO WHY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT CITIES YOURS OVERHAULING IN
MANY WAYS --
HOW WE MANAGE OUR TRANS GENDER
POPULATIONS --
I BELIEVE WE ARE AHEAD OF THE
NATION IN THAT RESPECT AND THEN --
I BELIEVE WE ARE HEAD OF WHAT --
I BELIEVE CORRECTIONS IS
PROVIDING PUBLIC SAFETY I KNOW
THAT -- WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AND CALENDAR RIGHT
THERE BECAUSE I COULD HAVE A FEW
MORE BULLETS BUT ALL AND IT FOR
TEMPORARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY COMMENTS
FROM -- LA --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
KEY ON ON YOU KNOW WITH THE LA --
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCLUDE --
THE ANTICIPATED A FAX OF TWO
RECENT POLICY CHANGES IN THE
POPULATION RELATED BUDGET
REQUESTS AND PROJECTIONS THAT IT
SUBMITS OF THE MAY REVISION.
AND THOSE ARE THE THOSE POLICY
CHANGES ARE AT THE RECENT
CHANGES TO CREDIT EARNING CALLED
POLICIES THAT THE SECRETARY
MENTIONED.
AS WELL SEE THIS YEAR AS EFFORTS
TO PROPOSE INMATES FOR
SENTENCING REDUCTIONS --
AND THEN WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
STATUTE DIRECTING CDC ARE TO
REPORT ON ITS RATIONALE FOR AN
ESTIMATED POPULATION --
IMPACT OF FUTURE CHANGES COMING
FROM A FINANCE.
OKAY WANT TO THANK THE FACT THAT
THE NET KNOWLEDGE THAT ARE CHAIR
OF THE BUDGET FILL TING HAS
JOINED.
US TODAY SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
OKAY NOT YET OKAY SOME OKAY --
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS
WITH REGARDS TO THE ILLEGAL OF
HIS ME CVC OUR PROJECTIONS.
OKAY WE GO TO ISSUE TO WHICH IS
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
RECENT.
AUDIT ALL OF ITS OWN CDC OURS WE
BILLET TATIAN PROGRAMMING AND
DEPARTMENT --
AND THE DEPARTMENT'S RESPONSE.
ALL THIS STILL INVOLVE CDC ARE
THIS IS THE CONCERNING THE AUDIT
REPORT ON REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING THAT'S RIGHT OKAY --
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIN FELDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
I WAS THE SUPERVISOR ON THIS YOU
SEE OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AUDIT AND I'LL BE
GOING OVER THE SOME OF THE
FINDINGS RACKS AND ESSENTIALLY
THE AUDIT WAS TASKED WITH
REVIEWING --
NOT ONLY COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY BUT ALSO ACADEMIC AND
VOCATIONAL THERAPIES --
EDUCATION AT CDC ARE.
NOW THE PRIMARY FINDING WE HAD
CONCERNED --
CPT AND THE FACT THAT.
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
DIDN'T WE FIND RESULTS AND
REDUCTIONS IN RECIDIVISM.
SPECIFICALLY WE ANALYZE TWO
GROUPS OF AN MASON THIS IS HOW
YOU REACH THAT CONCLUSION --
THE FIRST GROUP OF INMATES WERE
RELEASED IN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
THOSE INMATES.
HAD BEEN ASSESSED AS NEEDING
SOME CBT PROGRAMS AT A COMPLETED
AT LEAST HALF OF THOSE.
THE OTHER --
GROUP OF INMATES ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED AND BOTH GROUPS WERE
ALSO RELEASED IN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
HOWEVER THOSE INMATES I HAD
RECEIVED.
NONE OF THE ATTENDED AND NOT
COME HIGHER TO RELEASE --
AFTER TWO YEARS WE LOOKED AT THE
RECIDIVISM RATES FOR BOTH GROUPS
AND FOUND THAT THEY WERE THE
SAME ESSENTIALLY 2425%
RESPECTIVELY [inaudible]
NOW THAT.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT IT DOES
NOT APPEAR THAT I THAT --
THE CPT CLASSES HAD AN EFFECT ON
REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
WE WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT --
IT'S DUE TO CDC OURS FAILURE TO
PROPERLY ADMINISTER THESE
PROGRAMS THE LEAD TO THEIR
LIMITATION OF THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS.
NOW -- WE
CAN WITH THE THREE MAIN AREAS
THAT SEEM TO REALLY BE IMPACTING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE FIRST WAS --
THAT CITY C. R. REQUIRES ALL OF
ITS VENDORS TO TEACH THE CVT
PROGRAMS OUT OF CITY PROGRAMS
JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
COGNITIVE --
SORRY --
CRIMINAL CRIMINOLOGICAL THINKING.
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS AND ANGER
MANAGEMENT.
THERE WAS SOME OF THE VENDORS
THAT ARE TEACHING THESE PROGRAMS
THEY'RE ALL REQUIRED TO USE
EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULUM
CROOKLYN THAT'S PROVEN TO WORK
HOWEVER WE FOUND IT THAT INTEND
THE PRISONS WE REVIEWED. 20% OF
THE CURRICULUM HAD NOT BEEN
VETTED TO ASSURE THAT IT WAS
EFFECTIVE.
YEAH THIS IS CRITICAL.
IF YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
ANIMATE TO ATTEND A PROGRAM YOU
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PROGRAM IS PROVEN TO WORK.
SO -- WE
RECOMMENDED THAT CDC AND GOING
FORWARD ENSURE THAT.
THE A CREEK --
PRACTICE MORE ACTIVE OVERSIGHT.
THE SECOND MAJOR ISSUE WE
IDENTIFIED WAS IN TERMS OF THE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS INMATES ARE
GIVEN.
FOR RIGHT WHEN THEY ENTER
FACILITY THERE'S A COMPASS AND
CS ALREADY ASSESSMENTS THOSE
EVALUATED INMATES REHABILITATIVE
NEEDS OVER THE NEED AT AT MARCH
CATION PROGRAMS ANGER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. FOR THE FULL GAMUT OF
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES OFFERED
BY CDC ARE --
THE CSR A IS A VALUE WITH
RESPECT TO THE MAJOR CITY IN THE
FUTURE.
EVERY FOR THAT THOSE ASSESSMENT
TOOLS HADN'T BEEN REEVALUATED
INTENDED FIFTEEN YEARS
RESPECTIVELY EVEN THOUGH THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE INMATE
POPULATION IT CHANGE PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY NOW YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ASSESSMENTS
ARE ACCURATE.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU SAYS AN
INMATE IS NEEDING --
A CERTAIN CLASS WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ACTUALLY NEED THAT AND
ALSO THAT WHEN WHICH YOU'RE NOT
MISSING ANY CRITICAL NEED FOR
THESE INMATES.
AND A CITY SEARS INMATE.
ELECTION HAS CHANGED PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY SINCE PROP.
FORTY SEVEN FINALLY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CDC ARE IS --
FAILING TO PROPERLY PRIORITIZE
INMATES INTO.
THESE PROGRAMS OFF OF THE WAIT
LIST.
SO WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT CITY
SERVICE CAN --
RISK LOW NEED IN BATES INTO
THESE PROGRAMS WHEN SLOTS BECAME
AVAILABLE SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
WERE ASSIGNED TO ANY OTHER
ACTIVITY.
AND THAT THAT'S HOW THE
WEIGHTLESS FOR PRIORITIZING THEM --
INSTEAD OF THESE HIGH RISK HIGH
NEED IN BATES THAT WERE MADE
ENGAGED IN ACTIVITIES LIKE --
SOUNDS KEEPING OR IN THE WORKING
IN THE KITCHEN.
YOU KNOW THEY COULD HAVE A
TRANSFER THESE WERE
REHABILITATIVE ACTIVITIES THEY
WERE ENGAGED IN AND THE NEEDED
THESE PROGRAMS BUT INSTEAD THEY
WERE LEFT WHERE THEY WERE AND
LOW RISK LOW NEED INMATES --
SORRY LOOK RISK LIVE NEED
INMATES WERE --
PUT IN INSTEAD.
WE THINK THIS CONTRIBUTED TO
SOME --
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL --
LOW ENROLLMENT NUMBERS FOR THE
CITIES YOUR PRIMARY DEMOGRAPHIC
WHICH IS YOU GET --
INMATES WITH RSS WITHOUT
MODERATE TO HIGH NEED.
IN ANY PROGRAM THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY THEY PUT IN.
NOW WE'VE MADE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR ALL THE THINGS THAT I'VE
JUST DISCUSSED BUT WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO IMPLEMENT
OVER.
A PLAN THAT WE'VE DESCRIBED IN A
REPORT.
NOW THIS PLAN WOULD REQUIRE CDC
ARE TO CONTRACT WITH AN EXTERNAL
RESEARCHER SUCH AS UC IRVINE --
OR ANY OTHER OUTSIDE RESEARCH
WITH LARGE RESEARCH ENTITY AND
THAT THAT ENTITY WITHIN CONDUCT
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
BECAUSE OUR PRELIMINARY ANALYSIS
TO SEE BRITISH DOESN'T APPEAR TO
CHAU RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
ATTENDING THESE CLASSES AND
REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
BUT WE NEED TO SEE HOW A
VOCATIONAL IT EDUCATION IMPACT
THESE RECIDIVISM RATES.
BECAUSE THE GOAL IS. TO HAVE
THIS FISCAL YEAR CDC OUR
CONTRACT WITH --
A RESEARCH ENTITY HAVE THE IT'S
A TO CONDUCT THAT WORK AND THEN
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THAT CITY'S
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK AT WHAT'S
INEFFECTIVE.
AND START ELIMINATING THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THEN EXPANDING
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY ARE
PROVN TO WORK OR COMBINATIONS
THEREOF --
THAT'S THE KIND OF HIGH LEVEL
FINDINGS RECOMMENDATIONS THE
REPORT NOW FREE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM HELLO.
FIND THAT.
BECAUSE MORE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
FIND THAT THIS REPORT IS
GENERALLY IN LINE WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT ON IMPROVING IN
PRISON REHABILITATION --
THIS INCLUDES TO RECOMMENDING A
THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION LOOK AT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAMS
OFFERED BY THE CDC OR ANYONE
FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
ANYONE THE CITY OUR RESPONSE.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY.
MY NAME IS BRENT CHOATE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
FOR C. C. R..
AS NOTED IN THE AUDIT REPORT.
CDC ARE AGREES WITH THE FINDINGS
AND WILL WORK TO FIND REMEDY TO
WEAKNESS TO WITNESSES AND
BARRIERS TO SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PROGRAMMING.
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
I UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL ROLE
THAT I PLAY.
IN ENSURING THE BEST USE OF
STATE FOR DANCE BOTH PRISON AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
MY TEAM WAS AWARE OF THE ISSUES.
DESCRIBED IN THE AUDIT.
AND BEGAN DEVELOPING REMEDIES
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHEN THE NEW D. R. P.
OR DIVISION REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS TEAM WAS APPOINTED.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE OUR
CURRENT EFFORTS TO IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION AN EXTRACTION.
PRIORITIZE PLACEMENT INTO
PROGRAMMING.
AND CREATE PERFORMANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FIDELITY
MEASURES [inaudible]
MORE SPECIFICALLY.
WE HAVE ALREADY BEGUN OR
COMPLETED THE PROCESS OF IF I
AWAITING CDC OURS CURRENT RISK
IN THESE ASSESSMENT TOOL.
ANALYSIS OF COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
TREATMENT CURRICULUM TO ENSURE
IS EVIDENCE BASED.
MADE CHANGES TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
STRATEGIC FENDER.
AMANDA ADMITS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SONGS. TO
AUTOMATE PROGRAM WAITING LISTS
BASED ON RISK AND NEED.
WE'VE ALSO MET WITH UNIVERSITIES
AND OTHER RESEARCHERS TO BEGIN
THE RESEARCH DESIGN FOR AN
EFFECTIVE LONGITUDINAL
RECIDIVISM STUDY.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO FINDING
SOLUTIONS TO LOOK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING PERIODIC
UPDATES. TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
REQUESTED.
HELP YOU DECIDE AN INSTITUTION
IT'S GOING TO BE MONITORING YOU
SAY IT.
RESEARCH INSTITUTION EVEN SIDE
ONLY NOT TODAY WE'VE SPOKEN WITH
A COUPLE OF AND WERE WERE STILL
WORKING ON THAT.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
YES MY SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
JUST A COUPLE QUESTIONS AT THE
GUY VISITED ALL OF YOUR
FACILITIES BEGAN TO A FEW OF
THEM.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE.
SOME DIFFERENCES IN THE
FACILITIES WITH WHAT'S AVAILABLE
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU EXACTLY PROVIDE.
BUT BASED ON OTHER PROXIMITY IS
THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
FUNDED OR RUN BY --
PEOPLE WHO ARE NEARBY AS OPPOSED
TO SOME OF THE THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE FURTHER AWAY.
IT WAS A LITTLE HARD TO PARSE
OUT SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES FROM
ONE INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER.
BUT ARE YOU FINDING
CONSISTENCIES I GUESS THIS IS
BOTH FOR THE AUDITOR AS FOR CDC
ARE.
SOME OF THESE INCONSISTENCIES
BASED ON LOCATIONS OR BASED ON
SITES OR IS.
COULD ALL OF THIS TRUE KIND OF
ACROSS THE BOARD.
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT THAT IT IS
TRUE ACROSS THE BOARD --
WE DO HAVE.
THAT ALL THE PRISONS DO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
PROGRAMMING THAT'S GOING ON THE
THE MAJORITY THE PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY STATE CIVIL SERVANTS
THAT ARE PAID.
THROUGH STATE FUNDS THOSE WOULD
BE OUR CLASSROOM TEACHERS.
AND THE WE HAVE CONTRACTORS AS
WELL THAT PROVIDE ALL OF THE
KIND OF BE ABLE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS.
SO THAT'S A SMALLER PORTION OF
WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS IS ACTUALLY LITERACY AND
IN PREPARATION TOWARD COLLEGE
PROGRAMS.
RIGHT ALTHOUGH SOME AND SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT I'VE GONE IN
TO SEE THAT ARE. FOR MORE
LOCALLY LACKS ADEQUATE AND AND
AND A FEW OTHERS WHICH HAVE SOME
PRETTY INTERESTING INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS A LOT OF WHICH HAVE TO
DO MORE WITH THE THERAPEUTIC
COMPONENT ADD.
SOME OF THE THAT.
I GUESS MORE INDEPTH QUESTIONING
THAT SOME OF THE INMATES GO
THROUGH AS AS WAYS TO START TO
APPROACH GETTING THEMSELVES
READY TO BE ABLE TO GO BECAUSE A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS WHO COME IN.
TRAUMATIZED AND COME IN WITH
WITHOUT SOME BASIC.
COGNITIVE ABILITIES THAT MAY NOT
BE READY TO GO INTO A SCHOOL
PROGRAM A GOING TO BE REALLY
READY.
TO THAT APPROACH THE PROGRAMMING
THAT'S THERE AND I THINK THAT
MAYBE THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
BUT IT'S IT'S SORT OF SEEING
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE GET
TO SEE AND SOME OF THE DAY TO
DAY PROGRAMS THAT THERE JUST
SEEMS TO BE SOME DIFFERENCES.
SITE TO SITE.
AND IF ALL OF THE INMATES ARE
REALLY READY. TO TO GO INTO THE
PROGRAMS AND OVERCOME SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT THEY NEED TO
OVERCOME TO BE.
REALLY READY TO LEARN AND
WILLING TO TO TAKE ON THAT THE
EXPLORATION THAT THEY NEED TO GO.
BECAUSE IF WE JUST PUT PEOPLE IN
CLASSROOMS TO PUT PEOPLE IN
CLASSROOMS WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO SIX EXCEPT THAT I KNOW
YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT HOW DO WE ADDRESS THOSE.
DEEPER ISSUES THAT SOME OF THEM
NEED TO DO BECAUSE IT THERE.
READING LEVELS ARE VERY LOW.
THE ABILITY TO INTERACT
SOMETIMES OFTEN VERY LOW.
THAT TRAUMA SO THEY COME IN WITH
THAT ARE ON THAT WITH THE BECOME
SOMETIMES BARRIERS. TO REALIZING
WHAT IS GOING TO HELP OR NOT
GONNA HELP FROM SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
THE SCHOOL.
LEARNING ABILITIES ARE VERY LOW
EVEN AS WERE SORT OF STRUGGLING
WITH.
OR WORKING WITH WITH YOU ON THE
THE COPAYS AND SORT OF MEDICAL
ABILITIES THAT MEDICAL LITERACY
IS VERY LOW AND SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT.
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS EQUIPPED TO
DEAL WITH LIFE IN IN VARIOUS
WAYS AND SOMETIMES WE NEED TO
TAKE TO GET THEM TO THAT STEP IN
ORDER TO THAN TO GO INTO.
INTO CLASSROOMS AND SO IN SOME
OF THE FACILITIES THERE'S AN
ATTEMPT TO DO THAT AND OTHERS
THAT I'VE SEEN.
NOT ALWAYS AS MUCH I'M TRYING TO
FIND.
A COMMON DENOMINATOR REALLY
UNDERSTAND.
THAT IN THE WAY THAT PROGRAMS
GET DELIVERED.
YOU WANNA COME I COULD JUST
COMIC QUICKLY IF WE DID FIND
THAT CITY TO SEE OUR HAD
EXPANDED.
BASIC C. B. T. TO ALL VISITS
HOWEVER THERE ALL THE I THINK WE
ARE FOR JUST HAVE THESE
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS THESE MORE
LOCALIZED PROGRAMS.
WE'VE RECOMMENDED THAT --
IF YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH NO ANALYSIS
IS BEEN DONE TO DEMONSTRATE
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS YET.
THAT IS PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY CDC ARE SELECT SEVERAL
PROMISING LOOKING VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS AND LOOK AT HOW WELL
THEY'RE REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND
THEN CONSIDER EXPANDING KNOWS IF
THEY DO WORK WELL.
SO I THINK THE IDEA OF KIND OF
DOING SOME DUE DILIGENCE TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
EFFECTIVE AND THEN --
EXPANDING THAT IF IT'S IF IT
SEEMS WORTHWHILE.
AND AND THAT'S A KIA AT THINK
THE THE UNDERLYING POINT AS WELL.
SOMETIMES WE WE LOVE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED THERE'S AN EXTERNAL
FUNDING SOURCE OR SOME SORT OF A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM THAT COMES IN.
MAY NOT ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE
AND FOR US.
GET OUT OF WE NEED TO GET OUTOF
THE MODE OF JUST.
DOING PROGRAM FOR SIGNATURE
PROGRAM LOOK AT AFFECT THIS AND
LOOK AT WHAT'S REALLY.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THOSE ON
THE INSIDE SO THAT THAT'S GOING
TO END UP PRODUCING THE
RECIDIVISM AND THAT'S THE END
GOAL.
SOME OF THESE FOLKS WILL END UP
FOR SEDATING BUT THE MORE WE CAN
PREVENT THAT AND THE MORE WE WE
CAN POINT TO DIRECT SIGNIFICANT
RESULTS AND THE BAD.
WE'RE HAVIN A MUCH DEEPER IMPACT
ON RECIDIVISM A PRISON
POPULATIONS BACK IN COMMUNITIES
THAT.
IN A WAY THAT WE KNOW ARE GOING
TO BE PRODUCTIVE TO THAT
COMMUNITY AND KEEP THAT HELP
KEEP THAT COMMITTEE SAFER RATHER
THAN.
GOING BACK TO THE LIFESTYLE THAT
THAT THEY HAD COME IN AND SO
THAT EFFECTIVENESS THAT LOOKING
AT THE BROUGHT THE PROGRAMS THAT
THAT AND HOW THEY THE
INTERACTIVE THINK IS.
ULTIMATELY PORT.
YES I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING AND AND I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
THAT -- AS
YOU STATED THE ECONOMY HERE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS HAVE OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS EXPANDED FROM
LITERALLY THIRTEEN PRISON YARDS.
NOT THIRTEEN PRISON BUT THIRTEEN
PRISON YARDS TO EVERY YARD IN
EVERY PRISON SO THE THE
EXPANSION EFFORT HAS BEEN HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANT THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH --
AS WELL AS WE ARE AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT.
THAT THE METROPOLITAN AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A PRISON NEARBY
THEY SUPPLY QUITE A VOLUNTEER
FORCE AND AND THERE IS LIKE A
SAN QUENTIN OR SOLANO OR
LANCASTER STATE PRISON.
THEY MAY HAVE A GREATER
VOLUNTEER FORCE SO FOR THIS
REASON THROUGH THE HELP OF THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WE HAVE.
BEEN IMPLEMENTING THE INNOVATIVE
GRANT PRO.
A COUPLE.
HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT WERE OUT
THERE BEFORE ME THEY WERE IN
SOME OF THE METROPOLITAN AREAS
BUT THEY'VE NOW EXPANDED. TO THE
LESS POPULATED PRISONS.
ABOUT BUT WE ALSO REALIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF VALIDATING AND
VERIFYING THAT THAT THEY
ACTUALLY WORK.
RIGHT RIGHT AND AND THAT'S GOOD
AND THAT'S THE THE PART THAT WAS
A LITTLE HARD.
TO THE FOR ME TO KIND OF PARTS
OUT WHERE.
ALL OF THE THE PROGRAMS WORK
SAID THAT HAS BEEN OR AND I KNOW
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS LOOKED
AT IS.
IS JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE A LOT OF
VOLUNTEERS NEARBY THERE'S A
BENEFIT TO THAT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE IMPLEMENTING THE
SAME LEVEL OF IMPACTED AND ALL
OF OUR FACILITIES.
GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING THROUGHOUT ASK.
YES MISTER CHANG.
ON A COUPLE OF QUICK QUESTIONS
TO JUST TO CLARIFY FROM THE
AUDITOR AND THE ONLY RECOGNITION
YOU MENTIONED WAS JUST. TO TO
FURTHER EVALUATION OR TO HAVE
SOME EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM'S --
NO NO THAT'S NOT CORRECT WE HAVE
A VARIETY OF RECOMMENDATIONS --
TOWARD CDC ARE FOR THEM TO
IMPLEMENT A FIX.
THE ISSUES THAT I BROUGHT UP
DURING REPRESENTATION BUT ALSO --
TO HAVE TO RESTATE THOSE
SLIGHTLY --
SO CONCERNING --
THAT WITH THE WAIT LIST ISSUE AN
INSERT THAT THEIR PRIORITIZING
INMATES CORRECTLY --
TO DAVE PROVIDES THERE --
THE REVISED THOSE WEIGHTLESS AND
ISSUE DO POLICY DIRECTIVES SO
YOU CAN ENSURE THAT.
THE INMATES WITH THE HIGHEST
NEEDS HIRES HIGHEST RISK FOR
GETTING INTO THOSE OPEN SLOTS --
BOB PRACTICE ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT OVER THE CONTRACTING
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
CONTRACT ALL OF THE C. B. T.
VENDORS ARE TEACHING CLASSES
THAT ARE EVIDENCE BASED.
AND AB OF REALITY THEIR
ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
IN ADDITION WE'VE ALSO MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS --
FOR LIKE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
CDC R. E. D. D. CAN SHARE. FOR
INFORMATION SUCH AS SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS THAT WILL ALLOW
YOU DD AND CDC ARE TO DETERMINE
HOW EFFECTIVE THE VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS ARE BECAUSE THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO TRACK IN WEEKS AFTER
RELEASE TO DETERMINE IF THEY
HAVE -- JEFF
THEY FOUND JOBS IN THE FIELD
THAT THEY WERE TRAINED.
WE HAVE ADDED A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS ON OUR PART
THESE INCLUDE IN CHINA THAT ALL
PROGRAMS ARE EVIDENCE BASED AND
EXTENT THAT.
THIS DEPARTMENT TO DO SOMETHING
INNOVATIVE WITH LEGISLATURE WENT
THROUGH SOMETHING INNOVATIVE TO
DO IT ON A PILOT BASIS THAT WE
CAN TEST THE EFFECTIVENESS OF IT --
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED TARGETING
THE HIGHEST FIRST CAUGHT SNEAD --
OFFENDERS FOR PROGRAMS THIS IS A
LOT NORTH RESEARCH IN THE FIELD --
AND ALSO RE RECOMMENDED
IMPROVING OVER TIME THE PROGRAMS
USING PERFORMANCE MEASURES
[inaudible]
AND TOM.
GIVEN THE COMMON.
LACK OF EVALUATION OF THE
CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE YOU AWARE
OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT EXIST.
IN THIS UNIVERSE THAT HAVE BEEN
EVALUATED.
YEAH THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
EVALUATED FOR COST EFFECTIVENESS
AND OUR SON --
DATABASES OUT THERE ARE OF
PROGRAM TO HAVE BEEN TESTED FOR
EFFECTIVENESS --
I WOULD ADD THAT IN ADDITION TO
MAKING FOR THE PROGRAM IS
RESOURCE BASE AS BEEN PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE ELSEWHERE.
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED WITH FIDELITY
HILL OR TO INSURE THAT ACT ON
THE FACT.
ANSWER FIFTY DELIVERY --
TO ENSURE THAT THAT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED A IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THAT PROGRAM IT'S BEEN
BASED OFF OF THAT IT'S TIME THAT
SENT FAX HERE.
IN IN THE PROGRAM'S YOUR FRONT
DOOR ARE PROBLEMS THAT ARE NOT
IN CALIFORNIA BUT OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA --
SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
BY CALIFORNIA BUT YEAH GENERALLY
WITH THE EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM
TO GO LOOK FOR A PROGRAM THAT
HAS BEEN TESTED ELSEWHERE OR ARE
GOING TO JAIL OR PRISON IN
ANOTHER STATE OR A COUNTY.
AND THAT ADOPTED HER.
SO IT WOULD YOUR WOULD YOUR
RECOMMENDATION BE TO NOT.
TO FURTHER INVESTMENT IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND TELL OTHERS
EVALUATION --
WE HAVE NOT GOT.
THE TO THAT LEVEL ON THE
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
WAS A I'M NOT A CHARLOTTE THAT
WHY WE DON'T GO TO THAT LEVEL I
WOULD SAY THAT --
WE RECOMMENDED THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FUNDED OUR EVIDENCE
BASED.
ROAD AND SAY THEY CANCEL THE
PROGRAMS ARE IN EXISTENCE.
BE A PROGRAMS ARE EVIDENCE BASED
AND WE DON'T HAVE A EVALUATION
PROGRAM SO HOT WHY WOULD WE
CONTINUE.
TO MAINTAIN THESE CONTRACTS
UNTIL WE HAVE EVIDENCE --
ALL.
TO FORTY WELL WILL NOTE THAT THE
THE DAUGHTER FOUND THAT 80% OF
THE PROGRAMS WERE EVIDENCE BASED.
AND THE OTHER 20%.
WE CONSIDER THEM ACTUALLY
EVIDENCE BASED BUT THEY JUST
WEREN'T FOUND WITHIN THE P. --
TO THE PEW CLEARING HOUSE.
SO I APOLOGIZE I GUESS TO THE
THE SAMPLE SIZE THAT HE REFERRED.
TO HIM TO TO SAMPLE SIZES AND
APOLOGIZED AND PLAYED IN THE
YEARS ON SEVENTEEN FIVE AND ONE
WAS EIGHTEEN SO --
I'VE SO WE LOOKED AT TWO
DIFFERENT GROUPS AND THAT WAS --
FOR CPT ACTUALLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM --
BUT THE WELL I WAS DISCUSSING A
LITTLE BIT LATER WAS THAT THE
TEN PRISONS WE LOOKED AT WE
LOOKED AT THE CURRICULUM OF CVT
AT EACH AND WHETHER THAT WAS
EVIDENCE BASED.
AND WE FOUND THAT IT ONLY 17%.
I'M SORRY I WE HAVE ROUGH
ROUGHLY 20% WERE NOT EVIDENCE
BASED SO OF THE CURRICULUM THAT
WAS OFFERED AT THOSE PRISONS.
MANY OF THEM WERE FOUND TO BE IN
THE TIãU DATABASE THAT YOU
DIDN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE OF THEM
BEING SUCCESSFUL.
WELL WE WE LOOKED VISIT LOOKS AT
AUDLEY AT AT A AT A SAMPLE OF
INMATES FOR THE WERE RELEASED IN.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WHETHER THEY
WERE EVIDENCE BASED OR NOT WE
DIDN'T FIND THAT THE CVT
PROGRAMS THEY OFFERED APPEAR TO
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH A
REDUCED RATE OF RECIDIVISM HE
DIDN'T DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
EVIDENCE BASED ARE.
NOT EVIDENCE BUT THERE WERE
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH --
PRESENT AT THE TIME THAT KIND OF
HAD THAT --
THE POPULATION BIG ENOUGH FOR US
TO DO THAT ANALYSIS WE DID
CONTROL FOR THE PRUDENT TO BOTHGROUPS OF INMATES. FOR RACE AGE
EDUCATION AND CRIMINALITY YOUR
CONCLUSION WAS BASED ON THE
PROGRAM AND THAT WAS OFFERED YOU
TO FIND ANY EVIDENCE THAT THEY
WERE SUCCESSFUL.
THAT.
SO I'M JUST GOING BACK TO SEE
YOU SEE ARE YOU SAID YOU'VE BEEN
AWARE OF THESE SITUATIONS SINCE.
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND YOU LISTED A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT YOU'VE DONE ONE OF
THE KEY CRITIQUES WAS THE LACK
OF EVALUATION YET --
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THERE
CONTINUES TO BE. TO CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT EVALUATING BUT NOT
HAVING DONE IT JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHY IT'S TAKEN MORE THAN A YEAR
AND A HALF TO DO THAT.
WELL THE OVER THE PAST. TWO AND
A HALF BEEN FOCUSED ON BRINGING
PROGRAMS UP.
AND BRING THEM BACK TO WITHOUT
OR THE WITHOUT HAVING A PLAN TO
EVALUATE THE SUCCESS WE WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD A PLAN TO EVALUATE
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A PROGRAM IN
PLACE BEFORE WE CAN EVALUATE IT.
AND AN ENGLISH AND USUALLY WHEN
YOU PUT A PROGRAM PLACE YOU HAVE
BEEN EVALUATION PROTOCOL.
WHEN YOU DO THAT SAID THAT BUT
THAT DIDN'T OCCUR YOU'RE SAYING?
THAT IS CORRECT.
SO.
KNOWING THIS ISSUE EXISTED A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS LATER WHERE DO IN THIS
EVALUATION.
AS I STATED EARLIER WE HAVE
SPOKEN WITH WITH A COUPLE
DIFFERENT UNIVERSITIES.
AND TALKED ABOUT WHAT THIS
EVALUATION MIGHT LOOK LIKE --
THERE ARE THERE ARE MANY
COMPLEXITIES TO VIOLATIONS SUCH
AS THIS BECAUSE YOU YOU CAN'T
JUST EVALUATES.
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA PROGRAM
MORE CBT PROGRAM INDEPENDENTLY
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE FOLKS HAVE
WELL CALL CO CURRENT ISSUES.
AND SO HOW DO YOU KNOW IN
REALITY THAT IT WAS THE CVT
PROGRAM THAT WORKED AS OPPOSED
TO THE FACT THAT THEY HAD A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR A A DEGREE.
AND SO IT'S A VERY SOPHISTICATED
STUDY THE NEEDS TO BE DONE
[inaudible]
SO ON HE YOU YOU GOT AN ORDER
SAYING THAT.
THE AUDITOR'S NOT CONVINCED THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING OUR SUCCESSFUL.
SO WHY CONTINUE TO DO THEM ONE I
CAN NEW ONES.
I HAVEN'T I HAVE AN AUDITOR I
KNOW IT'S GOING TO JUMP IN YOU
CAN JUMP IN ANYTIME WELL WHEN
THE CLAIM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT AT THE TIME OF THE THE
DATA THAT THEY LOOK AT FOR THE
AUDIT WAS AND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN REHABILITATION
PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT IS IS DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN GETTING THAT
OUT TO ALL THE INSTITUTIONS --
THE CURRICULA THEY PICK AS
PRIMARILY SCHISM IN THE AUDIT
WAS THAT THE WHAT THE CURRICULUM
IS EVIDENCE BASE.
SOME PORTION OF IT IS NOT
WITHOUT ACTUALLY BEING TAUGHT TO
THEY WERE USING THE CURRICULUM
THE EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULUM IN
THE INSTITUTIONS.
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
CONCERN WITH THE EVALUATION IN
TERMS OF HOW IT AFFECTS THE THE
POPULATION MOVING FORWARD AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY BUT IT
REDUCES RECIDIVISM.
BUT AGAIN WE'RE NOW LIKE
INTERVIEW WE ARE IN OUR THIRD
YEAR OF SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO START SEEING
THOSE CHANGES IN THE NEXT THREE
TO FIVE YEARS AS THAT POPULATION
TAKES FULL ADVANTAGE.
OF ALL THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS BOTH C. B. T.
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
EDUCATION.
THIS WILL GIVE ME ONE SECOND SO
Gí
SAID YOU'VE DONE ON AFRICA THE
WORD YOU USE BUT AN EXCELLENT
JOB.
THAT'S BASED ON WHAT.
DOES THE SIMPLE FACT OF BEING
ABLE -- TO
ROLL OUT ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE AS A DIRECTOR CHUCK
MENTIONED THEY WERE IN THIRTEEN
YARDS AND NOW THEY ARE STATEWIDE
THEY ARE PROVIDING.
THESE.
THEY HAVE THE SLOTS AVAILABLE
THEY ARE PROVIDING THE THERAPIES
AND TREATMENTS TO THE I MEAN IT.
CONSIDERING THE NUMBER OF
INSTITUTIONS NUMBER OF INMATES
THAT WERE SERVING AND OF THE
COMPLEXITY IS GIVEN THE
DIFFERENT SECURITY NEEDS EACH
INSTITUTION.
I WOULD CONSIDER IT SUCCESSFUL
THAT THEY HAVE ANY RUNNING OUT
TO TO IT MAKES.
BUT WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE ONE WITH
THE OTHER WHETHER THEY'RE
ACTUALLY REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
AND AND AGAIN.
WE ARE IN OUR THIRD YEAR OF OUR
FOR BASICALLY FULL EXPANSION WE
ARE AT FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TERMS OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS --
THAT ARE HIGHEST SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE TEN PER INMATE.
AND AGAIN IT TAKES. THREE TO
FIVE YEARS AFTER THAT COHORT IS
COMPLETED. TO TO SEE THE RESULTS
OF RECIDIVISM BUT AS A DIRECTOR --
SKEWS ME SECRETARY D. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS WE HAVE SEEN RESULTS AND
REDUCING RECIDIVISM I GET.
THAT IT'S NOT AS AS SPEEDY OR AS
SIGNIFICANT I THINK AS MOST OF
US WOULD PREFER BUT AGAIN WE ARE
MAKING HEADWAY THEY ARE USING
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMMING THEY
HAVE BEEN TAKING STEPS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE STEPS AS
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT. TO ADDRESS MANY OF THOSE
THINGS SO --
OF THAT OF THOSE COHORTS HAS
THERE BEEN ANY ANALYSIS AS TO
WHETHER THEIR RECIDIVISM RATE IS
HIGHER THAN COURTS HAVE NOT GONE
THROUGH THE PROGRAM [inaudible]
WELL THAT.
SO THEY THEY LOOK AT AND I'M
GOING TO DEFER TO HOPEFULLY --
ONE OF THE FOLKS AND SEE IF YOU
ARE A REGARDING THAT BUT YOU
LOOK AT THE THREE YEARS POST
RELEASE.
AND SO IF WE ARE JUST NOW AT NOT
IS NOT WHAT WE CONSIDER FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF A
REHABILITATION.
TATIAN PROGRAMS BUT WHAT'S RIGHT --
REFLECTED AS A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT A REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
WHEN WE START LOOKING AT
RELEASES AND SEVENTEEN EIGHT THE
NOW THREE YEARS OUT WE WOULD
LOOK AT THAT COHORT I BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S THE DATA THAT THEY
LOOK AT IN TERMS OF RECIDIVISM?
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE AND WHAT IS THE DATA SHOPS
ARE SO THEY LOOK AT IT WHAT IT
WHAT IT CHAU EXCUSE ME.
I WILL DEFER ANYBODY WANNA
CONFIDENCE THAT QUESTION IN
TERMS OF THE ACTUAL --
LOOK AT RECIDIVISM RATES FROM
ELDERLY MISLI INCARCERATED BUT
WE ALSO MAKE A POINT THAT THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT SPECIFICALLY
TALKS ABOUT JUST 25% OF THE
PROGRAMS THE CB TEAS.
BUT ONLY I I DO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
I'M ASK ABOUT YOUR NUMBERS WHAT
ARE YOUR NUMBER SIR.
SO WE'VE DONE WE'VE ROLLED OUT
PROGRAMS AND NOW THEY'RE IN
EVERY SINGLE YARD WORK.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE?
AND WHAT DO YOU HI WOULD YOU
KNOW ABOUT HOW WELL THEY'RE
DOING.
THERE'S A LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
FEEDBACK THE MEDIA INTRODUCED
YOU TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR RYAN
SEUSS --
FROM THE DIVISION RESULTED
PROGRAMS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON FRANCES --
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR YOU --
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS SO SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE UP
FRONT IS REALLY FOCUSING ON
CREATING THE TOOLS TERMS OF DATA
COLLECTION DATA EXTRACTION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY INFIDELITY WHICH
IS REFERENCE EARLIER BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THOSE.
THAT IS FOR SURROUNDING REALLY
ARE CBT PROGRAMS WHERE
NATIONALLY WE KNOW THAT THE CVT
PROGRAMS CAN WORK IF IMPLEMENTED
WITH ACCOUNTABILITY INFIDELITY
AND THAT'S THE TOOL THAT WE
REALLY CREATED AROUND THOSE.
THAT RECIDIVISM MENTIONED BY
SECRETARY DS EARLIER SHOWS A
SLIGHT REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM
FOR THE MOST RECENT KEY
TOLERANCE LIGHT IT WAS ABOUT 3%
OFF OF THE POPULATION BASED ON
FROM WHAT PERCENT OR PERCENT.
I THINK IT WAS 41% 238% --
AND SO THAT'S A SLIGHT REDUCTION
BUTTON WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
INFIDELITY WE THINK THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE NATIONAL PERCENTAGES
WHICH IS CLOSE TO TWELVE AND 13%
FOR CBT PROGRAMS.
THERE WAS ALSO A REFERENCE OR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS PEOPLE
ACHIEVING THE LITERACY LEVEL
THAT WE THINK IS IMPORTANT WHICH
IS A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
EQUIVALENCY.
AND IN THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
POPULATION IT WAS RELEASED WE
SAW ONE YOUR CONVICTION RATE
FROM SOME INITIAL DATA THAT'S
ABOUT NINE POINT 5%.
NOW WHEN YOU COMPARE THAT TO THE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WHICH IS NOT
APPLES TO APPLES BUT IT'S A
STARTING POINT TO DISCUSS HOW
SUCCESSFUL THEY ARE.
IT'S AROUND 18% SO THAT'S NOT A
50% RIGHT THE LITERACY THAT WE
THINK -- ARE
ACHIEVABLE AND WHAT WE'RE AIMING
FOR SO WE'RE SEEING BITS AND
PIECES OF RECIDIVISM REDUCTIONS
FOR THE THINGS WERE POINT BUT WE
A 100% CONCUR THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE.
FOCUSING ON DATA COLLECTION
EXTRACTION AND EVALUATIONS NOT
FOR HIM INFORMACIóN SO WHAT'S
WITH THE PLAN TO GET TO THAT 20%
HOW TO CLOSE THAT 20% GAP.
THE INITIAL PLAN IS
IMPLEMENTATION WITH ENOUGH
LONGITUDINAL DATA.
AND THEN IMPLEMENT REALLY
ACCOUNTABILITY INFIDELITY
MEASURES PUT IN PLACE THE STUFF
THAT WE'VE WORKED WITH WHICH WAS
REFERENCED IN THE AUDIT ON AND
WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED TO THE
MEMBERS.
WHICH IS OUR WORK WITH
pUNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
THEY CREATED AROUND OUR
COGNITIVE BE REAL TREATMENT --
COMPONENTS REALLY ACCOUNTABILITY
INFIDELITY TOOLS AND MEASURES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT AND FIDELITY IS A VERY
CRITICAL --
PIECE OF MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ACHIEVING RECIDIVISM REDUCTION
AND THAT IS AN IMPORTANT POINT
NATIONALLY AS WELL AND I THINK
JUST A NOTE EARLIER WE HAVE A A
ROD.
BRANDT --
DIRECTOR CHOKE MENTIONED THAT WE
HAVE A BROAD ARRAY OF
PROGRAMMING THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION EVERYTHING FROM C. B.
T. AND EDUCATION BUT ALSO.
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COME IN AND
DO OUR GRANT PROGRAMS INTO OUR
VOLUNTARY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS CONSIDERED
TO BE EVIDENCE BASED OUR
RESEARCH AS DEFINED IN THE FEW
CLEARING HOUSE BUT THE STUFF
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING.
CREATES A CULTURE AND
ENVIRONMENT WE THINK IN THE
PRISON BRING THOSE OUTPUT
MEASURES AND OUTCOME MEASURES SO
IT'S NOT ALWAYS JUST ABOUT
RECIDIVISM WERE LOOKING FOR IS
DELIVERABLES TO SHOW.
MAYBE CHANGES IN THE POPULATION
CHANGES AND HOW THEY'RE REACTING
TO PROGRAMMING THE ABILITY TO
GET PREPARED FOR TREATMENT
PROGRAM IN WHICH OPENS UP SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
TRAUMA WOUNDS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE READY TO
ACCOUNT FOR AND HAVE THEM THERE
AND A BIG PIECE OF WHAT WE'VE
DONE TO WITH --
THE STUFF THAT WE WORKED ON THE
LAST YEAR'S REALLY DID ANALYTICS
TOOLS MAKING SURE OUR PSALMS
WEIGHTLESS PRIORITIZES RISK AND
NEEDS CREATING DATA ANALYTICS
TOOLS TO MAKE SURE GETTING
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT PROGRAM AT
THE RIGHT TIME.
SO ALL THINGS I CONCUR WITH YOU
WHEN WE NEED TO KEEP FOCUSING ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT WERE RID --
YOU KNOW REDUCING OUTPUTS AND
OUTCOMES AS NECESSARY AND THAT'S
RICH PRODUCTIONS AND RECIDIVISM
AND OTHER THINGS AS WELL HOW HOW
LONG TO IMPLEMENT THESE TOOLS.
WELL THE LAST TWO YEARS WE
REALLY CREATED ALL OF THEM SO
IT'S REALLY ROLLING THEM OUT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THE RIGHT REPORTING BACK.
THE WORK THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
WITH RESEARCHERS IS REALLY
TRYING TO FIND THINGS THAT WE
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
SEE AND THINGS WE BELIEVE IN WE
ARE ABSOLUTE PASSION ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS ARE PUTTING IN PLACE
AND WE KNOW THEY CAN HAVE THESE
RECIDIVISM A FAX.
SO WE PLAN ON BEING IN CONTRACT
CONSISTENT WITH THE AUDIT REPORT
BY JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
WORKING TOWARDS DELIVERABLES
THEY'RE NOT JUST LONGITUDINAL
BUT MAYBE SOME OTHER ONES.
SO WHEN YOU SAY ROLL OUT WHAT
WHAT DO YOU MEAN SO HOW HOW MANY
HOW MANY FACILITIES.
HAVE THEM HOW MANY PROGRAMS HAVE
THEM AND WHAT WHICH ONES DON'T.
FOR THE ACCOUNTABILITY
INFIDELITY TOOLS YES SO
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOLS ROLLED OUT
IN JANUARY AND ALL --
CHAPTER NINETEEN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND TWO WAS CREATED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WITH
UC IRVINE PERSON TRAINING BEING
DONE TO MAKE SURE WE ARE GOING
TO BE DOING IT RIGHT BECAUSE
PART OF WHAT WE WANTED TO DO AND
HERE HE WAS CRITICIZED ANIMAL
MODEL.
NOT HAVE TO ALWAYS PAY A
RESEARCHER A FEW INSTITUTIONS
BUT REALLY BE ABLE TO PUT
SOMETHING IN BROADLY.
AND SO THE ACCOUNTABILITY TOOLS
ROLLED ON JANUARY AND OUR STAFF
ARE GOING OUT AND DOING
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEWS NOW
THEY'RE ALSO BEING TRAINED ON
THE FIDELITY MEASUREMENTS.
THEIR WORK CREATIVITY IS HEREBY
ANOTHER HAPPENING OKAY MUSIC
ROLLOUT.
ALL THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS
OKAY SO EVERY EVERY INSTITUTION
NOW.
HOW'S THE TOOLS DEVELOPED BY UC
IRVINE.
AND NOW YOUR TEAM IS GOING IN
THERE TO DOUBLE CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY BEING.
AND IT ISN'T AT THE DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED THAT'S CORRECT.
YES COLLECTED IN IMPLEMENTED
WITH FIDELITY IMPLEMENTED AS THE
MODEL HAD INTENDED IN TERMS TO
DATE HOW FOR YOU GETTING DID YOU
GET IN WEEKLY.
MONTHLY WE ARE COLLECTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS MILLIONS
OF DATA POINTS YOUR EVERY WEEK
EVERYBODY THAT IS INVOLVED IN
OUR PROGRAMMING --
ONE OF THE THINGS WE REALLY TRY
TO FOCUS ON A LAST YEAR'S AS WE
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE RESEARCHERS
COME IN AND NOT HAVE THE DATA WE
OFTEN SEE THAT'S A PROBLEM WITH.
WITH THESE RECIDIVISM REPORTS OR
ANYTHING AS THEY SAY WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE DATA AVAILABLE SO
OUR TEAM FOCUSED REALLY ON
CREATING --
STRATEGIC OFFENDER MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM DATAPOINTS EVERYTHING
FROM TRACKING WHEN THEY WERE
ASSIGNED A PROGRAM HOW MUCH
THEY'VE BEEN ASSIGNED A PROGRAM
HOW MANY HOURS ARE IN THE
PROGRAM.
WE ALSO ROLLED OUT AT A ROBUST
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO WE'RE
DOING FIDELITY MEASUREMENTS WE
KNOW WHAT CURRICULUM THEY'RE
WORKING ON ON WHAT DAY AND THE
TREATMENT NOTES IN CASE PLAN
SURROUNDING IT SO WE REALLY TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE INFORMATION IS THERE SO THAT
WHEN WE EXTRACTED FOR THESE
FIDELITY REPORTS OR FOR THE
RESEARCHERS THE REALLY GONNA
HAVE A REAL FAST --
VARIETY OF INFORMATION THAT THEY
CAN GET FOR CAN YOU SHARE THAT
WITH US NOW.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEN.
GIVE GIVEN THIS IS A WAY OUT OF
THIS DOES THIS. TO THESE
EVALUATION THE AN AUDITOR DO
THESE EVALUATION TOOLS --
CHECK THAT BOX IN TERMS OF YOUR
RECOMMENDATION OR ARE YOU
EXPECTING MORE THAN THIS.
THINK WE NEED TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT INCLUDED IN THESE REPORTS --
ONE TO GET IN YOUR MENTION WAS
TALK ABOUT COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PROGRAMS AND COMPARING THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO SEE WHICH
ONES MAKE SENSE TO CONTINUE --
WE HAD ALSO HOPE THAT --
IT EVALUATION WOULD INCLUDE A
COMPONENT THAT WOULD.
ALLOW US TO SEE WHAT THE GAPS
ARE.
AND SEE WHETHER THE OR OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THOSE GAPS.
ANTHONY SYMBOL FROM ELLIE I
DON'T THINK I'D ADD IS AS THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT SORT OF
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION DATA IT'S A
THINK ABOUT THE POPULATION THAT
THEY'RE TARGETING AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED IN THEIR REPORT AS WE'VE
NOTED.
THE FARM HAS ALWAYS PART OF THE
HIGH SORT OF THE LOW RISK OF
NONI SO YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THEIR THEIR PRESENTING IN THAT
LIGHT IN OTHER WORDS ARE THERE
FOR REALLY FOCUSING MORE ON HIGH
RISK HIGH NEED.
WELL WITH THOSE OUTCOMES THE
KLAXON ONE THINK ABOUT THAT.
SO THAT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SO DO YOU BREAK OUT THE ON THE
DATA BASED ON THE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUAL THE SERVICE.
YEAH WE ARE WE ARE NOW FOCUSING
I THINK WITH THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN
A PRIORITIZATION AFFECTING THE
DEPARTMENT TO FOCUS ON HIGH RISK
HIGH NEED BUT IT'S BEEN A REALLY
MANUAL PROCESS.
SO TWO YEARS AGO WE GOT TOGETHER
SOMEHOW WE LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY
TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND THAT WAS
PSALMS WEIGHTLESS CHANGES ARE
DATA ANALYTICS TOOLS WE PUT IN
PLACE. TO REALLY FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS OF THE POPULATION THAT CAN
BE -- YOU
KNOW BASS ADDRESSED THROUGH
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION THAT'S
HIGHEST RISK AND HIGHEST NEED
BASED ON OUR TOOLS.
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF PROGRAMMING GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES IN OUR PSALMS
DATA SYSTEM AND SO THE NEW
VERSION WILL COME LIVE ON APRIL
SEVENTH TO BE ABLE. TO TO
ACCOMMODATE THE A BETTER WAITING
LISTS THAT.
THE TOP PLACE PEOPLE ON THEIR
HIGH RISK AND I NEED.
AND I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT WE DO
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE UC IRVINE THAT
CITIES HERE IMPLEMENT THEM AS
WELL AS THE WAITLIST ISSUE --
SO WE'LL BE FOLLOWING THAT UP --
THERE'S CITIES HERE SIXTY DAY
RESPONSES DID WAS AT THE END OF
THE MONTH SO WILL BEGIN IN THE
DOCUMENTATION OF THAT
IMPLEMENTATION AT THE END WE CAN
KIND OF MAKE JUDGMENTS ON WHERE
THEY ARE IN THAT PROCESS. ONE OF
THE THANK A A CHEER OF FOR THE
QUESTIONS IT WOULD GIVE ME A LOT
LESS TO ASK.
LOOK NO NO THAT'S GREAT THAT'S
WONDERFUL --
THAT'S GREAT --
IT APPEARS THAT.
WHO IMPLEMENTS THE PROGRAMS DO
YOU HAVE THE [inaudible]
PERSONNEL.
OF CAPABLE OF IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS WITH THE FIDELITY THAT
YOU TALK ABOUT.
I MEAN IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RESEARCH BASED PROGRAMS AND I'M
LISTENING TO FOLKS SAY BUT WITH
THE FIDELITY WHICH MEANS YOU
ACTUALLY KNOW HOW TO IMPLEMENT
IT AND AND IMPLEMENTED BY THEM.
BY THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED THE NEED TO BE THERE
DO WE HAVE THE STAFF TO DO THAT --
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T APPEAR IS IF.
THE WE HAVE A STAFF IN PLACE TO
COMPENSATE BECAUSE THE FOCUS
SEEM TO BE ON GETTING MORE
PROGRAMS GETTING LOTS OF
PROGRAMS BUT NOT NECESSARILY
ALWAYS GETTING THE RIGHT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENT IT THE RIGHT WAY --
SO DO WE HAVE THE STAFF TO DO
THAT ARE YOU IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING FOLKS TO DO THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
STAFF TO DO THAT.
THE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
TRY TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
MODEL WITH UC IRVINE WAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STAFF ARE FOCUSED
ON THE THINGS THAT REALLY MATTER
SO ROLL OUT.
OF OUR CONTRACTS WAS A
SIGNIFICANT UNDERTAKING IT TAKES
A LOT OF ON DAY TO DAY TASKS
WORK BUT NOW THAT THAT'S BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED WE'VE REALLY RE
DIRECTED THE STAFF TO SAY WITH
YOU KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT
FACTORS IN MAKING SURE THAT.
OUR TREATMENTS WORKING AS THOSE
THAT WOULD BE MEASURES AND SO
RIGHT NOW WE DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT --
ON AND THE IDEA IS TWO TO THREE
TIMES WE HAVE SO WE'RE NOT HE
JUST GETTING ONE FIDELITY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE WE'RE
GETTING MULTIPLE MEASUREMENTS
OVER A YEAR.
SO RESEARCHERS ARE ALSO ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT AND IF WE ARE FOR
SOME REASON ARE.
NOT ABLE TO ARE STRUGGLING WE
WOULD OBVIOUSLY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION --
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
RIGHT NOW WE DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
ENOUGH SO YOU BEGIN THE PROCESS
YOU SAID YOU BECAME AWARE OF
THIS PROBLEM AND AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OKAY AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT YOU BEGAN TO DO. TO MAKE
CHANGES.
OKAY BUT THEY WERE NOT READY BY
THE TIME HE DID THE REPORT IS
THAT CORRECT.
A LOT OF THE THAT MUST EARN.
A LOT OF WHAT WE TRY TO DO IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS
REALLY ASSESS WHY.
THAT THE REASONS THAT PROGRAMS
WOULDN'T WORK OR WOULDN'T BE
SHOWN TO WORK OR SOME OF THE
STRUGGLES WE HAD THOSE WERE
REALLY AROUND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAD DATA COLLECTION EFFORTS
UNDER WAY.
MAKING SURE WE WERE BOTH PUTTING
THINGS INTO THE CRACKS SYSTEMS
AND BEING ABLE TO EXTRACT THOSE
THINGS OUT CREATING AND STARTING
TO WORK WITH OUR STRATEGIC
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PRIVATIZATIONS
WERE RIGHT.
AND ALSO OUR DATA ANALYTICS
TOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RIGHT
PERSON THE RIGHT PROGRAM IN THE
RIGHT TIME.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS REALLY WERE
IN PLACE BECAUSE WHAT WE DIDN'T
WANT TO SOME LONGITUDINAL
RESEARCH STUDY.
THAT CAME OUT AND SAID WELL
YOU'RE PUTTING THE WRONG PERSON
AND SO WE WOULD GO BACK AND GO
OH WELL NOW WHEN YOU PUT THE
RIGHT PERSON AND FOR THAT
RESEARCH.
THAT WAS THE EFFORT HERE THE
LAST YEAR'S REALLY SAYING MAKE
SURE WE PUT THE FOUNDATION
TOGETHER CORRECTLY MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S GOING
TO BE THERE MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
FIDELITY THERE.
SO WHEN THE RESEARCH COMES TO
FRUITION WERE ABLE BECAUSE THEY
WORK NATIONALLY WE KNOW THAT
THEY WORK THE ONLY WORK IF THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER THAT'S CORRECT ONLY
WORK IF THE RIGHT FOLKS IN THE
CLASSROOM --
WHATEVER TEACHING YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT SOMETHING JUST HAS TO EXIST
ON A BOOK COULD YOU TAKE OFF THE
SHELF AND THEN IT BECOMES A GOOD
PROGRAM.
IT HAS TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
RIGHT WAY WITH THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF STAFF.
THE RIGHT FOLKS THAT ARE THERE --
SO I HOPE I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT THE REASON WHY OF COURSE
WERE ASKING QUESTIONS --
WOULD BE SPENT A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS OF REHABILITATION THIS
PAST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE HOPES
THAT IT WOULD OF IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THE OF THE THE INMATES
THAT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY BENEFIT
FROM IT.
AND THAT THE THE CONCEPT OF
REHABILITATION THAT'S IN THE
NAME OF THE ALL OF THE AGENCY
NOW IS A REALITY RATHER THAN
JUST A NAME AND SO --
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT THAT OUT I
THINK VISITING ASKED A VERY GOOD
QUESTION --
AND AND MAYBE WE SHOULD WHY
SHOULD WE CONTINUE THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE INEFFECTIVE.
YOU KNOW 80% OF THEM I GUESS ARE
EFFECTIVE IS THAT CORRECT OR
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED WITH SOME
FIDELITY.
SO.
ARE ALL REPORT DOESN'T.
RECOMMEND ANY REDUCTION IN
BRIGHTON --
IN THE PROGRAMS THIS TIME
BECAUSE WE REALLY DON'T FEEL
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TESTED
THOROUGHLY TO KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE
THEY TRULY ARE OKAY SO WE THINK
THAT'S WHY CECE'S HERE NEEDS --
TO CONTRACT WITH AN OUTSIDE
RESEARCH IT'S INDEED DO THAT
LIKE WORK AND THEN YOU'RE REALLY
EQUIPPED WITH THE TOOLS TO NOW
YOU KNOW WHAT --
WHAT PROGRAMS ARE WORKING AND
YOU REALLY WANT TO EXPAND THOSE
THAT FOCUS ON THEM AND THEN WHAT
PROGRAMS MAYBE AREN'T AS
EFFECTIVE AND BEGIN THAT CUTTING
BUT [inaudible]
AT THAT.
NOW YOU SAID ABOUT 80% SEEM TO
BE.
OF EVIDENCE BASIS FOR AND BEING
IMPLEMENTED AS SOON WITH SOME OF
THE DELL E. IS THAT CORRECT OR
JUST IT.
IF I HAVE IT IN SPACE SO --
AT THE TIME OF OUR WORKED WITH
YOU SEE OR BY TO DEVELOP THOSE
FIDELITY TOOLS HOWEVER THEY
WEREN'T IMPLEMENTED AT THE TIME
OF OUR WORK NOW SO.
SO I THINK AS THEY MOVE FORWARD
AND WHAT WE'LL BE LOOKING AT AS
THAT SIXTY SIX MONTH OF ONE YOUR
RESPONSES IS TO SEE OUT OF WHAT.
OF REPORTS THEY'RE GETTING BACK
CONCERNING HOW WELL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY BEING --
INSURE CONSISTENTLY TAUGHT IN
APPLIED ACROSS THE STATE.
I THINK THE CLOSER YES GO HEAD I
THINK CONTACT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WELL THAT THE THE
STATE AUDITOR WAS ONLY FOCUSED
ON OUR COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS RIGHT THAT
WAS THE THE REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM DISCUSSION.
AND I THINK TWO OF THE TEN
INSTITUTIONS ACTUALLY DID SHOW --
POSITIVE REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM FOR THOSE TEN THAT
THEY REVIEWED BUT THE 76% AS
NOTED IN AUDIT REPORT OUR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOCUS ON
LITERACY AND JUST LIKE I SAID --
A MINUTE AGO AND SECRETARY DS
DISCUSS THAT AS WELL JUST ON A
ONE YEAR CONVICTION RATE WE'RE
SEEING POTENTIALLY UP 250%
REDUCTIONS FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACHIEVING THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR EQUIVALENT THE SO
THESE ARE THINGS WE KNOW AS WE
GO FORWARD WITH OUR OUR RESEARCH
PROJECTS BOTH.
HOLISTICALLY THE VERY LARGE ONES
AND SOME OF THE STUFF THAT WE
CAN DO WITH OUR OFFICE OF
RESEARCH THESE ARE THINGS WE CAN
PROVIDE TO THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WILL HELP --
PROVIDE A MORE ABILITY SINCE
WORKING BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS WORKING EDUCATION
THERE ARE SOME INDICATORS RIGHT
NOW THAT SHOW THAT.
AND NATIONALLY SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT AND OTHER COGNITIVE
HERO TREATMENT WORKS UP TO YOU
KNOW ON WITH A FEW RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE 13% REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM SO WE BELIEVE THAT
PUTTING THESE FOUNDATIONAL
MEASURES IN PLACE WILL REALLY
HELP US ACHIEVE THOSE REDUCTIONS
AND BE ABLE TO MEASURE MOST WE
GO. FOR WITH THIS LONGITUDINAL
RESEARCH STUDY.
OKAY -- YES
JUST ONE OTHER SHOULD THINK
ABOUT AS THE DEPARTMENT TALKS
ABOUT ITS EVALUATION PLAN
WORKING FOR OUTSIDE RESEARCHERS
HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED HOW MUCH
THAT WOULD COST.
AND HOW THEY PLAN ON PAYING FACE
IS GONNA COME WITHIN THEIR
BUDGET IS GOING TO COME WITHIN
THE REHABILITATION BUDGET AND
WHICH PROGRAM SERVICES WITH A
NOT DUE TO FIND THE EVALUATION
THAT'S ONE THING HAPPENED
MENTIONED.
WHICH I GUESS WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU AND TAKING A MAJOR
EVALUATION ASSESSMENT.
OF THE OF THE PROPER PROGRAM
MAYBE A FACTOR THAT IN.
WE'RE STILL WORKING THROUGH THE
GENERAL SIZE OF THE EVALUATION
THEY CAN BE VERY COSTLY AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME OPTIONS
ABOUT --
TRYING TO BE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE WITH THAT AND SO
THERE ARE SOME THINGS OUT THERE
WORKING WITH NON PROFITS IS ALSO
AN OPTION WE'RE DOING SOME
THINGS BUT OBVIOUSLY.
IF THERE WAS A REQUESTED WE
WOULD DO THAT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AS WELL.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT ARE
THERE ARE FEDERAL --
GRANTS AVAILABLE --
THE STATEWIDE --
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION FIVE GIVES
A SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS TO
STATES OVER A COURSE OF SEVERAL
YEARS IF THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE A
PLAN TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
SAID SOMETHING THAT CITIES ARE
COULD LOOK INTO AS WELL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
WE CAN PROBABLY TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS NOW SINCE WOULD DEAL
WITH CDC ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS WILL GIVE YOU ONE
MINUTE.
TO HOPEFULLY SHARE --
YOUR THOUGHTS.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR AGENCY THAT YOU
REPRESENT AND WE HAVE ONE MINUTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TYAN OF ARGUS
ADMIN I'M THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND WHERE POLICY LED
ORGANIZATION BUILT BY AND FOR
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION --
I'M HERE AS PART OF THAT
TRANSFORMATIVE IN PRISON WORK
GROUP --
THEY'RE LESS MEMBERS HERE TODAY --
BUT I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
OUR TWELVE THOUSAND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED MEMBERS --
I'M HERE TO MAKE THREE SHORT
POINTS --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO IMPRESS
UPON THIS BODY THE FACT THAT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE BEGGING
FOR ACCESS TO UP TO MORE ACCESS
TO BETTER MORE TRANSFORMATIVE IN
PRISON GROUPS --
AND PROGRAMS WE CONDUCTED A
SURVEY LAST YEAR MORE THAN A
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND ASK THEM TO
RANK OUT OF TEN POLICY
PRIORITIES WHAT WE SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZING AND THEY RANKED
ACCESS TO BETTER PROGRAMS AS
NUMBER --
TWO THE SECOND POINT THAT I WANT
TO RAISE IS THAT INCREASED
ACCESS COMES WITH INCREASED
FUNDING --
WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT THIS
BODY ALLOCATE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS OPPOSED TO THE
CURRENT RECOMMENDED FOR MILLION
OF THE ALMOST TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET IS REALLY NOT A
LOT.
AND THEN THE THIRD
RECOMMENDATION THAT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT WHEN IN THE FUTURE
YOU'RE DOING YOUR RESEARCH ON
LOOKING AT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS --
WHICH ARE DISTINCT FROM THE
COGNITIVE BASED THERAPY PROGRAMS
RUN BY CDC ARE CONSIDERED THE
IMPACT ON PEOPLE --
CONSIDER ASKING YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS OR MAYBE PEOPLE WHO ARE --
ON PAROLE REENTERING IN THEIR
COMMUNITY SAFELY WHAT ACTUALLY
HELP TO THEM --
LOOKING AT RECIDIVISM AND YOU
KNOW ALL THESE NUMBERS ARE
IMPORTANT BUT THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE I'M HEARING FROM THE
PEOPLE MOST DIRECTLY IMPACT IN
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AS IMPORTANT AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
MY NAME IS JOHN GROW UP AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR
POTS FOR LIFE CAN NINE RESCUE
[inaudible]
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I WAS
GIVEN SIX LIFESENTENCES
CONSECUTIVE TO FORTY YEARS.
I WAS SENTENCED TO DIE IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM.
AND BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT COME
INTO THE PRISON AND PROVIDE SELF
HELP PROGRAMMING.
A PEER TO PEER PROGRAMMING.
AND REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
GENERAL -- I
WAS GIVEN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE
KIND OF WORK.
THAT --
MISTER STONE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
AND LEARN --
ABOUT --
INSIGHT AND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
REHABILITATED.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS --
ADVERTISEMENT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET AND THERE'S MORE
THAN A HUNDRED NINE OF THESE.
THESE PARTICULAR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING IN CDC ARE.
AND THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MEN
THAT IF MEN AND WOMEN THAT BEEN
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS.
COME OUT AND BECOME SUCCESSFUL
MEMBERS 99% OF LIFERS.
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY THIS IS A GROUP
THAT'S BEING THAT'S BEING
OVERLOOKED AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
BEING.
BROUGHT IN BY THE DEPARTMENT
THERE SEVERELY THAT WE HAVE
THESE OPPORTUNITIES THANKS VERY
MUCH LIKE WHO.
HI MY NAME IS MARK TAYLOR AND
I'M WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
I SPENT OVER TWENTY ONE YEARS OF
MY LIFE INCARCERATED IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS.
AND WAS RELEASED LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS AGO WHEN I FIRST ENTER
PRISON I WAS A DRUG ADDICTED
VIOLENT STREET GANG MEMBER.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
UTILIZE THE PEER TO PEER MODEL
HELP ME ACHIEVE SOBRIETY AND
ALSO HELP ME PERMANENTLY SEVER
GANG TOPICS.
SPECIFICALLY THE HOPE OF
REDEMPTION TEAM WHICH IS A GROUP
OF LIFE TERM.
INMATES WHO GO BACK INSIDE
HIGHER LEVEL SECURITY PRISONS IN
HELP REHABILITATE PRISONERS HAS
PLAYED A VITAL ROLE NOT
REHABILITATION.
THESE FORMER PRISONERS ARE
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE T CREATING
SAFE SPACES FOR INMATES TO
ENGAGE IN A REHABILITATIVE
PROCESS AND THAT IN TURN ENHANCE
ENHANCES PUBLIC SAFETY.
OVER TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
INMATES HAVE WENT THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM SINCE SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TODAY I'M HERE
TO SAY THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE THE PEER
TO PEER MODEL PROVIDE VITAL
SERVICES. TO INMATES AND
CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED WITH TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RICHARD AND
ARGUS I'M HERE REPRESENTING
SUCCESS STORIES WHICH IS AN
INMATE LEADER TO LEISURE TIME
ACTIVITY GROUP.
AND NOW A RECIPIENT OF THE
INNOVATION GRANT.
I STARTED SUCCESS STORIES IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHILE I WAS
INCARCERATED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND THIS IS WHY I
BELIEVE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
ILL TAGS OF THE COMMUNITY RAN
GROUPS AND FROM THE C. B. TWO
GROUPS THAT ARE HAVE BEEN
AUDITED AND ARE BEING QUESTIONED
TODAY.
WHAT IT'LL TAKE GROUPS CAN DO
THAT CBT GROUPS CANNOT ARE THREE
THINGS SPECIFICALLY ONE BECAUSE
WE AND SUCCESS STORIES WERE OF
THE PEOPLE WE WERE WORKING WITH
WE ARE ABLE TO SEE THE NEEDS --
THAT PEOPLE HAD IN A WAY THAT
WAS DIFFERENT WE ARE ABLE TO SEE
THAT PEOPLE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
THIRTY FIVE NOT ONLY RECIDIVIST
AT HIGHER BUT GOT INTO MORE
TROUBLE AND COMMITTED MORE
VIOLENCE WITHIN PRISON.
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THESE GROUPS
OUT IN THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE LAST
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD I STARTED
THE PROGRAM. TO WE WERE ABLE TO
INTERVENE AND MORE DIRECT WAYS --
THAT ARE A LITTLE HARDER TO
STUDY THAN JUST RECIDIVISM FOR
EXAMPLE WE STOPPED MANY FIGHTS
BEFORE THEY HAPPEN.
BECAUSE WE WERE AMONG THE PEER
GROUP OF THE OF OUR PARTICIPANTS
I WAS NOT A MANDATORY REPORTER I
DIDN'T HAVE TO TELL THE COPS
WHEN SOMEBODY HAD A CELL PHONE I
COULD DEAL WITH THEM DIRECTLY --
AND WE WERE ABLE TO STOP A LOT
OF IMPRISONED BYLANDT BY BEING
OF THE COMMUNITY THAT WE ARE
WORKING WITH.
THIRD AND FINALLY --
WE WERE WE BUILT WE BUILT
RELATIONSHIPS AUTHENTIC
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THE PRISON
WHICH IS VERY HARD TO MEASURE IN
A QUANTITATIVE WAY --
BUT WE HAD REALIZED THAT PEOPLE
WERE COMMITTING VIOLENCE BECAUSE
THEY SAW VIOLENCE AS A AS PART
OF BEING A MAN.
AND WE REMEDY THAT BY BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WERE NOT
BASED IN VIOLENT AGAIN
MEMBERSHIP BUT ACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND THAT SOMETHING
THAT COULD ONLY HAPPEN WHEN
THERE'S NO POWER DYNAMIC.
ON THAT SOMETIMES HAPPENS IN THE
C. B. T. GROUPS WHERE YOU HAVE A
PAID STAFF MEMBER RUNNING THE
GROUP FOR THAT REASON I ADVOCATE
FOR EXTENDED EXT.
EXPANDING THE PROGRAMMING OF THE
LEISURE TIME ACTIVITY GROUPS AND
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING
CONFLATED WITH THE CVT GROUPS
THAT ARE UNDER FIRE TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS A RICHER CREWS
I SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN PRISON.
AND I WAS A CVT SAP ONE'S SO I
KNOW THAT WORLD AND I KNOW THE
RULES OF OUTSIDE PEOPLE COMING
IN TO HELP TOO BECAUSE I'M
WITHIN HOURS THIS CALL THE HAVE
TO COLLECTIVELY GOING AND WE DO
THAT FROM A WORK.
AND HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
AND BOTH OF THEM WORK THEY WORK
FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE THERE'S NO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
AND THE ONLY DISCREPANCY I SEE
IS.
C. B. T. YES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION.
WE GET FOUR MILLION.
THERE'S A PROBLEM THERE.
SO IF WE COULD EVEN THAT OUT I
ME MYSELF I THINK THERE COULD BE
SOME.
SOME REAL REDUCTION OF
RECIDIVISM.
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE TO COME IN
A CARE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TALK
pTHERE'S SOME PEOPLE IN CB TEAS I
USED TO WORK WITH IN THAT CARE.
I KNOW THESE PEOPLE CARE.
TO IF WE CAN GET THEM IN THERE.
YOU KNOW THOSE RELATIONSHIPS I
THINK THAT'S WHAT HELPED ME GET
OUT.
BECAUSE I GOT ALL THAT LOVE FROM
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT'S WHY I'M OUT HERE DOING
GOOD I'VE BEEN OUT SINCE LAST
YEAR.
IN A THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
ON SUB TWENTY MY NAME IS BORING
HI I WORK FOR THE CLIP TRAINEES
TO IT AS A PROJECT MANAGER.
AND I WANT TO SHOWA LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH PROGRAMMING BECAUSE I I
WOULD I WAS RAISED IN PRISON
PRETTY MUCH.
I WANT TO SYSTEM WHEN I WAS
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD.
AND WHILE I WAS GOING TO SYSTEMS
I WAS TRYING TO FIND MY WAY
TRYING TO FIGURE STUFF OUT.
AND I'VE BEEN AN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM A BEEN IN THAT --
I'VE TAKE ADDITION RECOVER
COUNSELING'S SO HAVE A LOOK WIDE
EXPERIENCE IN PROGRAMMING BUT I
CAN SAY LIKE WAS MOST AFFECTED
TO ME THAT HELPED ME A LOT WELL
AS FOR ME BASED PROGRAM.
PARTLY BECAUSE IS BEING DONE FOR
PROGRAMMING AND IS IT THE TRUST
THE NEEDS OF THE POPULATIONS AND
WITH THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT HOW
WE GONNA DO WITH.
AND THE RELIGIOUS OF THE BILL
AND SO I WAS FORTUNATE BECAUSE
GOING TO THE PROGRAM I WAS ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND WHY CAME A CRIME
HOW WE GOT TO THAT POINT WAS
LIKEGOING UP OR TRAUMA
EXPERIENCE.
NOW IS IT WILL TAKE THOSE SKILLS
AND NOW COMING OUT ON BE
EMPLOYED BY THE SAME
ORGANIZATION WHOSE HELP ME LEARN
ABOUT MYSELF AND I'M GETTING
BACK TO MY COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT'S LACKING A LOT IN
ON THE C. T. PROGRAM BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE A LOT OF THAT
HAPPENING SOUL --
AND I'M ALSO LEARNING TO LIKE.
DOING THIS WORK THAT THAT I
DIDN'T KNOW WELL NOT A WORKING
AS THE ORGANIZATION WAS FULLY
UNDER FUNDED BY.
A WHAT WORKING --
TARGET FUNDS SOMEWHERE ELSE
WHERE I THINK I'D LIKE CECE ARE
LIKE WELL WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
IS THAT REHABILITATION COULD BE
THE CORNER THE CORNERSTONES OF
HOW WE ONE CORRECTION HOW MUCH I
DON'T SEE THAT I DON'T FEEL THAT
NOW AND I'M I'M HOPING THAT.
ON THIS COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
THINK DIFFERENTLY A HOW YOU FUND
ON VALUE WITH THESE WE BILL
TATIAN LIKE TO COMMITTEE BASED
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE DO OFFER.
SUCCESSFUL --
REHABILITATION TO FOLKS IN
PRISON THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANKS FOR HAVING
ME HOT MADAM CHAIR PERSONS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S FILAMENT IS AND I AM
THE OUT RECESS SO **** WITH
RESTORE JUSTICE ALSO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PERSON.
I WAS INCARCERATED FOR TWENTY
YEARS FILES WILL FOR PAROLE AND
I HAD NEVER TAKEN A COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY PROGRAM.
EVERYTHING WAS --
COMMUNITY BASED IT REALLY STRUCK
ME ABOUT THESE ORGANIZATIONS IS
THEM WHEN THEY BRING SURVIVORS
OF CRIME.
INTO THE FACILITIES TO SHARE
THEIR STORIES AND SHARE THEIR
PAIN AND GRIEF.
IT ACTUALLY MADE ME LOOK AT MY
CRIME IN A REAL WAY WHICH IS
REALLY TRANSFORM IF NOT JUST FOR
MYSELF BUT FOR EVERYBODY IN THE
ROOM.
AND WHEN WE COME HOME --
WE ARE WE ARE FOUND SUITABLE WE
BECOME PART OF THESE COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE GIVE BACK WE GO BACK
INSIDE AND WE GIVE HOPE TO
PEOPLE INSIDE WHO HAVE NEVER
SEEN ALIVE FOR GO HOME.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
STATS ON THAT --
SOME DATA COLLECTED ON ON OUR
IMPACTS ON OUR COMMUNITIES
INSIDE AND ALSO ON THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE IMPACT OUT
HERE IN A POSITIVE WAY.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS NAY WILLIAMS.
I'M IS I GUESS DIRECTOR OF
CHOICE FOR FREEDOM I SPENT
THIRTY TWO YEARS IN PRISON. ONE
OF THE FIRST JUVENILES THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS TRIED AS AN ADULT.
I SPENT THIRTY TWO YEARS WHEN I
AND I'VE NEVER BEEN PARTNER IS
KATA KATA COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
PROGRAM IS WILL.
THE PROGRAMS THAT HELP ME WE'RE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION LIKE THIS JIM COME
UP BEHIND ME.
IN THIS PROGRAM CALLED MULTI
CULTURAL TAUGHT ME ABOUT.
BUT WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT ABOUT.
ARM THIS IS ALWAYS A YEARS OR MY
FATHER'S ABUSE MY MOM SO A WIN
IS A LOT OF TRAUMA AND I HAD ON
HIS MASS LIKE EVERYBODY IN MY
COMMUNITY AND I IN AND LED ME TO
PRISON.
I HAD IS MASS WOMAN PRISONS
LIKABLE SICK I WAS HEARTENED AND
HIS MEN CAME IT WAS PROGRAM
TALKING ABOUT.
COMMUNITY TALK ABOUT ON HILL AND
TALK ABOUT HURT PEOPLE HURT
PEOPLE I WAS HURT.
FROM EIGHT YEARS OLD TO ADULT IN
PRISON.
AND DIDN'T UNDERSTAND A CALL
SPECTERS OF HOW I WOUND UP IN
PRISON.
WE'RE GOING.
TO COURT TO COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS.
ALLOW ME TO RETHINK A IN HEAR
OTHER RACES COMING TOGETHER AND
BRING IN HEALING AND TODAY THIS
MAN IS PART OF MY MOM I'M I'M A
PRODUCT OF THE COMMITTEE BASE.
THAT THIS MAN HELP ME TO BECOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN I STARTED THIS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
MONIES.
THE NEAR NINE AND HONDA THIS --
THE DIRECTOR OF SANTA CRUZ
BODIES NEEDLES.
INTO A ONE OF THE MY MAN I WANT
TO COMMIT COUPLE TIME COUPLE
WAYS ONE IS AS ALSO IS A FAMILY
MEMBER.
OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND NAY
AND ONE IN COLLEGE THAT WAS ME.
AND I WAS BLESSED TO BE THAT
INDIVIDUAL.
UP FOR FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE YOU --
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN GOING TO DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS ON A VOLUNTEER
BASIS WE DON'T ACCEPT ANY ANY
MONIES FROM US TO THE C. R..
WE GO OUT AND GET OUR OWN
FUNDING THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR CELL WE HAVE YARD SALES.
THING IS OUR RELATIVES ARE THERE
THEY'RE SUFFERING THEY NEED TO
COME HOME --
DURING THIS PROCESS OF LOS
SEVENTEEN OF MY RELATIVES TO
VIOLENCE SO I KNOW WHAT THAT IS
YOU KNOW BUT WHEN YOU DEDICATE
YOUR LIFE EITHER YOU GO ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER WHEN YOU DEDICATE
YOUR TIME.
TO DEAL WITH THAT TRAUMA.
AND JUST LIKE MADE SAID MATE
WILLIAMS AND MANY OTHERS NAY
IT'S AN LAWS THAT THE HEAD
CONVERSATION WAS THIS MORNING
BEFORE I CAME OVER HERE. TO US
SAID WELL IF YOU HAD A MINUTE
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TODAY.
AND THEY WERE VERY VERY SQUARE
THAT COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
LIVES YOU KNOW IT'S MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN.
IN MY LIFE IN TERMS OF HOW I
DEAL WITH IT I'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM.
THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE GO
INTO THIS INSTITUTION SO I WOULD.
VERY MUCH SUPPORT OF THE
PROGRAMS AND FIT THAT IT IT
TAKES IT TAKES HEART AND SPIRIT
CULTURAL SPIRITUAL AWARENESS
THERE WE ARE.
YOU KNOW TRULY HUMAN BEINGS IN
THIS IS THE INSTITUTIONS WITH
THE NOT ALLOWED TO CRY SO A LOT
OF THINGS OUT LEAVE IT WAS THIS.
LATTER THE TOES SOME OF THE
FELLOWS THIS IS YOU CAN'T CRY A
CRY FOR YOU YOU KNOW AND I SAID
THAT TO FOR YOU.
AND THAT'S THE TRAUMA BUILT IN
THOSE MOST BILLS OF HEART THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S KEITH WIDELY
I'M THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ON COMMON LAW.
WHERE --
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WORKS
WITH PEOPLE SERVING LIFE
SENTENCES THIS IS A GROUP THAT --
IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT --
OMITTED THE PROGRAMS.
THAT FOCUS ON PEOPLE SERVING
LONG SENTENCES IS CUTE INCLUDING
LICENSES AND REPRESENTED --
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE THE
TRANSFORMATIVE WORK --
THAT CAN GET THEM OUT OF PRISON --
YOU'VE ACTUALLY HEARD FROM A
COUPLE OF OUR FOR OUR FORMER
CLIENTS ALREADY TODAY.
I SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE TO
THE COMMITTEE FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
BUT ONE EMPHASIZES FOUR MINUTE
SOME WHAT YOU HEARD.
TODAY JUST --
THE IMPORTANCE OF OF UNRESOLVED
TRAUMA WHEN THE ROLE IT PLAYS IN
THIS THIS CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
INCARCERATION.
AND THE ROLE OF OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS FOR SURE AND
HELPING TO RESOLVE THAT PROBLEM
IT'S IT'S THE CORE OF WHAT WE
ALL DO --
AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
TWENTY YEARS IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
SO MANY PARTNERS.
OF DOING THIS WORK BECAUSE IT'S
WHAT'S MAKING A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IN THIS POPULATION IT HAS BY FAR
THE LOS RECIDIVISM RATES ONCE WE
GET A CHANCE TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO I URGE.
BETTER IDENTIFICATION OF THE
ROLE OF DRAMA AND BETTER SUPPORT
FOR THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE OR
HELPING TO ADDRESS IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE CORNER I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
FOR THE ACTORS GANG PRISON
PROJECT THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY --
A COUPLE OF THINGS WE ARE --
A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED THEATER
ARTS PROGRAM THAT CURRENTLY
SERVES --
TWELVE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
FRONT YARDS WE'VE BEEN
PROGRAMMING FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
AND AND WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO DO
THIS BECAUSE OF THE FUNDING THAT
CAME ABOUT IN. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FOR ARTS IN CORRECTIONS
AND INNOVATIVE PROGRAMMING
GRANTS SO WE WERE ABLE TO GO
FROM VOLUNTEERING TO ACTUALLY
BEING ABLE TO SEE --
GO THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
PROVIDE PROGRAMMING --
WE ARE ALSO ONE OF THE FEW --
ORGANIZATIONS THAT --
IT ACTUALLY --
HAS THE SOME DATA THAT WE CAN --
PROVIDE WE AS A NON PROFIT IT'S
EXTREMELY HARD AND COSTLY TO GET
DATA -- BUT
SO WE HAVE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE HAD A US CDC ARE DID
A PRELIMINARY STUDY.
THAT SHOWED A 10% RECIDIVISM BUT
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO PUBLISH
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A SMALL
SAMPLE SIZE LESS THAN A HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
SO -- WE
ALSO IMPACT JUSTICE DID A STUDY
FOR US AND OF OUR PROGRAM THERE
WERE -- IS A
ADOPTION IN --
BEHAVIORAL INFRACTIONS --
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY WE FOR
OUR REENTRY PROGRAM --
WE HAD A STUDY DONE AT ARE RE
ENTRY FACILITY IN WALDEN HOUSE
AND 77%.
OF THE THE GENTLEMAN THAT HAD
COMPLETED OUR PROGRAM FOUND
EMPLOYMENT OR INTER TO TRADE
AFTER OUR PROGRAM AS OPPOSED
2405% -- BUT
DID NOT COMPLETE ALL THIS TO SAY
THAT --
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING NEEDS
FUNDING AND SUPPORT FROM CDC ARE
AND THE STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS FOR HIS
FOLLOW AT ON THE TEACHING ARTIST
WITH THE ACTORS GANG --
PRISON PROJECT.
AND I STARTED PARTICIPATING IN
SELF HELP GROUPS AROUND.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT APPROXIMATELY
TEN YEARS AND MY SENSE AND I
PARTICIPATED IN A LOT OF ANY A A
A LOT OF THE STANDARD PROGRAMS
THAT THE PERSON HAD TO OFFER.
BUT IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE TICKET
EIGHT WEEK WORKSHOP WITH THE
ACTORS GANG PER THE LOCATION
CENTER.
BASICALLY CHANGED MY LIFE AND
YEAH I LEARN MORE ABOUT MYSELF
IN EIGHT WEEKS --
THAN THE PROGRAMS I WAS TAKING
ALTOGETHER AND OBSERVE THAT MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS I WAS INVOLVED
IN -- COULD
HAVE LIKE A PASSIVE APPROACH AND
IT REALLY DIDN'T HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON ME -- AND
I REALLY DIDN'T LEARN MUCH.
OF THE ACTORS GETTING WAS
DIFFERENT THEY TOOK AN ACTIVE
APPROACH IN GETTING --
MEN AND WOMEN ENGAGE IN
EXPLORING THE FOUR STATES
PROMOTION HAPPY SAID FAR FEAR
AND ANGER --
WHICH IS AT THE CORE OF OUR
CURRICULUM.
OF THE STUDENTS ARE GIVEN A SAFE
SPACE TO EXPLORE MOTION.
OF THAT HAS BEEN SUPPRESSED FOR
YEARS OR EVEN DECADES --
THESE EMOTIONS IF NOT HANDLED
THE SAFE WAY SOMETIMES CAN
TRIGGER.
A REVERSAL AT YOUR REVERSIBLE
EPISODES.
OUR WORK PRODUCES PROFOUND
BREAKTHROUGHS WITHOUT SINGLING
ANYONE'S EXPERIENCE OUT THAT
EVENTUALLY THIS WORK IS
TRANSMITTED INTO THEIR DAILY
LIVES.
BECAUSE THE MENTAL MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL BODIES.
EXPERIENCE THE MOTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DORMANT FOR A LONG TIME
THIS IS THE MAGIC OF THIS CLASS.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY THAT A WHEN
I TOOK THE CLASS THERE WAS NO
FUNDING. FOR THIS PROGRAM.
SO I DID EIGHT WEEKS THEY LEFT
AND I DIDN'T SEE HIM FOR ABOUT A
YEAR SO I STARTED MY OWN THEATRE
COMPANY.
AND WHEN THEY CAME BACK THE USED --
MY FORMAT WHICH WAS JUST AN ILL
TAG AND A IN ME LEISURE TIME
ACTIVITY GROUP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE ALL
WELL OVER A MINUTE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A GERMAN LANKA
AND I AM DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMMING
FOR THE ACTORS CAN PRISON
PROJECT.
I JUST RETURNED FROM OUT AN ALL
STATE PRISON WHERE I FOUND OUT
THAT --
FOURTEEN MEN WHO HAVE BEEN IN
THE PROGRAM THERE FOR TWO YEARS --
WEAPON BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
ALL FOURTEEN FOURTEEN OF THEM
WERE FOUND SUITABLE THAT'S 1100% --
AND NONE OF THEM HAVE RETURNED
SO.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS THAT
OVER THE COURSE OF DOING THIS
FOR EIGHT YEARS I HAVE SEEN?
THAT THE BIGGEST COMPONENT THAT
CREATES COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMMING IS THE STAFF OF CDC
ARE YOU ASKED IF ON CITIES YOUR
HAS THE CAPABILITY TO STAFF
PROGRAMMING AND I THINK --
ON AN UPPER MANAGEMENT LEVEL
ABSOLUTELY I STARTED TO SEE A
HUGE SHIFT IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS --
WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IS
TRAINING AT THE ACADEMY FOR THE
CADETS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
FACILITATING OPENING CELLS?
MAKING SURE THESE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WANT TO CLASSES I THINK WHEN
THAT HAPPENS.
WE'LL SEE THE SHIP WILL BE IN
FULL EFFECT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DAVE MEASURE ON THE
CEO OF A NONPROFIT CALLED THE
CATALYST FOUNDATION IN LANCASTER
CALIFORNIA.
WE PROVIDE UP A LOT OF SERVICES
TO THE COMMUNITY AND HONESTLY
YOU KNOW THE MOST POWERFUL
THINGS THAT I SEE HAPPEN WITH
ARE IN PRISON WORK.
ON MORE IN THIRTEEN FACILITIES
WERE NOT FUNDED FOR MOST OF THEM.
I'VE PERSONALLY BEEN TEACHING
CLASSES AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON LOS ANGELES COUNTY AT
LANCASTER FOR SIXTEEN
CONSECUTIVE YEARS EVERY SINGLE
WEEK I'LL BE THERE TOMORROW.
AND THE POWERFUL TRANSFORMATION
THAT I SEE IN THE IN THE
BEAUTIFUL INMATES WHO WHO HAVE
THE GUTS TO LOOK INSIDE.
AND EVALUATE THEMSELVES HONESTLY
AND MAKE CHANGE IS IS IT'S
AMAZING THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S GIVEN TO ON A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IS A
PITTANCE.
THERE'S NO MONEY TO DO ANY OF
ALLEYWAY TIONS ARE STUDIES IT'S
EXTREMELY LIMITED I THINK ON
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS DOING A
LOT OF REALLY GREAT THINGS WE
SEE IT.
AND WE ALSO SEE THINGS JUST AS
WERE MENTIONED.
GUYS CAN'T GET TO THE CLASSROOM
BECAUSE AND FEEL LIKE RELEASING
THE INMATES TO THE CLASS.
THEN THERE DROP FROM THE FROM
THE PSALMS LAST ON FROM THE FROM
THE CLASS ROSTER.
IF THEY MESS AND DON'T SHOW UP
SO THERE ARE YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPROVEMENT
THAT CAN BE MADE ON THE GROUND
AS WELL -- I
DO IT FOR SIXTEEN YEARS STRAIGHT
BECAUSE I SEE THE CHANGE THAT
HAPPENS IN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
IT'S IT'S POWERFUL OTHERS.
I KNOW RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW FOURTEEN GUYS THAT I'VE
WORKED WITH DIRECTLY ALL GOT
THEIR SENTENCES COMMUTED AND THE
COMMENTS BY THE BOARD OF PAROLE
WHEN THEY WHEN THEY TALK TO THEM
IS LIKE.
THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF TRAUMA IS
REMARKABLE THANK YOU THANK YOU
WERE.
RATHER.
DIFFICULT POINT AT THIS.
LET ME JUST SIMPLY SAY IF YOU'RE
ADDING ON TO WHAT THEY'VE SAID
TRY TO LISTEN CAREFULLY BECAUSE
WE WE WE GETTING THE MESSAGE
THAT THE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE INADEQUATELY
FUNDED.
ARE AFFECTED PROVIDE A SERVICE
THAT DOES NOT FOUND ELSEWHERE.
AND THAT WE NEEDED TO REASSESS
THAT SO I'M HOPING EVERYBODY
KNOWS WE'VE HEARD THAT MANY MANY
TIMES.
I HOPE THE GENTLEMAN WHO'S TALL
IN THE BACK [inaudible]
AND AND EVERYBODY KNOWS WHO WE
TALKING ABOUT OKAY SHOULDN'T BE
ANY QUESTION OF SO I HOPE THAT'S
THE LAST PERSON SO PEOPLE AREN'T
STILL JUMPING INTO THE LINE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM.
IT'S ARE ALMOST FIVE THIRTY
RIGHT NOW SO PLEASE MAKE IT
SHORT THANK YOU YES GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS EMILY HARRIS I'M WITH
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND I HAVE BEEN.
VOLUNTEERING AND PRISONS AND
JAILS FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS IN BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND IN MICHIGAN AND I
JUST WANTED.
TO I WILL I WILL REEMPHASIZE THE
PEACE AROUND I'M SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITY A LEAD.
TO A ORGANIZATIONS FOR LEADING
PROGRAMS BUT I WANT TO REALLY
TALK ABOUT --
WHAT YOU ALL COULD BE DOING TO
CREATE A CULTURE AND AND A PLACE
THAT WHAT NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED
ISN'T JUST ABOUT RECIDIVISM
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT INDICATOR
BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
INDICATOR OF A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM -- I
THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OTHER
PRO SOCIAL FACTORS ARE PEOPLE
MORE CONNECTED TO THEIR FAMILIES
ARE THERE DIFFERENT RACE
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE PRISONS --
AND REALLY TALKING TO THE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN THERE YOU
CAN FIND OUT THE BEST PROGRAMS
BY TALKING TO FIVE PEOPLE ON
EACH YARD YOU'LL KNOW WHICH ARE
THE BEST PROGRAMS IN CDC ARE --
BUT I THINK ADDITIONALLY FOR
CULTURE THE CULTURE AROUND --
THE PROGRAMMING IS AROUND
LOCKDOWNS ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ALLOWED INTO
THE PRISON TO LEAD PROGRAMS ARE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO THEIR PARTICIPATION --
HOW ARE THE GUARDS TREATING THE
VOLUNTEERS AND LOOKING AT SOME
OF THOSE FACTORS ARE ACTUALLY
GONNA PROBABLY BE BETTER
INDICATORS FOR YOU ESPECIALLY
SINCE SOME OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE?
AND VALUABLE PROGRAMS DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO NECESSARILY BE
IT BE EVIDENCE BASE BUT I WOULD
SAY.
THE PERSON'S ALTERED AT SAN
QUENTIN THEIR PROGRAMS THERE'S
INCREDIBLE STUFF THERE AND SOME
OF IT DIDN'T HAVE IT WASN'T AN
EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULUM COMING
IN BUT IT WAS A CREATIVE GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY
COMMITTED.
AND I WOULD JUST HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT YOU RESOURCE THAT
TYPE OF WORK THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ALEX THàNH I'M
THE FOUNDER OF POLLS FOR LIFE.
CANINE RESCUE LIKE MANY OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
POLLS FOR LIKE PROGRAMS KEEPING
FAMILIES TOGETHER PROVIDING
ACCESS TO HEALING AND TEACHING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY WHILE PREPARING
PEOPLE TO BE TENSE THEY
COMMUNITY.
WE DON'T JUST SAVE THE LIVES OF
PRECIOUS ON TO ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NONPROFITS PROVIDING THE
SINGLE MOST NEED TO TOOL WITHIN
THE PRISON SYSTEM.
QUALITY AND REHABILITATION OUR
ORGANIZATIONS TAKE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE COMMUNITY
VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE FEEL LIKE
THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE.
BACK TO SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS WITH
MORE SUSTAIN FUNDING.
SO AND I THINK WITHOUT ALL THESE
PROGRAMS YOU ALL WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO WAKE TOGETHER AND CREATE
THE PROGRAM AND THAT WILL BE
ACTUALLY CREATING THAT I'M NOT
THE RESULTS THAT WE HAVE TODAY
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DIANE WILD I'VE
BEEN GOING INTO PRISON FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS AND I AM
REPRESENTING BUDDHIST PATHWAYS
PRISON PROJECT OF A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TAKE ON ALL OF THIS.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THERE'S A
FIVE FATES POLICY BUDDHISM IS
NOT ONE OF THE FACE THAT IS
RECOGNIZED BY CDC ARE WE COME IN
WITH OUR OWN EFFORTS WE HAVE
PEOPLE OF ALL FAITHS COME TO OUR
GROUP BECAUSE WERE NONTHEISTIC.
IN WE DEAL WITH TRAUMA DALY
MINDFULNESS AND MEDITATION.
AND AS OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
MENTIONED WE GET SUCH GREAT
RESULTS BECAUSE AS THE MEN SAY
YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
BE HERE NOBODY'S PAYING YOU.
BUT YOU CARE ABOUT US AND I
THINK THAT MAKES SUCH A
DIFFERENCE IN ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMMING WHEN PEOPLE HONESTLY
REALLY CARE SO WE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE SOME GRANTS.
SOMETHING TO KEEP US GOING
BECAUSE WE GO TO A LOT OF
OUTLINED PRISONS WERE IN TWENTY
TWO PRESENTS RIGHT NOW.
AND IT'S A HUGE EFFORT TO TRY TO
DO THIS FOR SMALL ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI THANKS FOR ON CONTINUING TO
LISTEN TO THE PUBLIC MY NAME IS
ANNA ON THEM WITH THE W. HEY
WOOD BURNS INSTITUTE --
MORE BASED IN OAKLAND AND I JUST
WANTED TO UP LEFT AND REITERATE
SOMETHING THAT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SOUSA AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE EMILY JUST.
STATED THAT THAT.
WE REALLY SHOULDN'T JUST BE
LOOKING AT RECIDIVISM AS ONLY
METRIC OF SUCCESS --
WE'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE TALKING
AS IN FAMILY ENGAGE MEN --
YOU SEE THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN
THIS ROOM AMONG FOLKS WHO ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND SO ALL
OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE
LOOKED AT AND IF YOU'RE GONNA --
CONSIDER FINDING LONGITUDINAL
STUDY THAT IS LOOKING AT
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS I WOULD
REALLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
ENGAGING THE FOLKS IN THIS ROOM
AND THE CBO IS PROVIDING
SERVICES AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND NOT JUST
IN BEING.
SUBJECTS OF THE STUDY BUT IN
DESIGNING THE STUDY SO YOU CAN
LOOK AT THE YOU KNOW YOU
ACTUALLY DESIGN A STUDY THAT
LOOKS AT THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND DOESN'T JUST HONE IN ON
RECIDIVISM.
THANK YOU.
I GET AFTERNOON CAITLYN DUNKLEY
I AM THE COORDINATOR OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE PRISON IN PRISON
WORK GROUP THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME THIS AFTERNOON.
I JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS --
ARE THE RECENT R. F. P. PROCESS
FOR THE INNOVATIVE GRANTS
PROGRAMS WHICH GRANTED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR THE COMMUNITY GROUPS SOME OF
WHOM YOU SEE IN THE ROOM.
THERE IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF GRANT PROPOSALS PUT
IN FROM COMMUNITIES COMMUNITY
STAND READY TO CONTINUE TO CARRY
THIS WORK.
AND DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S MONEY LEFT ON THE TABLE
THROUGH THE C. B. T. PROGRAMS
COMMUNITIES ARE FIGHTING FOR
THIS FOUR MILLION --
AND I REALLY WANNA ALSO ECHO
THAT THE THIS IS THE RESULT OF
COMMUNITY GROUPS WHAT YOU SEE
HERE IN THE ROOM YOU SEE PEOPLE
COMING HOME FROM PRISON.
BEING EMPLOYED BY THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT.
DURING THEIR TIME AND THIS IS
REALLY THE KIND OF NETWORKING
REENTRY BRIDGING THAT WE'RE
LOOKING.
FOR I'M AND FINALLY JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT ONLY HAVING
RECIDIVISM AS A METRIC IS NOT
GOING TO GET US THE RESULTS IN
TRUE I AND NOW THIS IS THAT WE
NEED.
SO CHALLENGE --
ALL OF US TO CONTINUE THE URGE
TO PARTNER FOR AN OUTSIDE
RESEARCH INTO TWO INSTITUTION
AND TO LOOK BEYOND JUST THE
METRIC OF RECIDIVISM FOR REALLY
HOLISTIC PICTURE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS GREG
FEDERAL WITH INITIATE JUSTICE --
I WANT TO ECHO ALL THE COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE TODAY AND YOU
KNOW FOR THEIR WORK THE REQUEST
FOR VERY MODEST SUM OF TEN
MILLION TO EXPAND THESE PROGRAMS.
I'M I ALSO WANTED TO SHARE THAT
AS AN UNDERGRAD I SPENT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AT SAN QUINTIN IN A
SERVICE LEARNING PROJECT.
AND ALL OF THE RESOURCE IS AN
AMAZING PROGRAMS THERE --
YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD ALL THE
EVIDENCE TODAY ALL THE ANECDOTAL
RESEARCH OUT VERY HELPFUL AND
VERY YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD WORK --
BUT THAT ALL THAT ALL THOSE
PROGRAMS --
SHOULD NOT REALLY BE THE
EXCEPTION THAT SHOULD BE THE
NORM.
UNLESS ONE TO LET THAT BE KNOWN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ITEMS INTO
CONSIDERATION YEAH I WANTED --
TO BE AND WE'LL MOVE ON NEXT OUR
INSPECTOR GENERAL BUT AS SOME OF
YOU MAY BE LEAVING.
I DON'T WANT TO DOWNPLAY THE
IMPORTANCE OF I'M A METRIC OF
RECIDIVISM --
BECAUSE IS IT.
IT IS THE FINAL PRODUCT OF ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PERSON WHO IS WHOLE
AGAIN WHO'S DEALING WITH THE
ISSUES THAT GOT THEM THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE WE'RE BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FAMILIES
KNOWS THAT.
THOSE THEN.
CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
PERSON TO HAVE REDUCES THAT
ABYSS IT DID NOT GO BACK INTO
THE SAME LIFESTYLE THAT THEY
ONCE WERE IN AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO EVEN
THOUGH IT SOUNDS LIKE --
YOU ONLY HAVE ONE METRIC THAT
MEET BASICALLY IS WE ARE TO
REHABILITATE.
IF WE ARE TO ONCE AGAIN GO BACK
AND TRY TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
TRAUMA AND TO CREATE PERSONS WHO
ARE HOLD AND PRODUCTIVE AND
HAPPY AND WITH FAMILY.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S REALLY THAT'S
WHAT REHABILITATION IS ALL ABOUT
ANDONE OF THE WAYS YOU LOOK AT
IT IS DO THEY WANT TO GO BACK OR
DO THEY GO BACK.
INTO WHAT THEY'VE DONE BEFORE --
AND IS THE SCOPE BECAUSE WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IS A CYCLE OF PEOPLE
GOING BACK IN AFTER BEING OUT
AND SO OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE NOT
DONE THE WORK.
THAT THAT --
THAT WE NEED TO DO IT WILL FIND.
AS WE CHANGE NOT JUST THE
PUNISHMENT BUT TRULY FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC BUT ALSO TO HELP TO
REBUILD LIVES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK
RECIDIVISM IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T DEMONSTRATES
TO US IN SOME WAY THAT SOMETHING
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN HELPING
PEOPLE STAY AWAY FROM THAT
LIFESTYLE AND TO MOVE ON TO A
NOTHER.
LEVEL WHICH IS A DEALING WITH
FAMILY AND RESPONSIBILITY AND
THEMSELVES AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON SO THAT'S WHY RECIDIVISM TO
US IS IMPORTANT.
AW AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT OF
MONEY ALWAYS BUT REALLY ABOUT
REBUILDING LIVES AND THAT'S WHAT
WE HOPE TO DO THAT THEN WE A
BILL TATIAN. ONE OF THE WAYS WE
MEASURE.
OKAY AND ALL THE THINGS YOU'VE
TALKED ABOUT FACTORED INTO THAT.
THIS IS NOT JUST GOING TO A
PROGRAM AND COMING OUT AND NOT
GOING BACK IT'S REALLY DEAL
ITSELF AND MOST OF YOU'VE
MENTIONED IT ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS OKAY.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR OUR THIRD
ITEM WHICH IS A THE LAST ONE
WOULD EXPECT I'M SORRY WHAT IS
THE STATE AND YOU COULD EVEN
TRANSITION.
BUT I JUST GO BACK TO SEE TO SEE
ARE THE ONE THE ONE QUESTION IS
THIS GET GIVEN THE THAT THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE THERE OTHER QUALITATIVE
MEASURES I MEAN I KNOW WE FOCUS
A LOT OF POLITICS QUALITATIVE
AND I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
DOCTOR MEMBERS COMMENTS.
BUT ARE THERE QUALITATIVE
MEASURES AS PART OF THAT --
STUDY AND IF THERE ARE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO LATER YEAH I'VE
I'VE WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
QUALITATIVE MEASURES AND THAT'S
PART OF THAT THE THE RECIDIVISM.
AND HOLISTIC STUDY WE'RE LOOKING
AT WE HAVE A MEETING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
SPEAK WITHOUT CONVERSATION WILL
BE FURTHER BECAUSE WE THINK THAT
CULTURE CHANGESHAPPENING IN
PRESENT AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO TRY MEASURE THAT AS WELL.
WE ALSO HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE REPORT TO DEVELOP
PERFORMANCE METRICS --
FOR VARIETY OF KIND OF DIFFERENT
GOALS WE WANTED TO SET.
THANK YOU FOR IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR THE ITEMS
THE TRIP THREE AND FOUR TOGETHER
DEALS WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL --
AND I AM THREE BOOK INSPECTOR
GENERAL GIVE US AN OVERVIEW AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY OF WE WOULD OF
WILL ALSO PROVIDE US WITH
INFORMATION CONCERNED SALINAS
VALLEY STATE PRISON.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING THOSE
WHO LEAVING THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR INPUT.
GOOD FOR YOU ALL AGAIN.
NUMBER PUBLIC COMPANIES.
KNOW IT.
WELL DEPENDS ON YOUR INTEREST
LEVEL.
OKAY. ONE BEGIN YES GOOD EVENING
I'M RIGHT WESLEY I'M THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY.
I'M PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH INFORMATION
REGARDING MY AGENCY AND ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
I WILL FIRST PROVIDE A SHORT
HISTORY OF THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL PROVIDE A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF OUR CURRENT
JURISDICTION.
AND THEN SHIFT TO A REVIEW OF
OUR LATEST REPORT ON THE SPECIAL
REVIEW OF SALINAS VALLEY STATE
PRISONS PROCESSING.
OF INMATE ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT.
I PROVIDED YOU WITH TO HAND OUT
TO COVER THESE AREAS ONE IS A
QUICK REFERENCE ON WHAT WE DO
AND THE SECOND IS A SUMMARY OF
OUR REPORT.
THIS AGENCY WAS FIRST
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR AS A SUBDIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS THE DUTIES WERE TO
FORM SOME INVESTIGATIONS REVIEW
POLICY AND PERFORM MANAGEMENT
AUDITS MANAGEMENT REVIEW AUDITS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AS A
RESULT OF LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS
REGARDING CONCERNS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE OFFICE WAS MOVED OUTSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT AND WAS MADE AN
INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY.
WITH JURISDICTION FOR OVERSIGHT
OF THE DEPARTMENT AT THAT TIME
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS GIVEN
DISCRETION TO CONDUCT AUDITS.
AND INVESTIGATIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR IN RESPONSE
TO THE FEDERAL COURT IN THE
MADRID CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT THE
O. I. G.'S JURISDICTION WAS
EXPANDED. TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
TO THE DEPARTMENT'S INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION AND DISCIPLINE
PROCESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
LEGISLATION RESTRUCTURED THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE AGENCY.
THE RG BUDGET WAS CUT BY 45% AND
OUR STAFFING WAS ALSO REDUCED BY
ABOUT HALF.
OUR DISCUSSION TO CONDUCT AUDITS
INVESTIGATIONS WAS ELIMINATED
AND OUR STATUTORY DUTIES WERE
REDUCED. TO A DELINEATED LIST OF
FUNCTIONS WHICH INCLUDED
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
PERFORMANCE SPECS SHINS OF THE
PRISON MEDICAL SYSTEM.
WE NOW PERFORM ONLY THE DUTIES
DESCRIBED ON THE HANDOUT THAT I
PROVIDED.
AND WE HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO
PERFORM OTHER OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
TURNING TO THE SALINAS VALLEY
REVIEW AGAIN ARE PROVIDED A
SHORT SUMMARY OF THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN A RECENT CDC OUR CASE A
FEDERAL JUDGE SUCCINCTLY DEFINED
DUE PROCESS AS QUOTE GENERALLY
SPEAKING.
THE AIM OF DUE PROCESS IS
PROTECTION OF THE INDIVIDUAL
AGAINST ARBITRARY GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS UNQUOTE.
SOMEONE WHO'S INCARCERATED DOES
NOT LOSE THEIR DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS SIMPLY AS A RESULT OF
BEING IMPRISONED.
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS THERE'S
BEEN CONCERNED BY STAKEHOLDERS.
THAT INMATES HAVE NOT BEEN
AFFORDED THEIR DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS CAN A MEANINGFUL
MECHANISM TO BRING STAFF
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS FORWARD TO
THE DEPARTMENT FOR RESOLUTION.
IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MY OFFICE WAS APPROACHED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE.
JOINTLY REQUESTING THAT THE OIG
REVIEW THE END MAKE COMPLAINT
PROCESS.
ABSENT BEING INVITED IN.
WHY'D YOU WOULD HAVE HAD NO
JURISDICTION TO LOOK AT THIS
PROCESS.
HAVING COMPLETED OUR REVIEW WE
HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO DO ANYTHING
FURTHER IN THIS AREA INCLUDING
ANY ONGOING MONITORING OF THE
DEPARTMENTS COMPLIANCE WITH ITS
POLICIES.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
APPEALS INSTRUCTIONAL HANDBOOK
THE OVERALL PURPOSE OF THE IN
MAKE COMPLAINT PROCESS.
IS TO ENSURE TIMELY RESOLUTION
OF COMPLAINTS THAT SAME HANDBOOK
ALSO NOTES.
THAT STAFF MEMBERS DO RIGHTS
PROCESS DUE PROCESS RIGHTS MUST
BE PROTECTED AND THAT THE
COMPLAINT REVIEW PROCESS ALSO
FUNCTIONS. TO EXONERATE STAFF
WHO'VE BEEN FALSELY ACCUSED.
OUR REVIEW OF THE PROCESS
REVEALED A COMPLETE FAILURE OF
THE HIGH LEVEL DUE PROCESS GOALS.
AND THAT THE PROCESS APPEARS
ENTIRELY DRIVEN BY THE PURPOSE
TO EXONERATE STAFF.
WE ALSO NOTED THE DEPARTMENT
KNEW ABOUT MANY OF THE FAILURES
OF THIS PROCESS AS EARLY AS TWO
YEARS BEFORE OUR REVIEW.
WHEN THEY CONVENE A WARDENS
ADVISORY GROUP TO LOOK AT IT?
WE FOUND NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
ACTION TAKEN BEING TAKEN BY
MANAGEMENT ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE WARDS
ADVISORY GROUP PRIOR TO OUR
REVIEW. FOR OUR REVIEW WE
MONITOR ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT INMATE COMPLAINTS OVER A
SIX MONTH PERIOD.
WE RETROSPECTIVELY REVIEWED
SIXTY ONE COMPLAINTS IN WHICH
THE INQUIRIES WERE DONE BY THE
PRISON. FOR THE PERIOD DECEMBER
ONE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THROUGH FEBRUARY 222-820-0018.
THESE WERE PAPER REVIEWS.
OF WORKED AT IT ALREADY BEEN
CONDUCTED.
WE ALSO MONITORED IN PERSON ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
INCREASED THE PRISON INITIATED
FROM MARCH.
ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THROUGH MAY.
THIRTY ONE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
I SHOULD NOTE THAT WE PERFORMED
OUR REVIEW UNDER SIGNIFICANT
RESTRICTION WE WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO BE PRESENT DURING INTERVIEWS
WITH OFFICERS.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY WERE
SUBJECT TO THE COMPLAINT ARE
SIMPLY WITNESSES.
WE HAD NO VISIBILITY IN THIS
MAJOR AREA OF THE PROCESS.
DURING OUR ONSITE MONITORING
PERIOD WE WERE PRESENT FOR ALL
OTHER INTERVIEWS WHEN WE WERE
NOTIFIED.
THERE WERE A FEW INTERVIEWS THAT
WE MISSED BECAUSE OUR STAFF
BECAUSE THE STAFF CONDUCTING THE
INQUIRY NEGLECTED TO NOTIFY US.
FORTUNATELY THAT WAS NOT COMMON.
AFTER COLLECTING ALL OF OUR DATA
THROUGH MONITORING WE ANALYZED
OUR FINDINGS AND USED A
STANDARDIZED SET OF SIX
ASSESSMENT QUESTIONS TO ARRIVE
AT OUR CONCLUSIONS.
THOSE ASSESSMENT QUESTIONS ARE
FOUND ON PAGE THREE OF YOUR HAND
OUT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE WE LOOKED
AT THE DEPARTMENTS AND HEARINGS
TO ITS POLICY.
WE ALSO USED PROFESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIVE STANDARDS TO JUDGE
THE ADEQUACY OF THE IN CORY'S
WHEN THERE WAS NO POLICY ON
POINT.
IN MOST INSTANCES.
THERE WAS NO POLICY TO GUIDE
OFFICERS AND HOW TO PROPERLY
CONDUCT THE INQUIRY.
IF THERE WAS A POLICY WE
CONSIDERED WHETHER IN OUR
OPINION THE POLICY WAS
APPROPRIATE.
BASED ON OUR DATA WE MADE
FINDINGSAND DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS AND CORRECT THEIR
SHORTCOMINGS.
WE FOUND THAT NOT ONLY DOES THE
PROCESS NOT PROVIDE A FAIR AND
IMPARTIAL PARTIAL INQUIRY INTO
THE AND MAKE COMPLAINTS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT AS NOTED ABOVE THE
PROCESS FUNCTIONALLY ACTS TO
PROTECT STAFF FROM THOSE
ALLEGATIONS.
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT STAFF COMPLAIN INCREASE WE
EXAMINED. ONE I'M COREY BEGAN
THE PROCESS.
BUT WAS SENT TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS PRIOR TO THE
PRISON COMPLETING THE INQUIRY.
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
OPEN THE CASE AND INTERVIEWED
THE SUBJECT AND RETURN THE CASE
TO THE HIRING AUTHORITY.
NO VIOLATIONS OF POLICY WERE
FOUND IN THAT CASE.
IN FIVE OTHER INSTANCES
FOLLOWING THE INQUIRY THE HIRING
AUTHORITY FOUND A VIOLATION OF
POLICY.
IN THE FIVE THAT COMPLETED THE
LOCAL PROCESS WERE POLICY
VIOLATIONS WERE FOUND.
TRAINING WAS ORDERED AND FOUR OF
THE CASES IN A LETTER OF
INSTRUCTION WAS ISSUED AND ONE
THAT ONE PERSON RECEIVED HIS
LETTER OF INSTRUCTION TIMELY.
IN THE FOUR CASES WERE TRAINING
WAS ORDERED. FOR THREE OF THE
CASES TRAINING HEARD WHEN OUR
OFFICE CREED THE INSTITUTION FOR
THE TRAINING RECORDS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MONTHS AFTER
WE HAD BEEN ON SITE.
TRAINING WAS CONDUCTED ON THE
DAY WE ASK FOR THE RECORDS.
IN ONE CASE ALTHOUGH THE HIRING
AUTHORITY FOUND A VIOLATION OF
POLICY.
NO OFFICERS WERE IDENTIFIED SO
NO TRAINING WAS PROVIDE.
WE FOUND AT LEAST ONE
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCY IN A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE OF THE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT CASES
THAT'S 92% OF THE CASES THAT WE
REVIEWED.
WE FOUND THE ENTIRE INQUIRY WAS
INADEQUATE AND THE RESULTS
UNRELIABLE FOR DECISION MAKING
AND A HUNDRED AND FOUR CLICK
COMPLAINTS AND THAT'S 55% OF THE
CASES.
THE DEFICIENCIES INCLUDED POOR
INTERVIEWING SKILLS POR EVIDENCE
COLLECTION TECHNIQUES AND REPORT
WRITING SKILLS.
WE MONITORED SIXTY ONE DIFFERENT
OFFICERS WHO CONDUCTED THESE
INCREASE AND FOUND THAT NOT ONE
HAD MEANINGFUL TRAINING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND HOW TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION.
MOREOVER WE FOUND THOSE WHO
CONDUCTED THE INCREASE FOR THE
MOST PART DID NOT FOLLOW SOUND
INVESTIGATIVE TECHNIQUES.
NOR DID THEY PROPERLY GATHER
EVIDENCE OR PREPARE REASON AND
LOGICAL REPORTS.
WE ALSO DIRECTLY OBSERVED ABUSES
IN THE INQUIRY PROCESS WHERE THE
REVIEWERS WERE ARGUMENTATIVE
WITH THE COMPLAINTS.
DID NOT COLLECT A REPORT
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE AND
DISCOURAGED INMATES FROM GOING
FORWARD WITH THE COMPLAINTS.
NONE OF THE INTERVIEWS WERE
RECORDED SO THERE WAS NO WAY TO
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
INTERVIEW.
WHERE -- I
G. WAS NOT PRESENT TO OBSERVE.
FINALLY WE FOUND THAT THE
INCREASE ON THE WHOLE WERE NOT
INDEPENDENT.
WE FOUND IN CORY'S WERE
SUBORDINATES WERE INVESTIGATING
AND MAKE COMPLAINTS ABOUT THEIR
SUPERIOR OFFICERS.
INCREASE THAT WERE CONDUCTED BY
OFFICERS WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE
INCIDENT GIVING RISE TO THE
COMPLAINT.
AN INCREASE CONDUCTED BY
OFFICERS WHO ARE CLOSE COWORKERS
OF THE SUBJECTS.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE ENCOURAGE
WERE NOT KEPT CONFIDENTIAL
GIVING RISE TO CONCERNS ABOUT
RETALIATION AGAINST THOSE WHO
COMPLAINED BY THE SUBJECTS OF
THE COMPLAINTS.
WE FOUND NO TRUE CRITICAL
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROCESS BY
PRISON MANAGERS AND LEADERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING DECISIONS.
OFTEN THE ULTIMATE REVIEWER
SIMPLY RUBBER STAMPED THE
CONCLUSION OF THE OFFICER
CONDUCTING THE INQUIRY.
INSTEAD OF MAKING A THOUGHTFUL
DECISION BASED ON THE FACTS
PRESENTED.
IN FACT WE BELIEVE HAD THE
ULTIMATE DECISION MAKER
CRITICALLY CONSIDERED THE
INFORMATION THEY WERE GIVEN.
THEY WOULD HAVE REACHED THE SAME
CONCLUSION WE REACHED NAMELY
THAT THE INCREASE FOR SO FLAWED.
THAT NO CONCLUSION COULD BE
JUSTIFIED.
BASED ON THE SEVERE AND
PERVASIVE ISSUES WE FOUND WE
MADE A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATION
AND THAT LIST IS AT PAGE FIVE OF
YOUR HAND OUT.
AMONG THE MOST IMPORTANT ARE WE
BELIEVE THE INSTITUTION THAT --
CORRECTION SHOULD RE ASSIGNED
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO CONDUCT IN
MAKE COMPLAINT ENQUIRIES OUTSIDE
THE PRISONS COMMAND STRUCTURE.
THEY SHOULD ADOPT A REGIONALIZED
MODEL FOR STAFFING PURPOSES AS
THEY DO FOR THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
THEY SHOULD PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE AND ONGOING
TRAINING FOR ALL STAFF WHO
PERFORM ENQUIRIES.
THEY SHOULD CONSIDER
CERTIFICATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
FOR THOSE CONDUCTING THE
INCREASE AND A SIGNED IN.
A SIGN INCREASED ONLY TO THOSE
STAFF WHO.
THEY SHOULD REQUIRE AUDIO
RECORDING OF INTERVIEWS OF
SUBJECT TO WITNESS.
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED A
RESPONSE TO OUR REPORT.
THE RESPONSE NOTES THAT THEY DO
NOT DISPUTE THE FACTS THAT WE
PROVIDE.
THEY ALSO AGREE THAT THERE MAY
BE SIMILAR ISSUES PRESENT AT
OTHER INSTITUTIONS.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN A
DETAILED PLAN FOR HOW THE
DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO CORRECT
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE IDENTIFIED.
WE WERE PROVIDED AN EARLY DRAFT
AND I EMPHASIZE THIS IS AN EARLY
DRAFT.
OF PROPOSED POLICY TO SLIGHTLY
REORGANIZE THE APPEALS PROCESS
WITH THE HEADQUARTERS REVIEW HAD
IT.
THE DEPARTMENT ADVISED US THAT
HEADQUARTERS WOULD REVIEW CASES
WHERE THE INMATE DISAGREES WITH
THE FINDING OF THE REVIEWER.
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT THIS
APPROACH DOES NOT REMEDY THE
ABUSES THAT WE OBSERVE WHERE
CORROBORATING EVIDENCE WAS
OMITTED FROM THE FINAL REPORT
AND BIASED QUESTIONS WERE
PRESENTED.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A RECORDED
INTERVIEW OR BEING PRESENT TO
OBSERVE THE INTERVIEW WE BELIEVE
THERE'S NO WAY TO AUDIT WHETHER
THE REVIEWERS PROPERLY
PERFORMING THEIR DUTIES.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE DIALOGUE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT REGARDING
THE AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
DISAGREEMENTS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT.
COME FROM THE PRISON LAW OFFICE
DON SPECTER [inaudible]
IN READ.
OKAY HI MY NAME IS BELOW ME --
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS OF PEOPLE
INCARCERATED.
IN STATE PRISONS COUNTY JAILS
IMMIGRATION DETENTION FACILITIES
AND JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES. ONE OF OUR CASES
AGAINST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS CALLED ARMSTRONG IT'S ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE NINTH
CIRCUIT DESCRIBED THE CASE AS
QUOTE ALL WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
OFFICIALS.
OVER WHETHER DEFENDANTS MUST
PROVIDE DISABILITY
ACCOMMODATIONS INCLUDING BASIC
NECESSITIES OF LIFE FOR DISABLED
PRISONERS.
AS PART OF THAT CASE WE VISITED
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON
TWELVE SEPARATE TIMES OVER THE
LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS FOR A
TOTAL OF THIRTY FOUR DAYS ON
SITE.
CONDUCTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTEEN CLIENT INTERVIEWS.
AND WE RECEIVED OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED LETTERS FROM MY CLIENTS
THERE BUT ISSUES RELATED TO
ARMSTRONG.
WE THEN REPORTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT.
THAT STAFF MISCONDUCT INCLUDED
EVERYTHING FROM EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. TO HARASSMENT AND
VERBAL ABUSE TO RACISM. TO
RETALIATION AND INTERFERING WITH
THE APPEALS PROCESS.
WE SAW NO OR VERY FEW
IMPROVEMENTS IN RESPONSE TO
REPORTS OF WIDESPREAD MISCONDUCT.
ALL TOO OFTEN THE DEPARTMENT
MINIMIZED OR DISMISSED THE
REPORTS AND PROVIDED VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION TO US.
THE SYSTEM APPEAR DESIGNED TO
DISCREDIT THE VICTIMS OF ABUSE
BEHIND BARS.
IT BECAME INCREASINGLY APPARENT
TO US THAT THE STOCK COMPLAINT
PROCESS WAS FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN.
WE AND OUR CLIENTS STARTED TO
WITHHOLD ALLEGATIONS.
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT CONFIDENT
THAT THEY WOULD BE MEANINGFUL
INVESTIGATED.
WE ALSO THOUGHT THERE WAS A REAL
POSSIBILITY THAT OUR CLIENTS
WOULD BE RETALIATED AGAINST.
INCLUDING THROUGH PHYSICAL ABUSE.
I WANT TO GIVE JUST ONE EXAMPLE
THAT I THINK SORT OF PORTRAYS
THE SITUATION WE WERE ON IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN A TRANSGENDER
WOMAN WHO USED A WHEELCHAIR WAS
FOUND DEAD.
IN HER CELL.
SHE WAS IN HER UNDERWEAR WAS
AROUND HER ANKLES HER GENITALIA
WERE EXPOSED.
AND A PENCIL SHOVED IN HER EAR.
INTO THE POST MORTEM REPORT HER
QUOTE HEAD WAS NEAR ELECTRICAL
OUTLET AND THE PENCIL WAS
FASHIONED.
INTO ELECTRICALLY CONDUCTIVE
EMERGING HERE.
POST MORTEM EXAMINATION REVEALED
THE PENCIL TO TRAVEL VERTICALLY
THROUGH HER LEFT EAR AND UNDER
THE JAW FOR EMBEDDING IN THE
ADJACENT MAC.
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATORS
RAISE THE POSSIBILITY THAT
ELECTROCUTION COULD BE THE CAUSE
OF DEATH IF THE PENCIL HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN THE ELECTRICAL OUTLET.
THE CORONER COULD NOT DETERMINE
A CAUSE OF DEATH.
WE AT THE PRISM OFFICE STARTED
TO HEAR FOR OUR CLIENTS ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THIS TOOK
PLACE MANY HAD SEEN WHAT HAD
HAPPENED.
HAD HEARD WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY
AND SAID THAT STOCKTON THE UNIT
HAD PURPOSELY LEFT KNOWING THAT
SOMETHING WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THIS WOMAN.
OUR CLIENTS HOWEVER WOULD NOT
LET US REPORT IT BECAUSE THEY
SAID THE STAFF MISCONDUCT
PROCESS WAS SO BROKEN.
THAT THEY COULD NOT TELL WHETHER
WOULD BE MEANINGFUL INVESTIGATED
OR WHETHER THEY WOULD FACE
RETALIATION.
WE IN CITIES THEIR LEADERSHIP
KNEW THAT UNLESS SERIOUS ACTION
WAS TAKEN.
IN RESPONSE TO OUR CONCERNS WE
WOULD END UP IN COURT.
THEN SECRETARY KERN AND WE
AGREED TO HAVE THE EIICHI
CONDUCTOR OF YOU TO AVOID THAT
TIME.
THE O. I. G.'S REVIEW WAS
THOROUGH OBJECTIVE ACCURATE.
NEITHER WE NOR THE DEPARTMENT
DISPUTE THE O. I. G.'S FINDINGS.
THOUGH I JEEZ REVIEW CONFIRMS
WHAT WE HAVE REPORTED OVER A
YEAR AGO.
AND IDENTIFIED ADDITIONAL
SERIOUS DEFICIENCIES BUT WE DID
NOT KNOW ABOUT OR THAT WE HAD
MERELY SUSPECTED.
IT IS CLEAR AN UNDISPUTED NOW
THAT SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS OF
ABUSE ARE NOT BEING MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESSED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
AGAIN THAT THE AG REVIEW WAS
GREAT IT GIVES A LOT OF
STATISTICS AND DATA BUT I JUST
WANT TO GIVE ONE EXAMPLE.
AND IT'S WE HAD REPORTED MY
OFFICE HAD REPORTED THAT STAFF
TRIED TO FORCE ONE OF OUR
CLIENTS AN ELDERLY BLACK MAN WHO
IS A FULL TIME WHEELCHAIR USER.
OUT OF HIS WHEELCHAIR INTO A
STANDING HOLDING CAGE IN A
SECLUDED LOCATION.
THEY REPORTEDLY PULLED HIM FROM
HIS WHEEL CHAIR AND SLAMMED HIM
ONTO THE GROUND.
OUR CLIENT REPORTED THAT THE
OFFICERS QUOTE SLAMMED MY HEAD
WITH FORCED TO THE GROUND AND
PUMMELED ME.
THEY BEGAN KICKING AND PUNCHING
WHILE I WAS BASED ON THE GROUND
WITH HANDCUFFS ON ONE OFFICER
SAT ON MY FEET AND LEGS.
AND ANOTHER HAD HIS KNEE ON MY
NECK AND BACK WITH HIS BODY
WEIGHT WHILE THE OTHERS KEPT.
THOUGH I G. FOUND THE
DEPARTMENT'S REVIEW OF OUR
CLIENT'S ALLEGATIONS TO BE
INADEQUATE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS THE REVIEWER
FAILED TO INTERVIEW TWO OF THE
OFFICERS ALLEGEDLY INVOLVED IN
THE ALTERCATION.
AND DID NOT ADEQUATELY SUMMARIZE
OUR CLIENTS STATEMENTS IN THE
WRITTEN REPORT.
FURTHERMORE ALTHOUGH THE
REVIEWER IDENTIFIED A VIOLATION
POLICY THE REVIEWER FAILED TO
TAKE ADEQUATE STEPS TO DETERMINE
WHICH STAFF MEMBER HAD VIOLATED
THAT POLICY.
IN ORDER TO AVOID FURTHER
LITIGATION THE ID'S
RECOMMENDATIONS NEED TO BE
ADOPTED.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT IT WILL
COST MONEY BUT IT IS CRITICAL
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND CERTAINLY
LESS EXPENSIVE THAN A LAWSUIT.
THE FEDERAL COURT IN ARMSTRONG
ORDERED CDC ARE OVER SEVEN YEARS
AGO. TO DEVELOP QUOTE AND
EFFECTIVE INTERNAL OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROCEDURE TO THIS
DAY.
THEY HAVE NOT YET DONE SO.
THE O. I. G.'S THOUGHTFUL
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING I
QUOTE COMPLETE OVERHAUL OF THE
STAFF COMPLAINING FOR PROCESS
MUST BE IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY.
WE ARE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LACK OF REVIEWER
INDEPENDENCE AND BIAS AGAINST
OUR CLIENTS.
SOME RESPECT IT'S LIKE THE FOX
GUARDING THE HEN HOUSE THE
REVIEWERS ARE INVESTIGATING
THEIR COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS HE
CAN'T BE EXPECTED TO REMAIN
NEUTRAL.
THOUGH I DO YOU FOUND THE QUOTE
REVIEWERS DEMONSTRATED THEIR
BIAS IN FAVOR OF THEIR CO
WORKERS AND AGAINST INMATES AND
QUOTE FREQUENTLY COMPROMISE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE REVIEW
PROCESS.
POTENTIALLY EXPOSING INMATES TO
RETALIATION FOR FILING A
COMPLAINT.
TOP OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS PROCESS
APPEARS TO WORK REASONABLY WELL
BUT SO FEW ALLEGATIONS MADE IT
THAT FAR.
THE STATE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT MOST THE MOST IMPORTANT
INVESTIGATIONS ARE BEING DONE BY
THE I A THE I A IS ON A SEPARATE
TRACK THAT DOES NOT REYES
INDEPENDENCE CONCERNS.
OF THE INVESTIGATORS THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN TRAINING HIRING AND
PROMOTIONAL LADDER.
IN ADDITION TO THE O. I. G.'S
RECOMMENDATIONS CAMERAS MUST BE
INSTALLED AT SALINAS VALLEY AND
OTHER PRISONS.
OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT THAT MY OFFICE
REPORTED AFTER TWO HOURS AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
ALLEGATIONS CAME BACK SHE HATED.
THAT MEANS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
COULD NOT TELL WHETHER THAT
MISCONDUCT HAD OR HAD NOT
OCCURRED.
THAT SHOULD WERE YOU.
IT MEANS THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
STAFF COMMITTED SERIOUSNESS
CONTACT TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
TIMES WITHOUT BEING CAUGHT.
IMPROVING INVESTIGATIONS THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP BUT IT
IS JUST THAT A FIRST STEP.
EVEN THEN MANY ALLEGATIONS WILL
BE HE SAID HE SAID SITUATIONS
THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE TOLD
GUILTY PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE AND TO
EXONERATE OFFICERS.
IS TO HAVE CAMERAS IN THE
INSTITUTION.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD
THAT -- THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS
DONE TO REVIEWS AT THAT WE'VE
FINISHED TO HELP TO INITIATE.
ONE WAS THROUGH --
THE REQUEST THAT WE PUT WHETHER
WE REQUESTED FROM THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE OF HIGH DESERT
STATE PRISON THAT WHERE THERE
WAS AN INCREDIBLY HIGH LEVEL OF
ABUSE -- AND
THE OTHER ONE WAS OF JUST HEARD --
IN BOTH CASES.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OBJECTIVE REVIEW --
ALLOWED US TO HAVE US SET OF
FACTS WHICH BOTH PARTIES THE
DEPARTMENT AND US.
COULD RELY ON AND IN BOTH CASES
WELL IN THE HIGH DESERT CASE.
THEY TOOK.
A LOT OF REMEDIAL MEASURES THAT
WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING
CONTROL OF THE ABUSE THAT WAS
OCCURRING AT THAT PRISON --
AS INSPECTOR GENERAL WESLEY JUST
SAID HE CANNOT DO THOSE REVIEWS
ON HIS OWN HE HAS TO AT THE
MOMENT HE HAS TO GET.
PERMISSION FROM ME THE THE
SPEAKER OR THE PRESIDENT THE
SENATE IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
THOSE REVIEWS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT AS A WELL WE KNOW THAT WAS
A RESULT OF THE AMENDMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WE THINK THAT
AMENDMENT SHOULD BE REPEALED SO
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AT
HIS DISCRETION.
OR HER DISCRETION CAN --
INITIATE A REVIEW AND SAVE THE
STATE FROM SIMILAR LAWSUITS IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY FOR US TO GET ACT
INFORMATION THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS AND SINCE WE KNOW
THAT THEY BOTH PARTIES KNOW THAT%
THEY DO SUCH AN OBJECTIVE --
REVIEW.
IT WOULD --
I THINK.
A SAVE THE STATE MONEY AND ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS TO
TO FUNCTION IN A MUCH MORE
CONSTITUTIONAL MANNER AT SOME
PLACES THAN THEY ARE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AS LA --
RESPONDING.
ANYTHING LATER TOMORROW WITH THE
BUDGET AND THIS OFFICE WE DIDN'T --
ANALYZE THIS POLICY AREA ALL
RIGHT SOUNDS.
IS THE CD ARE HAVE A RESPONSE.
YES WILL.
LET THEM TAKE YOUR SEATS IF
EARLIER. FOR YOUR HAVE A
RESPONSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN.
SINCE THE SALINAS VALLEY REPORT
I I DO NEED TO SAY THAT --
PRIOR TO THE REPORT BEING
INITIATED WE WERE IN
CONVERSATION HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ALLEGING.
WE MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH --
I. G. ABOUT SALINAS VALLEY
DURING SALINAS VALLEY IN EVEN
POST SALINAS VALLEY ON HOW WE
CAN COME TO A REMEDY IN ADDRESS
IS VERY SERIOUS ISSUES AND
CONCERNS.
THE CASES THAT WERE SIDE BY THE
PLO WE ARE AWARE OF THEM.
WE HAVE BEEN AWARE OF THEM THEY
HAVE BEEN A PART OF OUR
OVERSIGHT AND PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS.
REALLY THE THE OVERSIGHT THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN I JUST NEED TO
BACK UP A LITTLE BIT AND JUST
STATE EVERY SERIOUS INCIDENT
THAT OCCURRED ON THE INSTITUTION
THE O. I. G. HAS NOTIFIED --
SO THE INCIDENTS OCCUR ALL AGES
NOTIFIED IF CASES ARE OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS THEY
FOLLOW THAT PROCESS THROUGH IF
THEY ARE MONITORED AND SELECTED
BY THE IG.
I THINK WHAT --
MISTER WESLEY COMPLAINT PROCESS
ITSELF.
IS THE INQUIRY PROCESS THAT
LEADS UP TO A DETERMINATION
WHETHER IN A BAG AN
INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO OCCUR.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WE AGREE THAT
COULD.
CASES LIKE --
MISTER SPECTER THE PLO AN ORGY
BRINGS FORWARD WE TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WE DO -- WE
DO NEED TO SAY THOUGH THAT --
AS A PART OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE WE DO AGREE THAT THE STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS DOES NEED TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE PRISON ITSELF.
WE DO NEED TO HAVE --
THE INVESTIGATORS A THE TRAIN
THE STAFF SO THEY CAN DO
INDEPENDENT INCREASE ON THEIR
OWN OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON
SETTING --
WE HAVE ALREADY AGREED TO A
PILOT OF THAT AT FIFTEEN
INSTITUTIONS --
WE HAVE THE RANK OF LIEUTENANT
CONDUCTING THOSE.
THERE IS A TRAINING COMPONENT
THAT GOES INTO THAT --
INTO THAT PIECE WHICH THAT
TRAINING IS NOW BEING CONDUCTED
THAT IS BEING POST CERTIFIED AND
WE REMOVE THOSE STEPHANOPOULOS
THEM UNDER.
THE DIVISION OF OVERSIGHT AND
RESEARCH --
THAT SITS WITHIN THE FIFTH FLOOR
THE PROBLEM TO CORRECTION BUT IT
IS WITH IN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS ARENA --
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT IF WE
WANT TO DO THIS --
EFFECTIVELY AND WE WANT TO DO
THIS STATEWIDE WITH SOME
EFFICACY AND TRAINING --
WE HAVE RECOGNIZE THAT ANY
CHANGES THAT THAT ARE GONNA HAVE
TO COME THERE ARE RESOURCES THAT
ARE GONNA HAVE TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM.
BECAUSE I DO NEED TO STATE THAT
WE DO HAVE THE STAFF COMPLAINT
PROCESS.
WHICH IS SEPARATE FROM THE
STANDARD APPEAL PROCESS.
AND THE STAFF THAT TRADITIONALLY
DID THE STAFF COMPLAIN PRIVATE
STAFF COMPLAINTS WERE.
ASSIGNED SUPERVISORY SERGEANTS
AND LIEUTENANTS JUST THROUGHOUT
THE PRISON THEY WERE ASSIGNED
BASED ON AVAILABILITY.
THE APPEALS PROCESS WERE DONE BY
STAFF --
THAT WERE ASSIGNED TO THE
APPEALS OFFICE.
AND THEY DID THE DAY TODAY
APPEALS WHERE THEY MAY BE
APPEALING --
CREDIT ISSUES TELEVISION BROKEN
ISSUES OR LOWER LEVEL APPEALS
BUT WHAT WE FIND IS.
IF WE PULL THOSE STAFF THE
APPEALS THERE'S A RESOURCE ISSUE
IN THOSE ISSUE STILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED SO TRYING TO FIND THE
RESOURCES TO PROPERLY ADDRESS
THE STAFF COMPLAINT HAD HAS BEEN
CHALLENGING.
WE WERE ABLE TO FIND --
REALLOCATE THE POSITIONS
INTERNALLY WITHIN THE PILLS
PROCESS --
FROM INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
LOWER LEVELS APPEALS WE CANNOT
SIGN THEM SO FUNDAMENTALLY WE
AGREED WITH THE O. I. G. IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE MAJORITY
OF THEM.
THERE ARE A FEW THAT WE DO THAT
STILL NEED TO HAVE FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS ON NOW THERE ARE --
LABOR IMPLICATIONS WITH THE
UNIONS WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING
STAFF UNDER TAPE RECORDER.
THAT FALLS MORE INTO THE FULL --
INTERNAL AFFAIRS PIECE THERE ARE
POBRE CONCERNS WITH THAT --
BUT WITH I THINK IT'S A WHOLE.
WE FUNDAMENTALLY AGREE AND I
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS ROLE AND
I ABOUT THIS BUT IT DOES COME
WITH A RESOURCE ISSUE.
AND SO IN TOTAL WE ARE LOOKING
SO AND IN INTERNALLY WE HAVE TO
LOOK INTERNALLY HOW WE CAN
STRUCTURE THIS WE CAN
AFFECTIVELY.
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AND IF
THERE IS A RESOURCE ASK AT WE
WOULD HAVE TO BRIDGE SENSE
SOMETHING MORE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES BUT THE
WHOLE TIME.
COMMUNICATING WITH THE IG TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE ASKING FOR THE
CORRECT THING BUT AT THIS POINT.
TO COME AND ASK FOR ANY
RESOURCES WITHOUT GETTING IN
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION BE
PREMATURE.
BUT I KNOW THAT --
THE FIFTEEN STAFF THAT ARE OUT
COMPLAINTS OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTITUTION THEMSELVES.
UNDER THE DIVISION OF OVERSIGHT
RESEARCH ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WE ARE ALREADY FINDING THAT --
THAT IS OUR TO BECOMING BURDEN
SOME JUST BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT
OF STAFF COMPLAINTS I DO NEED TO
SAY THE SALINAS VALLEY IS.
IS NOT LIKE THE OTHER THIRTY
FOUR INSTITUTIONS IT IS A HIGHER
LEVEL INSTITUTION.
OF THE COMPLAINTS THAT DO COME
OUT OF THERE --
ARE VERY CONCERNING JUST LIKE
THE RIGHT HIGH DESERT BUT I CAN
SAY.
EVEN WORKING WITH THE AND YOU
WITH HIGH DOES IT WE WERE ABLE
TO MAKE SOME SYSTEMATIC CHANGES
THAT I DESERT FIRST OF ALL BY
LEADERSHIP CHANGES IN AT HIGH
DESERT.
WELL WE HAD THE SAME THING THAT
SALINAS VALLEY WE HAD LEADERSHIP
CHANGES THERE.
WE HAD STAFF GOING INTO FOCUS
TRAINING WITH HEADQUARTERS STAFF
IN THE INSTITUTIONS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE ISSUES
ARE NOT BEING SWEPT IN THE RUNS
THAT WE ARE DRESSED
INAPPROPRIATELY.
I THINK HOLISTICALLY TO HAVE THE
TROOPS HELLO IS LOOKING FOR IT
WILL TAKE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MAKE THAT THE TRUE
CHANGE BECAUSE OF THE STAFFING
AND TRAINING --
WE NEED TO GET SOMETHING FROM
THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
SURE WORK OR MAKING THE RIGHT
REQUESTS.
YOU KNOW WHEN I READ THIS IS
SOUND LIKE A NIGHTMARE --
SOUND LIKE EVERY.
PRISON MOVIE I'VE EVER SEEN.
WHAT WITH PEOPLE WITH REAL
ISSUES REAL COMPLAINTS AND A
HIGH LEVEL INTIMIDATION
EVERYBODY'S KIND OF FEEDING INTO
THE SAME?
STORY AND NOBODY'S BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND SO RELEASED IT
SOUNDS VERY --
READ THIS FIRST OF ALL I MEAN
JUST IN.
TERMS OF BASIC THINGS THAT OUGHT
TO HAPPEN IN AN ASSESSMENT AND
EVALUATION YOU KNOW YOU NORMALLY
EVEN.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO HAVE PIERCED
EVALUATE EACH OTHER BECAUSE OF
THE YOU KNOW THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT THEY HAVE AND AND SO
THEREFORE YOU BUILD A SYSTEM
THAT KIND OF FEEDS ON ITSELF IN
IN SOME WAY AND AS A RESULT.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN AND THEY
BECOME EVEN WORSE BECAUSE THEY
BECOME MORE PROTECTED SO AS I
WAS READING THIS AND AS I HAD
HAVE TO MOTHER MEETINGS WITH
INDIVIDUALS IT BECAME.
I REALLY WAS I MEAN IT WAS LIKE
A NIGHTMARE MOVIE OF OF OF THE
GREATEST VIEW YOU HAVE ALWAYS IN
LIFE IS ONE IS GOING TO PRISON.
AND THEN BEING CAPTIVE THERE
WITH PEOPLE WHO DON'T SEEM TO
TREAT YOU FAIRLY AND THEN YOU
HAVE VERY LITTLE WAYS IN WHICH
YOU CAN.
EXPRESS YOURSELF BECAUSE THIS
HIGH LEVEL AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO WHEN I READ THIS IS
JUST LIKE WHOA AND THEN I ASKED
DO WE HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS
IN TERMS OF FROM THE THE FROM.
OF CDC ARE WITH YOU YOU SAY IS
GOING TAKE RESOURCES ISTHINGS
BE MOVES AWAY I DON'T SEE A
PROPOSAL NECESSARY TO FUND THIS
BUT TO ME THIS IS CRISIS AYE AYE
MAYBE IT'S NOT IN IN.
MAY BECAUSE I I YOU KNOW AND I
I'VE BEEN TO A LOT OF PRISONS
WOULDN'T MAYBE IT'S THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE NOT A CRISIS.
FOUGHT TO THOSE WHO ON THE
OUTSIDE BUT TO ME TO THINKING
THAT I WITH OUR WORK IN THE
INSIDE AND CAPTIVE.
AND HAVE ALL OF MY RIGHTS KIND
OF JUST TRAMPLED ON IN A DE
HUMANIZE IN SOME WAYS AND HAVE
LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS THAT I
CAN'T EXPRESS AND I'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY THAT BECAUSE THEN
THERE'S RETALIATION AND YOU
DON'T GET THIS YOU DON'T GET
THAT IN.
YOUR FOLKS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT COMING DEAL WITH PEOPLE.
IS THAT THAT IS FRIGHTENING TO
THINK THAT THAT THAT THERE IS A
REPORT THAT WE HAVE THAT ALMOST
MIRRORS --
SOME OF THESE MOVIES A WE SEE
THAT I'VE SEEN --
THAT REALLY TALK ABOUT THE
INTERNAL WORKINGS OF OF OF OF
INCARCERATED --
INDIVIDUALS IN TERMS OF THE
PRISONS AND AND THE LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ONE EXPRESS
THEMSELVES OR HAVE THEMSELVES
FAIRLY HEARD OR WHATEVER MAY BE
SO I'M CONCERNED AT THAT WE
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE ANYTHING THAT
SAYS THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I'M EQUALLY CONCERNED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE AN X. WHAT
INVESTIGATE THESE THINGS I ME
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS IN THESE
PRISONS MORE THAN ALL OF US
THERE IN ALL THE TIME AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY UNLESS
SOMEBODY ASKED THEM.
AND BY THE TIME THEY GET ASKED
THE PROBLEM IS IS IS HORRIBLE I
MEAN IT IS ESCALATED TO THE
POINT THAT THE SPEAKER OR THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE
GOVERNOR NOW IS AWARE OF THIS
PROBLEM.
WHEN IT GETS TO THAT LEVEL IT
HAS REALLY GONE BEYOND WHERE IT
SHOULD BE BECAUSE THESE KINDS OF
ISSUES SHOULD BE ADDRESSED ON AN
ONGOING BASIS?
IN TERMS OF STRUCTURE AND AND
PROGRAMS AND ASSESSMENT AND
EVALUATION AND ALL THIS KIND OF
THING SO.
I READ THIS WITH WITH WITH GREAT
ALARM I MEAN IT WAS LIKE A
NIGHTMARE TO READ THIS AND AND
THEN TO TALK TO PEOPLE AND HAVE
FOLKS SAY YEAH THAT'S TRUE.
IT OUT OF AND AND IT'S GONNA
TAKE RESOURCES TO CHANGE IT --
WHICH IS TRUE BUT I DON'T SEE A
REQUEST FOR THE RESOURCES SO I
DON'T REALLY SEE THE THE REAL
SERIOUSNESS ABOUT THE CHANGE
MAYBE IT IS SAID MAYBE THIS
SEASON SO COME FROM US.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE DEAL WITH
RESOURCES THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
HOW WE DEAL WITH AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL WHO HAS IT DOESN'T HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO OUT WAS THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
WAS DEMAND YOU KNOW THAT IN
TERMS OF PRISONS THAT THEY WOULD
BE THE PERSON WHO'S IN THERE ALL
THE TIME AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND IF THERE WAS
CORRUPTION IT WOULD BE BECAUSE
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS NOT
DOING HIS JOB.
BUT NOW THAT I DISCOVERED THAT
WE HAVE A NEUTER THIS AT TWO
GENERAL IN SOME WAY TO NOT BE
ABLE TO MONITOR THIS SYSTEM THAT
WE REALLY NEED MONITORING UP.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT THESE KINDS
OF NIGHTMARES THAT ISIS CEILING
TV MOVIES WOULD SAYING SAYING
PRISON OR WHATEVER IT WAS.
IT MAKES ME VERY VERY CONCERNED
VERY CONCERNED AND OBVIOUSLY
SINCE IS NOT BEING ADDRESSED.
IN REQUEST THAT I SEE IT BUT NOT
ALLOW THIS TO CONTINUE.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY ERIN
EDWARDS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
JUST WANT TO PROVIDE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS I I THINK FIRST OF ALL
ONE ECHO.
THE COMMENTS FROM MISTER DE AS
THAT THIS.
THIS THE THESE FINDINGS IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ARE
VERY FIVE VERY TROUBLING WE WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES.
THAT --
URGENTLY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED --
WE THANKED THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
ON THE PLO FOR BRINGING THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION --
AS MISTER DE AS INDICATED WE ARE
EVALUATING THE PASSED OPTIONS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
ARE IT IS LIKELY TO REQUIRE SOME
RESOURCES [inaudible]
AND WE ABSOLUTELY THANK THAT IF
IT DOES REQUIRE RESOURCES WE
WILL BE PROVIDING THOSE
RESOURCES THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE --
AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND FOLKS
THAT THERE ARE REALLY SORT OF
TWO POINTS IN TIME THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION COMES FORWARD
WITH REQUESTS IN THE BUDGET --
THE FIRST BEING THE JANUARY
BUDGET ON THE SECOND BEING.
AT MAY REVISE.
RIGHT THIS REPORT CAME OUT I
THINK RIGHT AFTER THE RE RELEASE
OF THE JANUARY BUDGET AND THAT
IS WHY THERE WERE NO RESOURCES
REQUESTED AS PART OF THE BUDGET --
IN TERMS OF THE TIMING HERE WE
ARE AS I SAID EVALUATING OPTIONS
AND WE DO ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE
TO COME FORWARD WITH SOME TYPE
OF PROPOSAL. TO ADDRESS THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AS PART OF THE MARY VISION --
WITH REALLY.
IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT
IT ALSO NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF THE LARGER
STATE BUDGET.
PICTURE AND I THINK THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO DO THAT IS
WHEN THE GOVERNOR CAN CONSIDER
ALL OF THE VARIOUS STATE BUDGET
PRIORITIES TOGETHER.
AS WELL AS THIS ISSUE --
AND DETERMINE WHAT IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO MOVE FORWARD WELL.
I'M SURE YOU RECOGNIZE AS MY
CHAIR OF A BUDGET ALWAYS SAYS
THAT THE THE IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO CREATE THE
BUDGET.
AT THE GOVERNOR ONLY HAS VETO
POWER -- AND
BUT HE CAN'T AT THINGS IN.
AND SO WILL MAKES A VERY CLEAR
HE CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT IS RESPONSIBLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE THE
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE THERE TO
MAKE THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND AND I REALIZE THAT DEADLINES
AND DATES HAPPEN IN TERMS OF THE
GOVERNOR MAKES A STATEMENT IN
JANUARY BUT WE HAVE A WHOLE LOT
OF LETTERS THAT COME TO US IN
THE INTRO.
BEYOND THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDATION.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO'VE MAKING REQUEST STATION.
OF THAT'S THERE AND AND AS I
SAID I YOU KNOW I LOOK AT THIS
IS IS REALLY
A A OF ALL THE THINGS WE'VE KIND
OF HEARD ABOUT PROGRAM TO WORK
AND DON'T WORK AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
THIS IS TRULY A VIOLATION I MEAN
THIS IS REALLY ABUSIVE PEOPLE I
MEAN TO HAVE THIS HAPPEN AND I'M
NOT AND I'M EVEN CONCERNED THAT
HAVING.
A THE RESPONSIBILITY WILL FORTY
SOME ODD YEARS OF DOING
ASSESSMENT EVALUATION FACULTY
AND STUDENT COMPLAINTS AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON THAT ONE I HAVE --
KIND OF PEOPLE INVESTIGATING
EACH OTHER.
AND THEIR FRIENDS.
THAT DOESN'T RISE TO A LEVEL OF
CONCERN FOR ME THAT I WOULD
THINK WITH SOME FROM THE SYSTEM
EVEN IF IF I ONLY HAVE A FEW
COMPLAINTS PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE
EVALUATING.
THEIR FRIENDS AND ASSESSING
THEMSELVES AND AND AND HAVE ME
BELIEVE THAT IS WITH ANY LEVEL
OF OF FIDELITY THAT THAT THIS IS
A GOOD PROCESS THAT THAT SHOULD
BE THERE THAT.
SOMEHOW TO AND AND I KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES IN THE PROCESS OF
DEALING WITH --
YOU KNOW WITH WITH FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN OTHERS WE HAVE A
TENDENCY SOMETIMES EIGHT
INSTITUTIONS KIND OF DISMISSED
THEIR COMPLAINTS OF TO DISMISS
THEM BUT NOT TO GIVE IN SAME
LEVEL RIGHTS AS YOU POINTED OUT
THAT.
THAT THEY'D STILL DESERVE IT
THEY HAVE NOT LOST PLAINTIFFS IN
THIS REPORT OF THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD.
SO I I'M JUST SAYING.
I AS IT TO ME ABOUT IT IT IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A RED FLAG
AS A LOT OF ALARM TO GO OFF WHEN
I READ SOMETHING LIKE THIS --
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE LEVEL
OF SENSITIVITY IN THE
INSTITUTION WOULD BE LIKE WISE
AND WHILE WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE
IT THE GOVERNOR MAY GET AROUND
TO DEALING WITH THIS.
THE REALITY IS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS HEARING IT NOW.
AND HAS TO RESPOND TO IT.
MANAGER IF I IF I MAY I I DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE THIS TABLE.
WHAT WITH THE THOUGHT THAT --
SINCE THE REPORTED IN PRE REPORT
ON POST REPORT THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS AN ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS.
OF BECAUSE WE HAVE AND JUST THE
THOUGHT THAT --
THE INITIAL THOUGHT THAT
INTERNAL STAFF DOING ENQUIRIES
ON THEIR OWN STAFF IS CONCERNING
UHHUH.
SO THAT HAS SINCE CHANGED.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED STAFF THAT
ARE DOING THOSE ENQUIRIES
OUTSIDE OF THE INSTITUTION AND
THEY ARE UNDER THE DIVISION OF
OVERSIGHT THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
PRISON PROPER --
THAT IN ITSELF IS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE --
THERE'S A TRAINING COMPONENT
THAT ALSO THE STAFF MEMBERS. TO
ASK THE PROPER QUESTIONS TO TO
HAVE REPORT WRITING SO WHEN THE
HIRING AUTHORITY OR THE DECISION
MAKER READ THAT THEY KNOW THE
READING A REPORT THIS BEEN.
THOROUGHLY WENT THROUGH THAT'S
BEEN THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATED --
WERE ALREADY SEEN INDICATIONS
THAT --
THAT'S IN A THAT THAT'S THAT'S
BECAUSE IT'S A MEANT BACK
BECAUSE WE TRADITIONALLY WERE
ABLE TO MEET TIME FRAME FOR
THESE COMPLAINTS.
WERE ALREADY MISSING THOSE TIME
FRAMES I DON'T LIKE MISS TIME
FRAME TO WHAT IT'S TELLING ME
NOW IS A DOING A MORE THOROUGH
REVIEW ON THESE CASES --
BUT I JUST DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE
THIS TABLE WITH THE IMPRESSION
THAT WE READ THIS AND HAVEN'T
DONE ANYTHING SINCE NOW I ASSUME
YOU WANT TO READ THIS.
AND THAT AND AS I READ SOME OF
THE OTHER THINGS THAT YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO LOOK AT MY CONCERN
WAS THAT IT THAT IT WAS IN PLACE
IN THE FIRST PLACE THAT.
THAT THE INTERNAL THE
INVESTIGATIONS WERE IN PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE INVESTIGATING THE
FRIENDS AND AND IT WAS KIND OF
AN INTERNAL THING THAT WAS
CONCERNED FOR ME CLEARLY ONCE
THE REPORT IS WRITTEN I KNOW
THAT --
BASED ON THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE AND WHAT HAVE YOU THAT
THING'S GOING TO A THAT YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES NOW.
I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED AS TO HOW
THEY HAPPEN IN THE FIRST PLACE
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE GET TO A
SYSTEM THAT STARTS DOING THIS
KIND OF THING THAT'S THERE AND
AND AND THAT WITH IT SHOULD
NEVER GOT [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIRMAN CONCERN AS AS
RITA POINTED OUT WE FOR A HAD
LETTER AFTER LETTER FOR THE LAST
I DON'T KNOW. TEN YEARS --
POINTING OUT THESE ISSUES --
AND IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO US
THAT THEY GOT IT GETS TO THIS
LEVEL AS WELL BECAUSE THERE ARE
UNKNOWN --
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED WHO
SUFFERED BECAUSE OF IT AND SO --
WE HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT --
ABOUT THIS AND IF BY CHANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T COME FOR
WITH THE APPROPRIATE PACKAGE AND
WE YOU WANT TO DETERMINE.
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE ALLOCATION
SHOULD BE WE CAN CERTAINLY
PROVIDE OUR INPUT INTO WHAT WE
THINK IS NECESSARY TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES IN THE FUTURE WELL
WE ALWAYS TAKE THE LETTERS?
THAT COME IN SO IF YOU HAVEN'T
SUBMIT ONE YOU SHOULD WE WILL
THANK YOU.
ANYTIME BUT YES.
SYSTEM.
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS
AND DISCUSSION IN LIGHT OF THE
DISCUSSION WE JUST HAD YES
BECAUSE IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
RECIDIVISM CARRILLO REALLY
LOOKING AT PROGRAMS THAT WE WANT
TO BE EFFECTIVE WITHIN THE
PRISON. TO IGNORE THAT --
HISTORIC SYSTEMIC.
CULTURE THAT HAS BEEN THERE THAT
THAT IF YOU EVER BEEN IN THE
PRESIDENT I CERTAINLY HAVE IT
GETS TALKED ABOUT SORT OF IN THE
SHADOWS.
AND THERE ARE CERTAIN STAFF DO
YOU SEEM TO BE VERY WILLING TO
DE HUMANIZE SOME OF THE THE THE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE.
SO FOR THE ONE HAND WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT PROGRAM
OVERLOOKED RECIDIVISM WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT THE SYSTEM AND TRY
AND IMPROVE THEIR LIVES ON THE
OTHER HAND WE IGNORE.
THE THE INHUMANE TREATMENTS AND
THE DIFFICULTY THAT SOME OF
THESE PRISONERS HAVE WHEN
THEY'RE INSIDE WHY WOULD THEY
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAMS
WHY WOULD THEY FEEL.
THAT THE CAN.
CULTURE IS CONDUCIVE TO SOLVING
THE ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE SO I
AM GLAD CDC OURS IS SERIOUS
ABOUT THAT A TAKE YOUR WORD FOR
IT AS WELL.
BUT THERE'S ALSO THIS A
SIGNIFICANT CULTURE CHANGE
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TO CHANGE INSIDE SO I
THINK IF THERE ARE PROPOSALS IF
THERE ARE THINGS.
THAT WE COULD AND SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT IT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THEM RIGHT AWAY.
WE NEED TO OUR OUR OBLIGATIONS
OVERSIGHT THIS IS PART OF OUR
OVERSIGHT WE CAN CHANGE THE
AUTHORITIES THAT THE IT HAS WE
CAN TAKE SOME OF THOSE STEPS BUT
IN THE MEANTIME.
IF THERE'S GOING TO BE A
QUESTION ABOUT RESOURCES FINE WE
KNOW HOW TO HANDLE THAT.
BUT IN ORDER TO PREVENT SOME.
MORE CATASTROPHIC EFFECT OF
HAVING.
THE HAPPENING INSIDE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT SIGNIFICANT CHANGES CAN BE
DONE.
EXTRA REVIEWS.
BUILD BACK SOME CREDIBILITY WITH
BOTH WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE BUT
ALSO WITHIN THE POPULATION THAT
YOU'RE SERVING AND MANAGING.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEND THEM
[inaudible] TO TO LOOK AT HOW
THEY CAN ADDRESS THEIR OWN LIVES
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING THEM
TO DO.
AND THEN REDUCE RECIDIVISM GET
BACK IN THE COMMUNITY TO
HEALTHIER WAY.
IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE INSIDE THEY HAVE NO
INCENTIVE THEY'RE AFRAID TO GO
DO THAT SO THESE ARE PART PARCEL
OF REALLY THE SAME CONVERSATION.
THAT WE'RE HAVING AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED REALLY AS PART OF THE
ONGOING LOOK AND BEFORE THIS
WHAT PROBABLY IS IT CRISIS LEVEL
BUT BEFORE IT GETS EVEN WORSE OR
THERE'S ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT
CLASS ACTION SUIT OR SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING.
TO REALLY FORCE US TO LOOK AT
THIS MORE DIFFERENTLY LET'S TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT IT
DIFFERENTLY NOW.
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO SEE WHAT.
WHAT CHANGES NEED TO HAPPEN?
INSIDE BECAUSE IT'S ALL OF OUR
COMMON GOAL. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING AS
RESPECTFUL OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THEIR THEIR THERE FOR A
REASON ABSOLUTELY THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT BY THEIR OWN CHOICE
THAT DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ACCEPT THEM
BEING TREATED AS ANYTHING LESS
THAN HUMAN.
THEY'RE GONNA PAY THEIR DAD BUT
WE HOPE SAYS IS GOING TO
REHABILITATE THEM IT'S GOING TO
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
CHANGE.
FIX WHAT THEY NEED TO FIX INSIDE
A COME OUT AND BE PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
RATHER THAN JUST RUN THROUGH THE
MILL THAT SOMETIMES PRISONS HAVE
THE REPUTATION OF BEING AND AND
SHOWS UP IN ALL WHO
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT.
WHAT WE WHAT WE NEED TO EMULATE?
SO SICK THIS IS OPPORTUNITY
LET'S ADDRESS THESE ISSUES ANY
PROPOSALS ANY THOUGHTS I THINK
THIS COMMITTEES HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN.
BE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT BUDGET
BUT IF WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
ADDING RESOURCES WE HAVE TO HAVE
A LOT OF CONFIDENCE THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE GONNA HAVE A FACT.
AND HAVE AFFECT NOW AND AND LEAD
INTO THE RECIDIVISM CONVERSATION
THAT THAT WERE THAT WERE ALSO
HAVING AND REALLY HAVE THE
IMPACT OF REHABILITATION THAT WE
HELP THE PRISON SYSTEMS.
ARE AND AND REALLY CAMBY.
I AGREE WITH I AGREE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK --
ONE OF THE CHANGES IN THE LAST
BUDGET WAS IN OUR STAFF TRAINING.
AND WE ADDED AN ADDITIONAL WEEK
AT OUR BASIC TRAINING ACADEMY TO
FOCUS ON THE REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS THAT ARE GOING ON IN THE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THAT WAS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT WE WE HAD TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR STAFF AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
POPULATION.
THE ON THE BASIC PEACE OFFER
TRAINING IN THE SAFETY IN THE
COUNTING AND ALL THE ALL THE
BASIC THINGS OF RUNNING A PRISON.
WE HAD TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE WERE
DOING A GOOD YOU WITH THE STAFF
REMINDING THEM WHY THEY DECIDED
TO JOIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION.
SO WITH THAT ADDITIONAL WEEK
WERE FOCUSING ON THE
REHABILITATED REHABILITATION
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
POPULATION AND HOW IMPORTANT A
ROLE.
THAT THE OFFICER PLAYS IN THAT
AND THAT THEY CAN BE A CATALYST
FOR GOOD.
WHILE MAINTAINING SAFETY
SECURITY BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE SAFETY SECURITY YOU CAN'T
HAVE ROBUST REHABILITATION OR
PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE I WANNA
COME.
SORE TRAINING STAFF IN THAT ON
TOP OF THEIR OWN WELLNESS.
FOCUSING ON THAT STAFF WELLNESS
TO WELL THIS PIECE IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AFTER YEARS.
PEOPLE FORGET THE LIFESTYLE THAT
THEY'RE LIVING AND THEY HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
AND IF THEY LOSE FOCUS OF WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THEN --
THEY IN TURN CAN BECOME
DISGRUNTLED DISMAYED AND START
LOOKING AT THIS JOB IS NOTHING
MORE THAN JUST WAREHOUSING
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR
WE ALSO ADDED AN ADDITIONAL DAY
IN THE ANNUAL BLOCK TRAINING
THAT STAFF GET ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AND WE'RE FOCUSING WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL DAY.
THOSE TWO THINGS ALSO REMINDING
THEM OF THEIR REHABILITATION
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT THEN IT
ALSO GIVES A TIME FOR THE
EXPECTATION TO GET GIVEN ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY ABOUT THE ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY IN REHAB --
AT IT IT DIDN'T TO GET LOST ON
ME THE COMMENTERS THAT MADE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT HOUSE SOME OF MY
SOME OF THE STAFF IN THE PRISONS
HAVE BEEN BOUGHT INTO IT.
I TOOK NOTE OF THAT SO WE NEED
TO A BETTER JOB AT THAT BUT I
THINK.
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ADDRESSING
THE TRAIN HERE TO DO MORE THAN
JUST SHOW UP AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE SAME AMOUNT TO INMATES ARE
THERE THAT WERE THERE WHEN YOU
SHOWED UP.
YOU HAVE A REHABILITATION ROLE
AND THAT IS TO TREAT PEOPLE WITH
RESPECT WITH DIGNITY --
TO MAINTAIN A SAFE AND SECURE
PLACE SO PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE
IN REHABILITATION --
I ALSO DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THIS
TABLE WITH WITH THE FACT THAT
I'M NOT AS CONCERNED AS THERE
ABOUT SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
STORES I'M FAMILIAR WITH THEM I
AM TROUBLED BY THEM.
AND I DO WANT --
TO MAKE THEM STORIES THAT WE
DON'T HEAR ABOUT THEM ANYMORE.
AND I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR THAT
AND I I KNOW YOU ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON THIS BUT SOME OF
THE CHANGES ARE GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT IN FACT WHAT I'VE
TOWARD SOME OF THE PRISONS.
THERE ARE SOME OFFICERS THAT
WE'RE ENCOURAGED NOT TO TALK TO
AND THOSE ARE ONES WHO HAVE NOT
BOUGHT INTO THE REHABILITATION
MISSION AND WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
THERE.
AND THEY SEE THAT ROLE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAT'S NOT CONDUCIVE
TO THE CHANGES WE NEED TO SEE IN
THE SYSTEM.
AND TO THE THE THE CHANGES WE
ARE ASKING THE PRISONERS
THEMSELVES TO GO THROUGH FOR SO.
THAT'S WHY I SAY THIS IS THE
SAME CONVERSATION THIS IS PART
AND PARCEL.
TO TO REALLY ALL OF THE ABOVE IF
WE IF WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE
THINGS I I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO BE SOME OF
VERY HARD WORK.
RASKIN PRISONERS TO GO THROUGH A
LOT TO ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THE
CULTURE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
MATCHING THAT LEVEL OF CHANGES
WHILE I AGREE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
JUST.
TO QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
SECRETARY --
SO BASED ON THIS SITUATION.
SORT OF ALLUDED THAT YOU CHANGES
SOME POLICIES CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH THOSE POLICY CHANGES AND
IF.
YOU CAN SURE HOW THOSE WERE
IMPLEMENTED WITH THOSE DONE IN A
IN ORDER IN A MEMO WE'D LIKE TO
SEE A COPY OF THAT AS WELL.
WE WE CAN GET YOU SOME OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHANGES LIKE I SAID
EARLIER.
WAS MOVING THE STAFF COMPLAINT
PROCESS OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON
AND PUTTING IT UNDER.
OUR OFFICE OF OVERSIGHT AND
RESEARCH AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THAT'S REALLY THAT'S UNDER
THE UMBRELLA OF WORLD OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS EXISTS.
SO IT'S OUT OF THE DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS I THINK FOR
THAT FOR US THAT IS --
THAT IS A BIG CHANGE BECAUSE
WHAT IT DOES IS IT.
PUTS A DIFFERENT SET OF EYES ON
THE PRODUCT IS BEING GENERATED.
IT'S OUTSIDE OF THE IN THE END
THE THE THE CONCERN THAT THE
WARDEN CAN DICTATE HOW THIS
INQUIRY GOES ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
IT'S REALLY NOT UP TO SOMEONE
ELSE A DIFFERENT DIRECTOR ALL
TOGETHER TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
THERE ARE NEGOTIATION PIECES
THAT HAVE TO GO WITH --
WE HAVE BEEN IN NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THEM AND AND THEY'VE BEEN
PROMISING.
WERE THERE ANY OTHER CHANGES
THAT THAT WERE DONE.
OUTSIDE OF THIS --
THERE'S A TRAINING COMPONENT SO
WE DID TRAIN THE STAFF AND POST
CERTIFIED COURSES ON
INVESTIGATION WE HAVE --
TRAINING THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
DO.
BUT WE DO HAVE A CERTAIN SET OF
LIEUTENANT TO BODY BENT TO THAT
TRAINING AT OPPOSE CERTIFIED
COURSE WHICH IS BEYOND WHAT WE
TYPICALLY TRAIN ON ATTACK AT THE
PRISON LAW OFFICE SOME.
MAYBE NOT A COMPLETE.
AGREEMENT YEP NO GOOD GOOD
FACIAL RECOGNITION THERE --
YEAH WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE CHANGE THAT THEY MADE OF
TAKING IT OUT OF THE INSTITUTION
AND PUTTING AN END TO THIS OTHER
DIVISION IS ONLY A HALF A STEP
IT'S NOT REALLY SUFFICIENT.
FORCE.
THE BEST STEP IS THEY HAVE AN
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS WHICH
ACTUALLY FOR CASES THAT GO TO GO
TO THEM I THINK EVERYBODY AGREES
DOES A VERY GOOD JOB OF AN
INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE KING
THESE THE TENANTS ARE POSITIONS
AND PUTTING THEM IN THE A A
WHICH AS RITA MENTIONED AS A
SEPARATE TRACK THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT PART OF THE
INSTITUTIONAL CULTURE.
AND THEY'RE ALREADY DOING A GOOD
JOB TO HAVE A GOOD MODEL SO USE
THE MODEL EXPANDED A LITTLE TOO
TO THE INSTITUTIONS.
AND YOU'LL HAVE A MUCH OF BLYTON
BETTER LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS
SOME THAT SECRETARY WHY WHY
WEREN'T THEY BE DIRECTED INTO.
NUMBER ONE THERE THERE IS A
CONCERN FOR THAT LINE EXISTS
BETWEEN IN KOREAN INVESTIGATION.
SO IN CRANE WERE WERE FOR OUR
FACT FINDING WE'RE TRYING TO
GATHER AS MUCH INFORMATION AS WE
CAN TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER WE ARE GOING TO OPEN A
FULL INVESTIGATION FOR WE WE
START PUTTING PEOPLE UNDER --
UNDER BLY BARGER UNDER OATH SO
THEY CAN GET ON TAPE AND RECORD --
FOR US WE WE BELIEVE THAT WE
WANTED TO APPROACH THIS THAT --
SINCE IT IS UNDER THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT RESEARCH THAT
THE TRAINING THAT THE STAFF
RECEIVED AS THE EXACT TRAINING
THAT'S UNDER THAT DIRECTOR --
WE DON'T BELIEVE THE SEVENTH
MOVING AT THE MEANING THE UNDER
SIX EXCUSE ME SINCE THE HOURS
LATE.
HOME.
IF YOU SAW THE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT WRITING IT'S
BASICALLY SAYING SO YOU SO
YOU'RE SAYING THE INQUIRY DOES
NOT TO BE DONE BY INTERNAL
AFFAIRS BUT WHAT WHAT WHAT THE
INVEST.
WHAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
SAID AND FORGIVE ME IF I'M
READING THE CRAFTING CORRECTLY
IS?
THE INQUIRY THAT WAS DONE
[inaudible]
WAS COMPLETELY --
DONE.
BY THE WRONG PEOPLE.
SO SO HAVING THE INQUIRY DONE.
BY THE RIGHT PEOPLE SEEMS TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY.
IMPORTANT SO SO IT IT'S IT
DOESN'T IT IT DOESN'T APPEAR
COMPLETELY THAT --
YOUR INCREASE BEING DONE BY THE
RIGHT PEOPLE.
WELL AS I I DON'T WANT TO SCREW
THIS UP I REALLY DON'T I DO HAVE
WAS DIRECTOR.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
OVERSIGHT IS GAME OF YOUR ROSA
AND IF I HAVE MISREPRESENTED
SOMETHING GAMBLE PLEASE CORRECT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
ACTUALLY THAT'S GOOD EVENING HOW
ALL OF MAKE SURE I PAY.
ATTENTION THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH TIME BUT MISTER DE AS
YOU'VE NOT MISREPRESENTED ANY OF
OUR ACTIONS I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LEAVE TODAY.
IF YOU JUST GIVE ME A MOMENT
HERE TO GO OVER.
ALL OF THE EFFORTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS ACTUALLY
UNDERGOING HAS EITHER.
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED OR IS IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE GRAVITY OF
PORT AND IN FACT HOW WE HAVE
SOME TREMENDOUS CHANGE IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT AT THE MARGINS IT'S
REALLY OVERHAULING THE ENTIRETY
OF THE STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS.
THE FIRST ONE IS STRUCK FROM THE
OFFICE OF APPEALS IN FACT THE
OFFICE OF APPEALS WHICH IS THE
FINAL LEVEL OF REVIEW THEY CAN
WRITE MANY OF THE COMPLAINTS WAS
IN THE SAME CHAIN OF COMMAND IS
THE PRESENCE RUPTURE THE THE
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT'S NOW BEEN MOVED IN JANUARY
THAT MOVED. TO MY DIVISION WHICH
HAS INTERNAL OVERSIGHT THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
FOR THAT FINAL LEVEL TO ACTUALLY
REVIEW WHAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE
INSTITUTIONS AND IT GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE IT BEFORE
HAS TO GO TO A LAWSUIT.
THE SECOND ONE IS REGULATORY
REFORM THE DEPARTMENT IS IN THE
PROCESS OF COMPLETELY CHANGING --
THE STRUCTURE OF HOW FOLKS
RESPOND. TO THESE APPEALS. TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHEN THE
PROCESS OF REDUCING THE REASONS.
NOT FOR REJECTING AN APPEAL FROM
TWENTY SEVEN FIVE THAT'S
SIGNIFICAN IT MEANS THAT IN THE
PAST AND DURING THIS.
PERIOD WHERE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REVIEWED.
IN FACT THE WE DO BELIEVE THAT
WE HAD A PROCESS WHICH WAS
WEIGHTED TOWARD THE REJECTION OF
THE APPEALS.
THROUGH REGULATION WE'RE
CHANGING THAT SO THE GEAR IS
ACTUALLY WORK WORK WORK LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD SO THAT IN
FACT THE INCARCERATED HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THOSE.
APPEALS ANSWERED MORE PROPERLY
DEDICATING STAFF SO TEDIOUS HAS
TALKED ABOUT DEDICATING
LIEUTENANTS BUT ALSO
CORRECTIONAL CANCER TUBES IN
EVERY INSTITUTION.
THEY'RE DEDICATED SOLELY TO THIS
PROCESS.
DIFFERENT THAN PERHAPS BEFORE IN
WHICH THEY WOULD BE HANDED OUT
TO FOLKS THAT DIDN'T HAVE
ADEQUATE TRAINING.
THE ENHANCED TRAINING.
THE TRAINING GOES BEYOND SIMPLY
TRAINING THE FOLKS THAT ARE
ANSWERING THE APPEALS.
WHAT WE INTEND TO TRAIN EVERY
SUPERVISOR THE SUPERVISOR
ACADEMY ON HOW TO PROPERLY
ANSWER APPEALS EVEN IF THAT'S
NOT THE PRIMARY DUTY?
IN ADDITION HIRING HIRING
TRAINING HIRING AUTHORITY SO
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND.
THEIR VITAL ROLE IN ENSURING THE
RIGHTS OF THE POST TRAINING THAT
WAS RECOMMENDED BY INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
IS ON OUR AGENDA IT'S ALREADY
BEEN FUNDED INTERNALLY AND FOLKS
ARE ANSWER THESE APPEALS WILL BE
ATTENDING POST TRAINING SO THAT
THEY FALL MORE IN LINE WITH
PROFESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS.
THE FIDELITY NOT ITS PEACE
COMPONENT.
I I DON'T WANT TO SKIP OVER THIS
TOO QUICKLY BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO PREVENT US.
FROM FALLING INTO ANOTHER
SITUATION SUCH AS AND POINTED
OUT BY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL YOU
VAST RIGHTLY SO WHAT EFFORTS
WERE TAKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE NOT.
IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN
IN THE FUTURE FOR FOR SIMILAR
SITUATION.
BY USING THE OFFICE OF AUDITS IN
COURT COMPLIANCE TO REGULARLY
AUDIT THESE GRIEVANCES WE
BELIEVE WILL HAVE AN INTERNAL
MECHANISM. TO IDENTIFY WHERE
PERHAPS THERE COULD BE FIXES TO
THE SYSTEM BEFORE YOU IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL CAN.
CAN POINT THAT OUT TO US.
ELECTRONIC SUBMISSIONS --
THE DEPARTMENT EXPLAIN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TABLET KIOSK BASS
GRIEVANCE AN APPEAL SUBMISSIONS.
SO THAT INMATES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT THEIR
APPEAL WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS THAT THEY'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT.
CURRENTLY WELL WE HAVE AN
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM IN WHICH WE
ATTEMPT --
TO ENSURE CONFIDENTIALITY THE BY
MOVING FORWARD WE HOPE TO HAVE
AN ADDITIONAL TECHNOLOGY BASED
SOLUTION FOR THEM.
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM --
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CREATING A CHIEF RISK OFFICER
WITHIN THE AUDITS OF OFFICE IN
COURT COMPLIANCE.
WHOSE WHOLE TASK WILL BE TO
GATHER ALL THE STATE OF THAT WE
HAVE IN DETERMINE SOME OF THE
AREAS WHERE --
WE MAY HAVE ORGANIZATIONAL
PROVED MET BEFORE IN FACT IT
TURNS INTO A CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATION OR BEFORE.
THERE'S A BECOMES A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT.
AND LASTLY THE INDEPENDENT STAFF
COMPLAINT INQUIRY PROCESS WHICH
IS RECOMMENDED BY BOTH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE PLO
THIS IS THE SECTION WHERE.
I THINK WE'VE HAD TO BE SOMEWHAT
COOLEY BUT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND BE VERY CLEAR.
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD.
IN CREATING A SYSTEM --
OUTSIDE OF THE INSTITUTION.
THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
IS THE NATURAL PLACE TO DO THAT --
WE AGREE --
IT'S INDEPENDENT IT'S OUTSIDE OF
THE DIVISION --
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL EAT IN HIS
REPORT MADE THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS IS THE CORRECT PLACE TO
DO THAT.
WE'RE WE'RE MOVING FORWARD TO DO
THAT THAT'S WHERE THE RESOURCES
MAY BE NEEDED AND THAT'S THE I
PRETTY VERY CLEARLY THAT IF THE
RESOURCES NEEDED WE SHOULD LET
YOU KNOW --
SOME HERE TO HAVE A THINKS WHICH
ONE IS IT IS IT GOING IN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS NOT GONNA
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
AND IN TERMS OF RESOURCES WHAT
DO YOU MEAN YOU NEED OR YOU NEED
NO NEW RESOURCES.
WHERE'S ALL SAY I MEAN THE ISSUE
OF WHETHER GOING TO TURN AFFAIRS
IN THIS THIS WAR THIS IS WHY I
DIDN'T WANT TO LOCK OURSELVES
INTO.
YOU KNOW THE RESOURCE NAY THAT'S
WHY WE'RE EXAMINING INTERNALLY.
IF IT'S GOING TO GO UNDER
INTERNAL FOR AS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WERE ASKING FOR THE RIGHT
RIGHT RIGHT RESOURCES FOR AND BY
I'M SORRY IF IT'S NOT GOING
UNDER INTERNAL AFFAIRS YOU'RE
SAYING YOU HAVE PEOPLE OUTSIDE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS THAT CAN DO
THIS.
YOU DON'T HAVE PEOPLE IN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS WERE WHY WHEN
SHE MOVED INDIVIDUALS WERE
OUTSIDE INTO INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
SO A LOT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE BIG
WHAT WILL BE ASKING FOR
SUFFICIENT STAFFING FOR THAT
RIGHT NOW WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
FIFTEEN TO TO IF YOU SAID YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED A PROTOCOL AND YOU
HAVE SAID YOU ARE ALREADY MOVE
THIS PROCESS.
INTO THIS INTO HIS DIVISION.
SO HAVE YOU MOVED IT BUT THEY'RE
NO PEOPLE THERE SO THE PROCESS
IS THERE BUT THERE'S NOBODY TO
DO THE WORK THE STAFF THERE NOW
THESE --
THAT'S WHY WOULDN'T YOU WITH THE
SAME STUFF INTO INTERNAL AFFAIRS
GEN OUR WITHIN MY DIVISION.
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT AND COLORS LE
QUESTION YOU CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
THE COMPASS IS MORE THAN SIMPLY
INTERNAL AFFAIRS SOME OF THE
DUTIES CAN YOU ANSWER MY
QUESTION FIRST BECAUSE I'VE I'VE
I'VE WAITED VERY PATIENTLY FOR
YOUR LONG ANSWER.
I'M STILL WAITING FOR AN ANSWER
TO MY QUESTION.
PLEASE ASK AGAIN.
YOU WANT ME TO REFRESH MEMORY ON
THE QUESTION THANK YOU TO SPEND
I WANT TO BE VERY A TEN MINUTES.
IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN YOUR
DIVISION UNDER YOUR PURVIEW.
THERE ARE DOING THIS WORK WHY
CAN THEY NOT BE MOVED INTO A
TOTAL AFFAIRS WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL BUDGET AUGMENTATION.
THEY'RE INSUFFICIENT FOLKS.
CURRENTLY TO WHY BECAUSE I CALL
THEM ONCE INCORRECT.
VACATIONS ONE WHY WOULD YOU HAVE
THEM DO THE INQUIRY TO BEGIN
WITH IF THEY'RE INSUFFICIENT
FOLKS.
IF THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO DO
THE INVESTIGATION WHY HAVE YOU
ASKED HIM TO DO THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THEY ARE CONDUCTING IN COURSE
NOT FULL INVESTIGATIONS WELL ONE
OF THE GIVEN THE NONPROFIT TO DO
YEP IT BUT IF YOU MOVE THEM INTO
INTERNAL AFFAIRS WHY CAN'T THEY
DO THE INQUIRIES WITH AN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
YEAH I I I APOLOGIZE I OBVIOUSLY
HAVEN'T BEEN SUFFICIENTLY CLEAR
BUT MANY OF THE THINGS THAT I
DISCUSSED.
OCCUR NOW WITH IN THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS BUT INTERNAL
OVERSIGHT.
MOVING THE ENTIRETY OF THE STAFF
COMPLAIN PROCESS WHICH IS.
LIKE 720% OF ALL OF THE PROCESS
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING WHY CAN'T YOU MOVE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THIS INTO
A TRAUMA.
THE CURRENT PEOPLE TO DO STAFF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE PRISON
SYSTEM THAT'S NOT THEIR SOLE.
JOB OF THAT IN FACT IS ONE OF
THE SAID BY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL IN FACT THE MAJORITY OF
STAFF COMPLAINTS ARE HANDLED BY.
FOLKS THAT HAVE THAT IS AN
ADDITIONAL DUTY DOCTOR NORMAL
CHRIS OF DUTY FOR THE SO THEY'RE
NOT.
P. Y. SPECIFICALLY DEDICATE YOUR
YOU'RE TELLING ME YOU'RE ASKING
PEOPLE WHO ARE QUALIFIED. TO DO
INCREASED TO DO INCREASED.
THEY ARE THEY HAVE BEEN TRAINED
IN THE STAFF COMPLAINT PROCESS
THE NEW INQUIRY PROCESS THEY
WILL BE TRAINED ON THEY WILL BE
TRAINED IN THIS NEW PROCESS WHEN.
TRAINING ALREADY BEGAN LAST
MONTH WE WILL BE COMPLETE.
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE YOU
TRAIL [inaudible]
UNDER THE THE EFFORT WERE STILL.
TRAINING FOLLOWED WASTING SADDAM
NOT REMEMBER ANYTHING.
THE WESTERN FROM SCRATCH WITH ME
THAT'S A GOOD --
FOLKS THAT WERE TRAINING YEAH
AND THE INSTITUTIONS TO DO STAFF
COMPLAINTS.
THANK YOU FOR TO HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ON HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE.
I THINK WE HAVE ONE SCHEDULE I
ALWAYS GO.
LIKE APRIL MAY.
AND WE'RE TRAINING RIGHT NOW --
EVERY CC TO CORRECT OKAY ALSO
SUPERVISOR.
TO AND EVERY STEP COMPLETELY TO
THAT WE HAVE WHICH IS.
FIFTEEN AND THAT'S THE STAFF
WERE TRAINING RIGHT NOW OKAY AND
AND THE CLASSICAL LONG THE
TRAINING PROGRAM IS.
FOR THE SENATE DISTRICT
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S TAKEN TELL
MADE A TRAIN FIFTEEN PEOPLE.
WITHOUT IS REGIONAL ALLIES
TRAINING GOING TO ALL THIRTY
FIVE PRISON SO I THINK IT'S
EITHER SO THE TRAININGS ROAD
EIGHT MORE ARE MAY I DON'T HAVE
THE CALENDAR WITH ME A WIN IN.
I CAN'T RECALL.
BET BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
ASKING A QUESTION THROUGH MEANS
I'M ASKING THE QUESTION RIGHT SO.
WHY CAN'T THOSE FIFTEEN
INDIVIDUALS BE PART OF THE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS TEAMS?
EVEN WITH A FIFTY INDIVIDUALS
BEING PART OF THE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS TEAMS.
THAT IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO DO ALL
THAT SO I WAS IN THE QUESTION.
QUESTIONS WHY CAN'T THEY BE PART
INFERNAL FIRST I MEAN YOU COULD
TRY IT AGAIN I I'M JUST ASKING
THE QUESTION YOU CAN TELL ME
WHATEVER YOU WANT BUT I'M JUST
SAYING.
CAN I GET AN ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
APARTMENT DID IN RESPONSE TO NOT
ONLY THE IG REPORT BUT WHEN WE
WERE LOOKING AT TO THE IS AT
FIFTEEN OVER INSTITUTIONS WE HAD
WHAT WE CALL CORRECTION COME
THROUGH.
TO AND THAT'S THE FIFTEEN
PRESENCE THERE WERE TWO STAFF
WORK THE APPEALS OFFICE.
AND THEN EVERY OTHER PRISON HAD
ONE QUESTION TO SUPERVISOR.
ACTION TO SPECIALISTS.
BECAUSE WE WERE TRYING TO AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM
WHEN YOU HAVE STAFF WORK THE
SAME FACILITY. TO THE SOUTH
COMPLAINT.
SO WHAT WE DECIDED INTERNALLY
BEFORE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT CAME OUT.
WAS TO TAKE AT THOSE FIFTEEN
PRISONS THAT HAD THE HIGHEST
APPEALS.
THE SECOND COMMERCIAL CANCER TO
SPECIALISTS WE CONVERTED TO A
LIEUTENANT
AND SO FOR US WHAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE SHOT OURSELVES IN THE
FOOT ESSENTIALLY MISTER DE AS
TALKED ABOUT --
WE RUN UP AGAINST OVER DO
APPEALS OR WHAT HAVE YOU IS WHEN
WE TOOK AWAY THAT WORK FORCE FOR
THE APPEALS OFFICE WE CUT ARE SO
SHORT.
WE PULLED THE TRIGGER TO SO AND
SO FOR US TO MOVE THOSE FIFTEEN
LIEUTENANTS OVER.
TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS VERSUS FIFTEEN
LIEUTENANTS AND COVER CONVERTING
BACK TO QUESTION CULTURE TWOS
THE HELP TO THE WORKLOAD IN THE
APPEALS OFFICE.
WHERE WE CUT OURSELVES SHORT?
I'M I'M I'M SORRY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEEK WE HAVE.
TO CLEARLY WE'RE NOT ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTION AND I I I I KNOW
THAT THE BASIC QUESTIONS WHAT
WHY DON'T WE JUST MOVEMENT AYE
INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
AND AND THEN WHAT THE THE THE
BIGGER QUESTIONS RIGHT YOU YOU
YOU YOU CAME HERE AND YOU SAID
IN A DOCTOR DOCTOR I'M I'M NOT
I'M NOT GONNA REPEAT WE TALKED
WEBER SIR BECAUSE SHE ALWAYS.
SPEAKS MUCH MORE ELOQUENTLY THAN
ALL OF US I'M JUST GOING TO ASK
THAT THE QUESTIONS.
WHICH IS.
YOU SAY YOU ARE AS TROUBLED BY.
BY THIS AS WE ARE.
AND I'M JUST LOOKING FOR A
REACTION THAT REFLECTS THAT SAME
LEVEL OF CONCERN.
SO I GUESS TO SAY THAT YOU WERE.
ASKING FIFTEEN PEOPLE DOESN'T
QUITE WE HAVE WOMEN WE GOT TO
THE NEXT QUESTION.
WHICH IS WHAT HAVE YOU DONE IN
SALINAS ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION.
YOU GOT ALL THESE COMPLAINTS YOU
GOT THIS INVESTIGATION THAT WAS.
COMPLETELY.
IT INADEQUATE NOT EVEN THE RIGHT
WORD BUT WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN
THEY'RE SO.
STICK IT ON THE FIRST LINE OF
QUESTIONING WHICH IS.
HOW DO YOU ENSURE?
THE PEOPLE'S NOT ONLY CIVIL
RIGHTS BUT THEIR HUMAN RIGHTS TO
BE PROTECTED AND THEY HAVE AN
PROPER.
THEY HAVE A PROPER COMPLAIN
PROCESS AND THAT THERE'S A
PROPER.
I GUESS INQUIRY ENDED
INVESTIGATION.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE.
THE PROCESS THAT YOU ARE SAYING
HAS YOU'VE TAKEN A HUGE STEP.
IS AND I'M GLAD I'M NOT GONNA
PUT WORDS IN MY MOUTH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OR THE PRISON
LAW OFFICE BUT THEY CAN CHIME IN
IF THEY WANT.
TO DOESN'T SEEM. TO PASS.
THE SNIFF TEST.
OF THEM [inaudible]
AND SO.
I'LL JUST SAY THIS IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE YOUR **** TROUBLED OR
AS CONCERNED AS WE ARE.
SO.
EITHER YOU CAN FIX IT OR WE WILL.
I THINK I GOT THE PROMISE.
RIGHT NOW I UNDERSTAND SO THEN
THE BASIC CORE QUESTION AS TO
HOW SOON CAN YOU COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
WITH.
A PLAN.
AND I DON'T THINK NAY IS FAST
ENOUGH.
BECAUSE ANYTHING BECAUSE IF YOU
COME IN MAY AND WE DON'T LIKE
YOUR PLAN THEN WE WILL REJECT.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
BRING IT BACK SOONER SO WE CAN
COME TO SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
AGREE ON OTHERWISE DOCTOR WEBER
IS ENTIRELY CORRECT.
THAT IF THIS COMMITTEE.
SEE SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T
LIKE IT WILL NOT BE IN THE
BUDGET.
OKAY.
THESE ARE VERSION OF SO WHAT WAS
THE QUESTION OF YOU CAN HOW SOON
CAN YOU COME BACK.
BY THE END OF THE MONTH END OF
THE MONTH END OF MARCH.
OKAY SIR THANK IS THAT OKAY
DOCTOR WEB SOUNDS GREAT SO WITH
SALINAS WHAT HAS BEEN DONE.
SO YOU YOU HAVE THIS
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
COMPLETELY [inaudible]
BUNGLED.
BUT CLEARLY THERE'S PROBLEMS SO
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE IN SALINAS TO AT LEAST TRY
TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS.
MANY OF THESE.
SOUNDS LIKE FAIRLY HORRIFIC
INCIDENTS THAT WERE --
WERE CARRIED OUT.
SECOND ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION.
I WANTED THINGS WE'VE STARTED AS
DIRECTOR OF YOUR ROSA SAID IS
THE TRAINING OF THE STAFF.
AND SO I SALINAS VALLEY THE WORD
IS CURRENTLY USING ONLY STAFF
HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO DO
INVESTIGATIONS AND HAVE THOSE
TECHNIQUES AND BE ABLE TO SET UP
TO ENCOURAGE CORRECTLY.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN LOOK REALLY
RESTRICTED TO A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF PEOPLE DOING THEM WE'RE STILL
WORKING TO GET ALL OF OUR STAFF
TRAINED TO PROPERLY.
THROUGH -- I
ATE BUT IS SOME OF THE STEPS
THAT THE WORD HAS TAKEN VERSUS
HAVING. TWENTY DIFFERENT STAFF
DONNA WHO HAVE NOT BEEN I THINK
THE NEW PROCESS PROCESS IN PLACE
THERE'S NEW COMPLAINTS.
THERE'S CLEARLY A PROBLEM I
DON'T I DON'T I DON'T NEED TO
HAVE ANOTHER YOU KNOW FIVE
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION TO SEE THAT'S A
PROBLEM TO BASED ON THE EAST
THIS PROBLEM.
WHAT WHAT IS BEING DONE AT THE
PRESENT TO ADDRESS?
WHAT SEEMS LIKE SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WHAT WHAT ACTIONS HAVE
BEEN TAKE?
WELL WE'VE HAD A CHANGE IN
LEADERSHIP WITH THE NEW WARDEN
THERE SHE'S BEEN THERE.
MAYBE SENSE I THINK ONLY ONE
PERSON.
NO THE WARDEN HAD BEEN THERE OF
SHE'S GOT IT.
ACTING DEPUTY WE SENT IN A
MENTOR RETIRE WARDEN IN THERE TO
HELP MENTOR ALSO.
SO AND WE'VE ALSO GONE IN WITH
SOME RESOURCE TEAMS PREVIOUSLY
AND SINCE SOME FOLKS IN THE HELP
WORK MARKET AND WORK THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO WORK WITH
SALINAS VALLEY THE WARDEN THERE --
TAKE THIS REPORT VERY SERIOUSLY
SHE'S VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WELFARE OF HER AND MAYES THERE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HER
FROM HAVE A HEADQUARTERS
PERSPECTIVE.
NOW I I FULLY APPRECIATE YOU GOT
A LEADERSHIP CHANGE --
HOW DO YOU?
HOW DOES YOUR TEAM GO IN THERE
AND?
ASSESS SORT OF CULTURE CHANGE
WITH THE TEAM [inaudible]
AS IT IT'S GREAT THE WARDEN SPOT
IN BUT YOU GOT A TEAM.
THAT PERHAPS IS NOT PART IN SO
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
WORK THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT I
KNOW DOESN'T HAPPEN OFTEN I
APOLOGIZE TO SPEAKING OF NOT AT
ALL.
SOME OF WHAT WE'RE DOING ISN'T
WORKING AND THE RETIRED AND KNOW
WHAT TO MENTOR THAT WE HAVE IN
THERE.
IF ONE THEY STARTED WITH
SUPERVISORY MEETINGS WITH
SERGEANTS AND LIEUTENANTS.
BECAUSE WHERE YOU REALLY GET
YOUR BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IS
DIRECTION FOR THAT PRESIDENT.
THIS IS ALSO DOING TOWN HALL
MEETINGS WHERE OFFICERS HERE.
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR WHO HAS
OVERSIGHT OF THEIR PRISON MAKES
FREQUENT TRIPS DOWN HERE AS DOES
THE DIRECT W. DIRECTOR WHO WAS
JUST HERE RECENTLY.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO VISIT IN
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT SHE'S DOING HER.
TOWN HALL MEETINGS WITH HER
STAFF THAT SHE'S MEETING WITH
HER SERGEANTS AND LIEUTENANTS TO
REALLY GET THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE.
THEY'VE GOT TO DO BUSINESS
DIFFERENTLY.
AND WE'VE GOT TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR JOB IS TO
PROVIDE A SERVICE TO THE
POPULATION WHO LIVE THERE.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
BASED ON THESE --
SORT OF NEW IMPROVE IMPLEMENTED
PROCEDURES HOW HOW WILL.
HOW WOULD YOU GET FEEDBACK THAT
YOU'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION?
I HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT --
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE MEASURE THEN
YOU CAN RESPOND OKAY.
AFTER PROVIDING THE TRAINING IN
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW PROCESS.
A PART OF THE ONGOING --
RESTRUCTURING INCLUDES THE
OFFICE OF APPEALS ACTUALLY GOING
AND DOING LIVE OBSERVATIONS OF
THE APPEALS PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS ARE.
HAVE BOUGHT IN THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY --
TREATING THE IN MAY TWO MAINLY
IN.
ALL OF THE INTENDED.
OUTCOMES ARE CURRY --
THEY'RE NOT FROM THE SAME
DIVISION THEY THEY'RE GOING FROM
MY OUTFIT DO THESE OBSERVATIONS
AND COME BACK WITH RESULTS AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHETHER
NEEDS TO BE.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING OR
DISCIPLINARY.
AND HOW ABOUT WHEN ARE THEY
START TO GO DOWN AND THEN WILL
YOU START TO GET SOME FEEDBACK
OF SOME RESULTS WELL THE
TRAINING.
BEGAN LAST MONTH THAT'S GONNA
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS --
DURING THAT SAME PERIOD WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FOLKS FROM MY SHOP
THEY'RE GOING TO ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THEMSELVES SO THEY CAN
FUNCTION THAT CAPACITY THAT
MENTORING CAPACITY.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT IN A BUT
WHAT IS YOUR TEAM YOU MENTIONED
YOUR TEAM'S GONNA GO DOWN INTO
SOME OBSERVATION MAKE SURE THAT.
THINGS START TO CHANGE A TARGET
FOR THAT WAS --
THE BEGIN TO THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR SO JULY.
JULY OF THIS YEAR SO JULY.
NINETEEN CORRECT OKAY SEE SO YOU
WON'T HAVE ANY.
YOU'RE YOU'RE IN THERE YOU'RE
DOING TRAINING YOU'RE YOU'RE
TRYING TO ASSESS BUT YOU WON'T
HAVE ANY.
FEEDBACK INTEL.
JULY OF NOT WHAT JULY THAT YOU
WHEN YOU GONNA GO DOWN THERE
THAN WOMEN YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME.
DATA AND SOME RESULTS WHICH OF
THE QUICKLY BUT IMMEDIATE
ACTIONS THAT WE'VE TAKEN IS THAT
THE WORK GROUP SO WE'VE PUT
TOGETHER INCLUDE FOLKS THAT --
TRADITIONALLY SO JUST JUST TO
STICK WITH MY IF YOU COULD JUST
STICK WITH ME FOR ONE SECOND SO
JULY YOU'RE SENDING PEOPLE DOWN.
YES.
AFTER YOU SEND PEOPLE DOWN WHEN
WILL YOU GET --
THE REVIEWS BACK FROM THAT.
HEY.
THINGS ARE GOING RIGHT THINGS
ARE NOT GOING RIGHT THINGS SEEM
LIKE THEY'RE THE MOVE IN THE
THOSE REVIEWS --
MEDIA SO THE WEEK AFTER THEY GO
DOWN HAVE OUR FIRST SET OF
INFORMATION TO FROM WHICH TO ACT
OKAY SO SO SOMETIME IN JULY WILL
HAVE A SENSE OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE ACTIONS HAVE.
BEEN APPROPRIATE.
THE TRUE BUT BEFORE THEN WE'VE
ALSO ENGAGE THE OFFICE OF THE
OMBUDSMAN AND OUR WORK GROUP --
IT AND THEY COME BACK WITH
FEEDBACK AS WELL WE HOPE THAT
BECAUSE THEY ARE PRESENT
THROUGHOUT ALL THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE IF THEY
SEE CHANGES OR I THINK IT WENT
BY THE TO THE WORK GROUP AS WELL
WHEN WILL WE HEAR BACK FROM THE
ON BUTTON.
AT WHICH I ENGAGE AND RARELY
HAVE MEETING EVERY TWO WEEKS --
REGARDING THIS TOPIC.
SO THEY'VE ALREADY STARTED GIVE
YOU FEEDBACK.
THEY HAVE AND WHAT'S THAT. ONE
OF THE SENATE WELL THE FEEDBACK
HAS.
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON THE
TRAINING COMPONENT --
THEY ACTUALLY REVIEWED THE
CURRICULA ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO
TRAIN FOLKS --
AND NOW THAT THE TRAINING IS
STARTING I HOPE TO SEE FEEDBACK
TO MOZILLA THEY'VE BEEN PRESENT
AT ORIGINAL TRAINING.
THE SECURE BUT THERE IT'S AT THE
OMBUDSMAN JUST REVIEWING THE
TRAINING THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY OBSERVING TO SEE.
IF SAY HEY THESE FOLKS TOOK THE
TRAINING AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING IT IN THEIR EVERYDAY WORK
THAT'S TRUE BUT THEY RECEIVE
COMPLAINTS OBVIOUSLY FROM AN
MAYES THROUGHOUT THE THE STATE.
OKAY AS A HOW THEY'VE BEEN
RECEIVING COMPLAINTS TO FROM
SALINAS.
THAT'S I'VE NOT RECEIVED
FEEDBACK WITH REGARD TO SALINAS
IN PARTICULAR [inaudible]
HAVE YOU.
WHEN THE OMBUDSMAN'S GO OUT THEY
TYPICALLY GO IT IS A MONTH TO
DIFFERENT PRESS AS AND THE CHIEF
OF THE CHIEF OMBUDSMAN WILL DO
ME A ROLL OF OTHER REPORTS?
SO YES WE STILL GET SOME
COMPLAINTS OF SALINAS VALLEY AND
I THINK --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE SAID IT TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE TO CHANGE
THAT I NOW MAKE TAKES TIME IS
NOT OVERNIGHT PROCESS.
BUT I GET A WEEKLY WE ROLL UP
FROM THE OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE OF
ANY ISSUES THAT THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED IF THESE TOWARD OUR
PRE PRESENT THAT PREVIOUS WEEK.
AND AND SO ON HAVE HAD THE HAVE
THE COMPLAINTS IN SIMILAR OR
LESS SEVERE I I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE RIGHT.
WAY TO ASK THE QUESTION IS AT
THE MEAN.
THIS IS A LIFE.
THE SAME KIND OF COMPLAINTS WERE
SEEN HERE ARE THE SORT OF MORE
MINOR COMPLAINTS BUT WHAT I
TYPICALLY SEE FROM THE OMBUDSMAN
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T ASKED ME IN
PARTICULAR OF OR HAVE THEY
PROVIDED ME ANYTHING WITH
THERE'S ALLOCATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT.
IS USUALLY EITHER AROUND THE
INMATE DIDN'T GET SOME THAT HE
SHOULD HAVE HAD COMING OR
THERE'S A PROPERTY ISSUE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR IN THEY
DIDN'T GET RELEASED ON A PROGRAM.
SO I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM
THEM IN RELATIONSHIP TO WHETHER.
INMATES HAVE ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT AS RELATES TO
USE OF FORCE OR OTHER ISSUES.
WITH THE ITS INMATES GO TO THEM
WITH THOSE KINDS OF COMPLAINTS.
YES THEY DO ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN SAN
CONFIDENTIAL MAIL TO THE
OMBUDSMAN ALSO AND WHEN THE
OMBUDSMAN'S ARE OUT AN
INSTITUTION.
THERE ARE OTHER INSTITUTION FOR
AN ENTIRE WEEK.
AND SO THEY WALKING THE TALK
WITH THE POPULATION.
IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO
ASK THEM SPECIFICALLY THAT
QUESTION I GET IT BACK TO US
WHETHER THERE IS ADDITIONAL.
YES I CAN DO THAT --
MY SUGGESTION IS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS INVITE
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO GO IN
AND DO A FOLLOW UP --
TO SEE.
IF ANYTHING DIFFERENT HAS
OCCURRED.
IS IS IS THERE A REGULAR FOLLOW
UP PROCESS TO YOUR REPORT NO NOT
IN THIS REPORT IN.
OTHER REPORTS THAT WE DO.
WE GET A CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE IT'S
PART OF OUR JURISDICTION TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TO THAT AREA.
IN THIS INSTANCE WE WERE INVITED
IN TO LOOK AT THIS PROBLEM.
AND THEN ARE.
WE HAVE NO JURISDICTION.
TO ASK FOR CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN OR TO GO BACK AND LOOK TO
SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING SO I HAVE
NO VISIBILITY ON WHAT'S ACTUALLY
GOING ON THERE NOW.
SECRETARY TIAS AND I HAVE HAD.
A NUMBER OF DISCUSSIONS.
BUT I HAVE NOT HAD ANY
DISCUSSION WITH HIM ABOUT LONG
CREEK FIXES FOR WORKER FOR THE
ISSUES THAT WE WERE SO MISTER
SECRETARY HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
FOLLOW UP BY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
I DO NOT I WOULD LIKE FOLLOW UP
I KNOW THAT --
THE ONLY G. DOES HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO RECEIVE CONFIDENTIAL
LETTERS FROM AND MY POPULATION
THERE IS A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER POSTED IN.
EVERY HOUSING UNIT AT THE
PRESENCE OF THE GIVEN DIRECT
ACCESS TO THE O. I. G. --
I HAVEN'T HEARD AND ROY YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF IF YOU RECEIVED.
COMPLAINTS OF THIS NATURE SINCE
YOU'VE LAUGHTER LE BECAUSE THAT
AND I KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE USE.
IF THERE ARE CONCERNS LIKE THAT
YOU DO COME TO US WITH THEM.
YES IN FACT --
STAFF MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS ARE
THE NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT WE
RECEIVE ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT SINCE SINCE THE O. I. G.'S
SINCE THE REPORT WHAT WHAT'S IT
LOOK LIKE.
FOR LETTERS AND PHONE CALLS I
THINK SINCE THE REPORTS COME OUT
WE HAVE SEEN A DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS I THINK.
MY HUNCHES THAT THE INMATE
POPULATION IS WAITING TO SEE.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS BECAUSE?
OF THE FEEDBACK WE GOT WHEN WE
SHOWED UP WAS DIDN'T REALLY
COMPLAIN TO US MUCH BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY FAITH THAT
ANYTHING WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
[inaudible]
ALSO.
AFTER THE REPORTS COME OUT I
KNOW THAT MISTER SPECTER'S HAD
DISCUSSIONS HIS STAFF HAS HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH.
WITH --
THEIR CLIENTS.
AND I THINK THAT.
NOW EVERYBODY'S IN KIND OF A
WAITING.
PATTERN TO SEE A HOLDING PATTERN
TO SEE WHAT COMES OUT OF THIS.
WHAT WE ME WHAT MY MY PERSONAL
PREFERENCE IF YOU'RE AGREEABLE
IS THAT?
THE TWO OFFICES CLOSER TOGETHER
AND DEVELOP SOME FOLLOW UP PLAN.
IF IF THERE IF THERE ISN'T A
FOLLOW PLAN DEVELOPED I MEAN I'M
SURE THAT WE CAN.
REQUEST THE SPEAKER WE HAS
INTEREST ROW ROW AND I'D ME
QUITE REGULARLY AND WE WE
COMMUNICATE QUITE REGULARLY AND
ONE OF THE LAST CONVERSATIONS
WAS AS WE DEVELOPED I DID COMMIT
TO HIM WOULD BE SHARING AT ALL
ALL THE PLANS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED SO WE SELECT WE DON'T.
TALK.
I UNDERSTAND THAT I THINK THE
QUESTION WAS IS REGARDING
SALINAS WHAT ARE NOT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SHOULD FOR
ONLY WOULD YOU BE WILLING.
TO HAVE THE OFFICE TO DO ANY
FOLLOW UP SPECIFICALLY.
WITH THE SALINAS SITUATION SO
YOU SEE YOU HAVE THE ABOUT THE
PERSON YOU HAVE THE TRAINING YOU
GOT JULY COMMON.
SO THE QUESTION IS WE WHAT WHAT
WHAT ABOUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WOULD YOU.
BE INTERESTED IN HAVING THEM.
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK TO TYPICAL FOR
US WHEN WE HAVE OUR AUDITOR. TO
REPORT SOME YOU JUST HEARD THE
AUDITOR EARLIER ALL UP WITH THE
AUDITOR BASED ON WHAT THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE FOUND THAT
THAT'S A PROTOCOL WHICH ARE
GONNA BE FOLLOWED WITHOUT AUTO.
SO THE QUESTION IS IS WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHICH WOULD
YOU LIKE THE OFFICE --
MORE FURTHER INVOLVED AND YOU
KNOW IF YOU DON'T WE WE MAY WANT
TO HAVE THE OFFICE MORE FURTHER
INVOLVED THAT TO SEND YOU TO
TALK MAYBE RYAN I DEFINITELY
MAKE WITH THE THE TOPIC OF THE
MEETING THIS WEEK.
PERFECT AND IF YOU COULD REPORT
BACK TO US SO WE'RE I MEAN WE'RE
AROUND NEXT WEEK. ONE OF THE
ISSUES I HAVE TO BRING IS THE
SAME ISSUE THAT MR TIAS BROUGHT
HIS THAT ARE.
BECAUSE THIS IS A PART OF OUR
OUR STATUTE OR NOT RESOURCE TO
FOR THESE KIND OF ONGOING THINKS
NOW I'M.
OBVIOUSLY WILLING TO GO BACK AND
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK.
AND DO THAT BUT THAT IMPACTS
OTHER WORK THAT WE DO.
BECAUSE FOR EVERY HOUR I HAVE
SOMEBODY DOING THIS OR NOT DOING
SURE THE WORK THAT THAT THE
NORMAL THAT'S A SEPARATE
CONVERSATION YOU NEED TO HAVE A
DOCTOR EVER SINCE.
IN OF THE CLINIC YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS ANYONE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR MATTER.
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
DON'T HAVE ONE PERSON.
GREAT OKAY THANK DR NORMAN SCOTT
NOT I TEACH CRIMINOLOGY
SOCIOLOGY OF LAW CHICO STATE.
BUT FOR THIRTY YEARS I HAD A
CAREER IN RESEARCH --
IN CORRECTIONS MOST OF IT WAS
WITH THE YOUTH AUTHORITY BUT FOR
AWHILE AFTER I'M SORRY WE
COMMENTS SO SINCE IS ONLY TWO OF
YOU.
IS THAT RIGHT.
YEAH OKAY WOULD YOU EACH GET TWO
MINUTES SIR OKAY [inaudible]
ANYWAY -- I
WAS OUT WITH THE FORMER YOUTH
AUTHORITY AT THE TIME OF THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE YOUTH
AUTHORITY AND CDC ARE.
SHALL I A WAS WITNESS TO SOME OF
THE DIALOGUE AND SO FORTH IT WAS
HELD AT GALT AND SECRETARY
HICKMAN AT THE TIME.
I DID A BIG --
PUSH ON TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE CODE OF SILENCE
[inaudible]
AND I REMEMBER SITTING IN THIS
CROWD OF I DON'T KNOW FOR FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AND KIND OF SEE THE SNICKERS AND
OVER HEARING THINGS IN THE MEN'S
ROOM AND WELL IT IT WAS AN UP
HILL BATTLE AND I DON'T KNOW IF
MUCH MORE HAS BEEN DONE ABOUT
THAT EVERYONE.
HAS TO SIGN A STATEMENT SAYING
THAT THEY AGREES TO IN A REPORT
ON STAFF MISSED CAUGHT MUST
CONDUCT.
BUT THEY DON'T.
AND MADAM CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE --
NIGHTMARE IDEA WHAT GOES ON THE
PRISONS.
IN TERMS OF MOVIES WHEN PEOPLE
ASK ME I SAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
MOVIES.
IS ALL TOO TRUE.
NOW SOME PRISONS ARE WORSE THAN
OTHERS.
MOST CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE
DECENT PEOPLE.
BUT THERE'S FEAR EVERYWHERE.
AND IN THAT FEAR GOES INTO
CENTRAL OFFICE AS WELL.
FULLER FREDDIE TO RAT ON
SOMEBODY ELSE AND IT CAN BE --
FOR FIT THEIR PHYSICAL SAFETY.
IT CAN ALSO BE MORE LIKELY THEIR
CAREER.
AND I FOUND OUT THIS.
PERSONALLY --
WHEN I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
EVALUATION?
OF THE BEHAVIOR MODIFICATION
UNITS HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON.
AND SEVERAL OF US BROUGHT BACK
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE. TWO
CENTRAL OFFICE.
AND WE SAID ALLEGATIONS WE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T EVEN BELIEVE A
LOT OF IT.
ALTHOUGH SOME OF IT WAS
SUBSTANTIATED WITH MEDICAL FILES
THAT WE WERE GIVEN.
BUT WE QUICKLY REALIZED THAT.
NO ONE WANTED TO HEAR THAT.
AND THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RETALIATION AGAINST ME
I RETIRED EARLY BASICALLY
BECAUSE OF IT BUT I JUST WANT TO
SAY IS THERE IS A WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOW IS IS JUST ONE INSTANCE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT THERE'S YOU
KNOW THESE KIND OF SITUATIONS IN
EVERY PRISON ALL THE TIME.
BUT THEY HAPPEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND NOTHING EVER REALLY SEEMS TO
BE DONE ABOUT IT.
HI I WAS INVOLVED IN THAT YOU
KNOW ISSUE INTO HIGH DESERT
STATE PRISON A FEW YEARS LATER
THEY HAD ANOTHER ONE UP THERE.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S JUST IT'S IT'S
REALLY FRUSTRATING.
AND AND I'VE BEEN WORKING I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF THE AMERICAN
FRIENDS SERVICE COMMITTEE FOR A
FEW YEARS.
AND I SEE HOW HARD THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING TO TRY TO DO THINGS BUT
IT'S REALLY SLOW.
IT'S IT'S A TREMENDOUS.
FORMIDABLE TASK TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE CULTURE
INSIDE.
THANK FOR MENACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER ON JIM
LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA --
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
I GUESS I'M QUALIFIED --
ON ACCOUNT OF THE FACT THAT --
OUR ORGANIZATION SENDS A
NEWSLETTER OUT. TO ALL THE
PRISONS AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
WE GET AN AWFUL LOT OF MAIL.
UP FROM PRISONERS AND OVER THE
YEARS --
WE'VE JUST ABOUT COMPLAINTS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT.
BUT USUALLY THE OVER ARCHING
THEME.
IN THESE LETTERS TO THESE
COMPLAINTS TO US.
IS THAT --
PRISONERS DON'T FEEL THEY HAVE
ANY MEANS OR OR PROCESS --
TO DEAL WITH THESE COMPLAINTS
AND UP YOU KNOW WE DON'T DO CASE
WORK IN OUR OFFICE OUR FOCUS IS
LEGISLATIVE --
I WAS HERE WHEN HEARINGS WERE
HELD A ABOUT THE CODE OF SILENCE --
WITH -- BY
SENATOR GLORIA ROMERO --
SENATOR JACKIE SPEAR --
I WAS INVOLVED --
IN NORTH MISTER SCOTT IT INTO
THE LEGISLATURE --
AFTER THE INCIDENTS AT HIGH
DESERT --
BACK IN --
TWO THOUSAND TEN THAT HE MADE
PEOPLE AWARE OF AND I'M SORRY TO
SAY.
THAT I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
THERE WAS REALLY LEGISLATIVE
INTEREST AT THAT TIME.
AND AS A RESULT THAT HAS
AFFECTED MY ADVOCACY.
AND IN FACT TODAY I DID GOOGLE --
HIGH DESERT --
AND INCIDENTS OF STAFF MISS
CONTACT A TRYING.
TO REFRESH MY MEMORY ABOUT WHEN
I BROUGHT --
MISTER SCOTT OF TO THE
LEGISLATURE BACK THEN AND A
WHOLE SET OF NEW INCIDENTS.
POPPED UP ON GOOGLE OF OF THINGS
THAT IT HAPPENED --
AFTER THAT OKAY BUT I I THINK
THAT THE THING THAT.
CONCERNS ME THE MOST --
IS THE IMPACT THAT THIS DOES
HAVE ON THE PRISON CULTURE --
IT'S BASICALLY TELLING PRISONERS --
THAT THEY DON'T MATTER --
THAT THEY HAVE NO RIGHTS AND SO
THEN WHY WOULD THEY BUY INTO --
THE EFFORTS THAT WE'RE MAKING --
HERE TO TRANSFORM THE CULTURE
AND MAKE PRISONERS PRISONS UP
MORE REHABILITATED.
THEN PUNITIVE ARE YOU AUTHORED A
BILL COUPLE YEARS AGO AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY WHICH THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ACT.
WHICH SAID THAT THE PURPOSE.
OF OF SENTENCING WOULD BE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AS OPPOSED TO WHERE IT ALWAYS
SAID --
PUNISHMENT --
SO I I JUST THINK WE'VE.
STILL.
GOT A LONG WAY TO GO BUT WHEN I
SAW THIS ON THE DAILY FILE AND
IS INTEREST --
IN IN IN THIS ISSUE AGAIN IT IT
REALLY --
MADE ME WANT TO COME FORWARD --
BUT I I DO THINK THAT IT THAT --
THESE INVESTIGATIONS I DO HAVE
TO BE CONDUCTED OUTSIDE OF THE
NORMAL --
PRISON ENVIRONMENT --
WE NEED TO PUT CREDIBILITY BACK
IN INTO THE PROCESS SO THAT
PRISONERS WHEN THEY HAVE.
LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS NOTED THAT
THERE IS SOME DUE PROCESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THAT --
THERE'S NO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THE THINK WE'VE HELD HER THE
FOUR ISSUES OF THE TH REALLY
THREE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE --
TO THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US --
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
WE'LL HEAR BACK FROM THE
INTERESTED PARTIES --
AS WE LOOK AT THE ISSUES THAT
ARE THERE IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
LETTERS OR OR IDEAS THAT YOU
THINK WE NEED TO CONSIDER AND
THIS PROCESS WE DON'T WANT TO
LET THIS JUST SIMPLY.
GLOSS OVER AND GO FORWARD --
BUT WE WANT TO SEE WHAT WE CAN
DO --
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN TO MAKE CHANGE
IN THE SYSTEM AND TO CORRECT
SOME OF THE ERRORS AND NOT JUST
SIMPLY UP --
LET THIS MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
ANY INTERVENTION WELL FOR YOUR
INFORMATION FOR YOUR COMMENTS
THANK THE AUDIENCE FOR COMING
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR HANGING
AROUND THIS LATE IN THE EVENING
AS WELL --
BUT THE OBVIOUSLY THE
CONVERSATION IS WELL WORTH IT
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH IN THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU